I'm scuffed too, don't worry.
Woah, I don't even see him.
Yeah, I don't see you, Gerard.
Where are you?
Are you in the right lobby?
I'm in the wrong lobby.
I sent you to go.
Look at Discord DMs.
They're gonna start this without you.
Oh no.
It's in...
Oh, Gerard.
Are you in?
Gerard?
I think I am.
I'm team number 8 right here.
Yeah, but do you see me in Flame?
Do you see me in...
I think you're in the wrong lobby, Gerard.
I think you're in the other lobby.
I don't think you're in lobby A.
This is the code.
I also sent him the code too.
I think he's in lobby B.
I don't know.
Doki...
I don't know about today, man.
My teammate can't get in the lobby.
Her teammate can't get in the lobby.
I also porn.
Did you say you just also porn your game?
How do you join lobby B?
How do you do that?
There's literally one code.
How do you get lobby B?
Wait.
Where did you get to lobby B?
I don't even know how you could access lobby B.
I only see lobby A.
Where are you?
I alt-F4.
Wait, I'm going to launch the game.
You're alt-F4?
They started abruptly.
I couldn't leave.
Wait, they started?
How did they start?
I don't know.
We were supposed to start two minutes ago.
It wasn't me.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
We're so scuffed.
They're like, we're never inviting the English speaking team again.
I didn't mean it!
Oh god.
This is turning out so fucking horribly.
This is like the sign.
I think we're the 20th place in doors.
No, 19th!
19th!
Any team that's below us should be ashamed of themselves after that.
Wait, Troy, are you in?
I'm opening the lobby.
There we go.
Are you still in the wrong lobby?
I don't see you.
Private match.
Okay.
Join match.
Oh my god, there you are.
I'm going live right now.
There you are.
Apologize right now in the chat.
Tell them you went to lobby.
I'm live now.
I clicked go live.
Okay.
Oh, they're starting right away.
They're starting right off.
Okay.
Okay, this is like three minutes late.
So you're going to get this in three minutes chat.
But Gerard...
Gerard actually joined lobby B.
Lobby A.
Also, like, I don't know how loud my teammates are.
So if they're too loud, we'll figure this out after the game.
Oh my god, immediately after starting the fucking tournament, I already fucked up.
No!
Gerard, where's Gerard Piquin?
Gerard Piquin left, Gerard Piquin left!
Piquin, Piquin!
What happened?
Jesus Christ, hello everybody.
Welcome to the stream.
Today I'm joined by Strafing and also DokiBurn.
Hello everybody.
God, this is such a bad start.
Jesus Christ.
We might be coming 20th place today, but at least we'll have fun.
If we get to winner's bracket, we don't have to play another set.
Just saying, I'm just saying.
If we get top 10, we don't have to play another six.
Oh, it is the official!
This is not my fault, this is all Doki's fault.
You invited me last minute!
You said yes, you said yes.
By the way, I asked Gerard, like...
You said yes, but I didn't think...
I was like, what do you mean?
I explained everything so perfectly clear.
I'm on here.
Guys, loot!
It's time to loot!
I'm joining, okay, okay.
I'm looting, I'm looting.
Mastiff is still strong, right?
Okay.
We're fine.
Okay, for those who don't know, Flame, he's our pro player and he went to ALGS championship.
And so, we believe in him so hard and there's no pressure at all.
I don't believe in myself right now.
We got you, we got you.
You gotta believe.
If you don't believe in us, who's gonna believe in us?
Yeah, who is?
There's no one else but us!
I don't know.
I think the worst part is that you could have just not ulted for it.
It's a different team, I didn't know!
They started rolling, I'm spamming leave button and they wouldn't let me.
I panicked, okay?
I panicked, I didn't know what to do.
I must have took somebody else's spot and I felt so bad, I panicked, I'm sorry.
Wait, that means someone else was late.
Yeah!
Someone else was late, you took their spot and they started because of that.
Dude, everyone's names were like fucking Japanese.
Why do you think that's us?
I mean, I saw it!
I saw it!
IGL, where do you think zone's gonna end?
I don't know.
Wait, you're not the...
Okay.
We will have console.
We have the people ring, but we can't scan that yet.
Nah, we can't.
We have to pick between the UAV or the console.
So where should we go?
I think we're going to Barrow here so we can hit the console.
If we go into Echo, we won't have enough to get blue.
Alright.
We have to be a little bit slow.
Don't be in the front, Gerard.
I can take him.
Be in the middle between us.
Let's go over here and do the spiders.
We have to wait for Barrow to rotate out.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright, Gerard.
I need you to be in the middle.
Actually, no, you can be in the back.
It'll be fine.
I think I'll be the best.
Do you want me to do the spiders now?
Yeah, we can do the spiders.
I'll do the spiders now then.
Alright, yeah.
I understood what happened.
I understood what you guys said.
Totally fine.
Shoot the spiders.
That's all you have to do.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm doing great.
I'm shooting the spiders.
Yeah, that's good.
I'm so proud of you.
Oh my god, I think we can make it.
I think we can make it to the finals, bro.
I think we can get...
At least one knock.
That's my goal.
At least one knockdown.
Or at least a shot.
I never actually hit anybody.
Oh, no, you shouldn't.
Let's be realistic with our expectations here, Gerard.
Don't aim for something you can't...
Gerard, Gerard, come back.
Get this helmet.
Blue helmet.
I'll watch over him.
I'm going to shoot the dragon.
Okay, there we go.
Also, chat, I told...
I told Flam that I haven't touched Apex in two weeks, but instead I touched Marble Rivals, so my aim is still good.
Dang.
I'm envious of what you guys have.
The last time I touched this thing was during tournaments only.
Yeah.
I'll open it.
I'll get it.
Someone needs to sit up top and just look around.
Yeah, Gerard, just sit up top.
Okay, if you die, just scream.
There's like...
I'm always screaming.
That's like the only thing I can say.
Just scream at us if you die.
Sure, sure.
I'll try my best.
Do you want me to do Swift Shield or Heal's Hustle?
I don't remember which one was the right pick.
I think...
Swift Shield.
The one that gives you better cooldown.
Yeah, it increases the cooldown?
Okay.
I know there was a team here.
I think they rotated out already.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think they rotated really fast.
Alright, tell Gerard what to upgrade.
Oh my god.
Car, car, car.
Shoot the car, shoot the car.
Oh, they're really far.
You want to come to us, Gerard?
That's why they don't see you.
I'm on my way, I'm on my way.
I'm so far away.
I cracked one, I cracked one.
Great job team, great job team.
Yeah, it's all team effort.
That's good, that's good.
I believe in you.
Moral support, moral support.
Alright, good job, Gerard.
You were there.
Yeah, I was there.
Moral support.
Without me, you guys are nothing.
Just saying.
Gerard, would it be fucked up if I packed your scope from you?
Do you have a scope to run?
Scope?
Uh, yes.
Do you?
What scope do you have on?
Wait, where'd it go?
I just threw it on the floor.
I know, where the fuck did it go?
Yeah, that's fine, that's fine.
Let's just go, let's just go.
Let's just go, guys.
Take it, oh my god, it's right on the floor!
Gerard, that's fine, that's fine.
I'm gonna shoot this dragon.
Take it, take it, take it.
Here, take it, take it.
Thank you very much, Gerard.
I'm gonna die anyway!
Where are they?!
Let's go over here.
We'll rotate into launch pad here.
Wait for ring three and then maybe go up here.
I believe in you.
Yeah, yeah, keep on believing.
We gotta be careful of the left here, yeah?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There might be a team coming up.
Uh...
I think we'll go back to spiders.
We didn't finish spiders, did we?
No, wait, did we not?
Oh, we must have missed one.
Yeah, we left the spider.
I mean, we're gonna go back anyway.
What does it do when we kill all the spiders?
We get more armor points.
Oh, okay.
There's people there, there's people, there's people!
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
There is people there.
Don't worry, we got this.
We got this.
These guys can aim.
Oh yeah, well, we can aim.
Look at me.
They're pushing up, they're pushing up.
I got them!
Just heal, just heal, just heal.
He's one, he's one.
Yeah, I distracted him.
Distracted him.
Give me on the rock.
He's one, this guy's one.
He's getting shot behind, he's getting shot behind.
He got knocked, he got knocked.
Gibby's still here, he's still down here.
I'm getting a side angle.
He's good, go, go, go, go!
I'm pushing this.
Don't worry, don't worry, don't worry.
I think we got backup, the other team's pushing up.
The other team's pushing up.
Make sure you're behind cover.
Get behind cover.
Just heal, just heal, droid.
Press Q.
Okay, that's fine, I can ulti you whenever.
I'm checking, I'm checking them.
Um...
There's a team right here, there's a team right here.
I can throw a Q.
Just run over here.
I'm trying to cover you.
That's fine, you're fine, you're fine.
Just heal, just heal, just heal, just heal.
I'll cover him, I'll cover him, I'll cover him.
That's fine, that's fine.
Just full heal, full heal.
You're doing great, you're doing great.
Doing great, doing great, surviving so far.
Where do we go?
Should we go back to the inn?
Let's just go here.
Just run, just run.
Come with us, come with us.
There's a team that did ring over here.
I saw the notification.
Okay, alright, alright.
Okay, they just rezzed.
I think that's the team that we killed.
We're gonna hit this console here and then try and make our way into zone.
Do you want me to get stronghold or ultimate savior?
The castle wall or regen?
The shield regen.
Alright, tell Jiraiya what he needs to do.
Oh wait, you're not purple yet, so you're fine.
I have no idea what you just said.
It's okay, just listen.
Just listen.
I'm trying, but I don't know fucking shit.
You're doing great, you're doing amazing.
You're doing so well.
It's fine, it's fine.
I believe in you.
Just calm down, breathe in.
Just fast, fast, follow me.
No hesitation.
No looting, just follow me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, just follow him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, here, do you need shield?
Here, take a bat if you need it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'm over to mid, okay?
You might have to shield me here.
I'm not sure if it's safe.
I think it is.
Yeah, I think it should be okay.
Alright, I'll cover you.
I think you'll be fine.
I think you're fine.
We have a three minute delay.
What stream sniping would they do?
What?
They would, they would.
I don't know, we'll find something out.
I'm going to poke them.
We're just going to sit here and look behind us for now.
I'm poking them so they won't...
You guys just double sit on the rock there.
And look over.
I'm checking my right side.
Okay.
I only have 100 ammo for light.
So I'm going to try and see if I can find more light.
Here, here.
Shoot it, shoot it.
They're not going on it.
Shoot it up, shoot it up.
Yeah, they couldn't get it.
Where are they, where are they?
I have the Lifeline 50, we can get these kills here.
Yeah, they're rotating.
Yeah, just shoot them.
That's a blue zipline, we can shoot that zipline.
Oh my god.
Okay, I need a reload.
Oh my god, he's so low.
He's so low.
He has Lifeline.
No.
I almost cracked him.
Gerard, careful, you're in the open.
It's fine.
They lost meds though for it.
We might still be able to kill this team if there's nothing over at these houses.
Yeah.
Come here, Gerard.
Just one fucking hit, I swear to god.
Just one hit.
I've done nothing.
I'm gonna open this bin for us.
Yeah, there's people over at the building, we just have to chill.
Oh, there's like health pack and bat.
I'm looking to my right.
We're gonna be playing through an evac here.
And we're gonna land like kind of in the middle of ring here.
Okay.
One of these spots, and then you just have the new castle like slammed on us.
Alright, yeah.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
You'll be fine, I believe, you're so healthy.
Yeah, I'm healthy for now.
Let's do it a little bit early, maybe.
How much light do you have, Doki?
I have...
I have 102, but Gerard has more light ammo.
So I can moosh off of him.
I'm giving you 40 here.
I'm gonna throw these bats.
So you can take them if you want it.
Okay, come to me, guys.
Yeah, I'm here.
I'm just carrying everything.
Yes, ma'am.
Yes, sir.
I got everything.
Follow us, follow us.
I have to throw a Q for our...
Just hit this right away.
Just follow us, just follow us.
Fly right and then left.
Just follow...
Land right here in this red corner here.
Yeah, and then I'll...
Other corner, other corner.
It's safe.
Do I need it all?
What?
Don't worry, don't worry, don't worry.
We don't need him, right?
It's okay, it's okay.
How?
Don't worry, don't worry about it.
They're running towards me.
We just have to relax.
Okay, just relax.
We need to look out for replicator drops here.
Okay.
Have a replicator land somewhere near us so we can try and craft it.
Yeah, I have rez on me too.
We're just chilling for now.
Your valuable teammate is right behind you.
Gerard, it's time.
It's time for you to learn today.
Don't worry, we can pick it.
We're not last, Gerard.
We're not last!
That's great, great progress.
Way better than last time.
Really great.
I'm looking.
As expected, I'm the first one to die.
I don't have an angle.
At best, I can shoot the roof.
Yeah, let's just pray for them.
Pray for them, everybody.
They're doing so great.
Thank you for the morals.
Thank you, Gerard.
We really appreciate it.
Fine, fine.
I'm looking.
They're all doing so great without me.
I think I'm beginning to think that I'm the one holding them down.
No, no, you're like our moral support.
Oh yeah, you're right, you're right, you're right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
On this rock here, Lifeline.
Yeah, I see.
I don't see them though.
They're fighting up here.
Should I look?
Or do I want to stay here?
Stay, stay, stay.
Ooh.
I have a lot of bats though, if you need any.
Yeah, we're okay for now.
If they fight over at the left here, we have to try and wrap the third.
Okay.
I'm looking.
I think we have to go.
Come, come, come.
Go through the bottom.
I think I heard someone healing on me.
Uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
No.
Okay.
Stay in the corner.
I'm gonna swap this.
We just keep wrapping left here, I think.
Okay.
Team right here.
Joe, Joe, Joe, Joe, Joe.
Do we go back to our corner?
I think we just move over to this corner.
No, no, no.
We go over here.
Just run and climb.
Run, climb, run.
You okay?
I'm looking for you.
Don't drop resins here.
Good job, good job, good job.
I have ult, I have ult, I have ult.
Stay in that corner.
We need to walk into this close side of the zone on the left here.
I agree, I agree with whatever you said.
I'm pretty sure there's another team over at the right.
I'll stay here, I'll stay here just in case.
Wait, no, they're fighting, they're fighting.
Go, go, go, go.
On me.
One, dead.
On my right, on my right.
There's more teams coming.
Yeah, we have to chill.
Careful, careful.
It's a full team and a solo.
Full team and a solo.
We have to kill this full team.
I'm healing, I'm healing.
I'm all here.
I'm pushing the truck.
Kill the guy.
I get there, I get there.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
It's fine, it's fine.
Just play your life, play your life.
What the fuck?
I slammed and then I...
I got slammed back.
Oh god, oh man.
I believe in you to play your life.
That was a crazy slam that they did.
Okay, Strafing, you got this, Strafing!
I believe in you, Flame.
You...
You're so good at this game, Flame.
We're not last because of you, Flame.
Just remember.
Okay, okay, okay.
We gotta let him think.
These guys focus up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
What the fuck was playing Mirage?
Nice.
Nice, nice!
Nice!
Oh my god!
You're so awesome!
You're so great!
He's insane.
He's actually insane.
Nice, nice, nice!
I think that's the only team in front of you right now.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Nobody knows.
Do they still have the highlight on?
This is nerve-wracking.
Dude, there's so many people.
There's so many people around you.
There's so many shooting at you.
Oh wait, no, no, no.
Okay, no one's shooting at you.
Oh my god.
This team under me has to die though.
Don't worry, they must die.
There's no way they're gonna let them rotate so free.
They're at the bottom.
Oh my god!
Nice, nice, nice!
Shit!
Oh my god, there's another team walking to your right.
Oh no.
They all want a piece of you.
Oh!
Oh, this is rad!
You're just staying low!
Great, seven squads remaining!
In between enemies!
Just inside the ring!
Nobody knows this!
Shh, shh.
He's gotta listen to the sound.
He's gotta listen to the footsteps behind him.
Oh my god.
I hope your skin blends in with the leaves or something.
Amen.
Amen, amen!
Oh my god, the catalyst!
Oh my god, top six!
Holy shit!
Top six!
Oh my god!
Top five?!
Top five!
We're getting carried so hard!
I'm getting carried so hard!
No, Flame, don't do it!
Don't do it!
They're so distracted, they can't see you.
They don't know.
There's no way they'll know.
There's no way.
They won't push.
Oh my god, there's a shield right behind you.
Oh my god, the shield!
No fucking way!
You get a free shield!
That's crazy!
Free shield, free shield, free shield!
You get a free shield!
Let's fucking go!
They're peeking!
It would be so fucked up if the shield just took that wall away.
He just takes that wall away after that.
Can she do that?
She can, yeah.
Oh my god!
I hope they got...
I hope she's down or something.
Or she doesn't notice, I hope.
She doesn't notice it's like her own wall.
Oh, nice, nice!
Cracked!
Oh my god.
That was insane!
Oh wait, I think you might...
I think she noticed!
Oh god, oh god!
She might know it's her wall.
Wait, they're getting pushed.
There's a Gibraltar right above them.
Nice, nice, nice, nice!
Oh no, they got the full kill though.
You're right.
You got both angels on your shoulders.
I think you can do this.
See guys, this is the difference between a pro player and us.
Us regular folk.
Oh, just top two.
You can do this.
Get that top two.
No.
Oh my god, oh shit!
We're not pushing him?
Oh no.
We know you exist now.
Oh no!
They knew your existence!
I haven't done anything.
Look at my awesomeness!
You gotta be fucking kidding me!
Oh my god!
I can't believe it!
I would like to give a special shout out to my boy Gerard.
For hyping you up!
It's a shout out!
No need, no need!
I don't need that fucking shout out after a terrible performance!
No way!
Oh my god!
Congratulations to the team that won!
Holy crap!
That wasn't my main!
That wasn't my main.
I could have done a better job if that was my main or something.
This was stage.
Warm up.
That's crazy.
It's not crazy!
It isn't!
I'm just warming up you see!
Yeah, I believe you Gerard.
Warm up, warm up!
His stress level is like at...
Okay, what's more stressful?
This or anal GS?
All of them!
Every single time that I'm here it's just fucking stressful!
Yeah, yeah.
No, flame, flame.
What's more stressful, flame?
What's more...
What's more stressful right now?
Unfortunately, in LGS at least I have teammates.
Oh damn!
Oh!
We got you covered though!
You wouldn't have made top 3 without our moral support.
Oh my god!
Just a little bit harder, but you know.
I did my job though, flame.
Didn't I do my job?
Hey, I shielded everybody in the first one!
Okay, I shielded everybody.
I healed somewhat.
Yeah, I was there.
You did great, sweetie.
Shut the fuck up!
Don't say that to me!
Okay, I actually need help on this one.
So apparently, my stream delay isn't working.
So how do you do that?
Okay, you gotta stop stream.
Stop stream.
And then...
Go to advanced.
And then put 180 seconds for your stream delay.
In OBS settings?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then they have to wait 3 minutes until the go live button comes up on YouTube.
Okay, okay, okay.
Is it on stream?
Yeah, it's on advanced.
It's on advanced settings.
So you go to settings, and you go to advanced.
Uh-huh, okay.
Advanced, and which recording, stream delay...
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
And it's like 180 seconds.
Yeah.
Okay, 180.
Guys, there's no...
There's no way we can be last place with that now.
There's no way.
We have enough points to like...
To not be 20th place now.
To not be 20th place.
That is correct.
We did it.
Okay, so I'm restarting my stream.
Yeah, and then you have to wait.
You have to wait until the button goes live because it's literally doing a 3 minute stuff.
So as soon as 3 minutes pass, you can go live.
Okay, alright.
There you go.
Now you learn how to do stream delay.
I don't know when you'll ever use that again.
No, I will never use that again.
Now you know.
Wait, you're not trying to be an ALGS pro?
Yeah, you don't want to be an ALGS pro after that?
Aren't you inspired after Flame's performance?
Don't you want to get better at Apex after that?
No, I think I want to focus more on Marvels because that's my shit right now.
Wait, Flame, have you played Marvel Rivals yet?
No, I haven't played that much.
Wait, you haven't played that much?
No, I played like a few games.
Maybe 5 games or so.
Oh, so you haven't got addicted yet.
The moment you touch rank, it's over for you.
It's so over.
When I did Quickplay, I was like, this isn't that competitive.
I'm alright.
But then the moment I touch rank, it hooks you.
I think it's just the same, right?
It's just the addiction kicks in because you get more competitive and then you just like to see your numbers go up too.
Where are your mains?
I'm just supporting main.
I mostly do Luna, Mantis, Cloak, and Raccoon.
Luna!
Luna's my fucking favorite.
She fucking dances and becomes immortal for like 3 minutes or something.
They ban Luna now.
So when you get to Diamond, they start banning your characters because Luna's too powerful because everybody lives forever.
They just ban Luna now in the beginning.
So you can't even play Luna.
So there's like character banning?
Yeah, there's hero bans like League.
Oh god.
Because I was like Luna one trick and then I got to Diamond and they start banning Luna so I actually had to learn other characters.
I had to learn other characters in fucking Diamond.
I'm really envious of you.
You're able to play Marvels, man.
I'm so fucking busy with everything.
I can't even.
We finally had perm for that but I still can't play it.
At least he didn't watch other people and live vicariously through us.
Soon, soon I'll be able to play it.
Maybe, I hope.
Okay, I hope that was enough 3 minutes.
I hope so too.
Alright, we're fine.
We're totally fine.
We can do this again.
You know, not totally doing spiders was such good bait.
Unintentionally.
We didn't get a kill.
It was so smart.
But we got kills from it.
It was such a good unintentional bait.
Yeah.
Did great.
I'll loot this side then.
I'll loot the back.
One of you guys need to hit the blue bin.
Yeah, I can hit it.
Go wherever you're at.
Yoink.
I can hit it for us.
Don't worry.
Cause I don't think Gerard knows what the fuck the blue bin is.
Of course I don't.
It's kind of silly that you still assume I know stuff.
Exactly.
That's why I said I'd do it because I know you don't.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You do it.
For those who don't know, also like Huge shout out to Gerard for you know coming clutch because he literally got in like today.
He's a bronze rank.
I think he's the lowest rank in this lobby.
Yes, I am.
Dude, I'm not even bronze.
I think I'm just rookie level.
I don't think I'm like qualified at all for this type of thing.
Anything to help.
No, I believe in you.
I believe as well.
I'm like support so I don't need to run batteries.
I can just use shield cells.
Yeah, but you still want to pick up batteries so you can give them to me.
Yeah, that's true.
Gerard can pick up batteries so he can give it to you.
Not me.
He's the...
True, true, true.
Doki, can you grab the cash over at the right there?
Yeah, I can.
I got a flatline here if you guys want.
I'm okay.
I'm going to run the 30-30 instead of the...
30-30 is still good.
30-30 is good.
I thought you were talking about the triple take.
I'm not going to lie.
If I could find a triple take but I haven't found one.
Triple take is actually like...
The best gun so far.
I don't think I've seen one.
I've only seen...
We want to leave now.
Alright, I'm handing over to you.
I'm going to evac us.
Okay.
Alright, Gerard, come here.
Come on, Gerard.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
How is it that I don't have anything?
I don't have any...
We want to just be at this house here, I think.
Just follow us, Gerard.
Just follow us.
Don't get triple take.
We have to go house.
Just don't get triple take.
Just go inside here.
We can shoot this guy on the zip.
No, I don't think I can make it in time.
That guy is crazy.
Gerard, can you...
Don't be in open.
It's not bad here.
Can you throw a health drone on me, Gerard?
Yeah.
Press Q.
Gerard, give him health drone.
Gerard, you got this.
I'm trying, I'm trying.
There we go, there we go.
Yeah, I can.
There we go.
It's fine.
See, he's learning.
I'm learning, I'm learning, I'm learning.
Big steps, Gerard, big steps.
Yeah, big steps, big steps.
Are you seeing a sniper stalk?
Let me know.
Yep.
There's a triple take here.
Oh, nice.
I'll take that, actually.
I actually got purple heavy mags.
I don't know if...
Okay, I have a...
There's more energy ammo.
You have to be really careful from behind you.
They look down at us.
I know.
I have a purple heavy mag.
Oh, Gerard, you can stay inside.
Stay inside, Gerard.
You want to stay inside and just look around?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, just stay inside.
I'm worried for you, so...
Okay, alright, okay, fine.
I'm like setting up my stream.
That's why I'm a little bit quiet.
Okay, there we go.
Yeah, just stay inside.
Just stay inside, don't go out.
I'm inside, don't worry.
I'm a good boy.
I'm staying inside.
There we go, there we go.
Are you seeing more energy ammo?
Let me know.
I only have 72.
I have 64 here.
54, 54.
Someone need that?
No, I'm fine.
I need any of these.
Any attachments for a triple take?
Yeah.
I have lots of them.
Listen, Gerard.
Try and keep an eye out on just east here.
So there's like spiders.
Yeah, like right there.
That team.
Just look out for it.
Yeah, I'm looking.
Just look here.
Alright, just shoot.
They're flying south.
I think they might be going for the building next to us.
Yeah, they are.
I'm looking.
Okay, I'm looking.
I'm doing my job.
This team, we don't like...
We kind of want to make sure they don't push us.
Uh oh, enemy here.
I think I see someone here.
Okay, nice.
Good call.
Oh, wait.
I don't have a scope, so I can't see anything.
There's a 3x scope here that I can bring for you.
Give me a little bit.
Are you okay with a 3x?
Dry, are you fine with a 3x or no?
3x, uh, sure.
Alright, um...
I'm looking for you.
Yeah, so you can use to look.
They're rotating, they're rotating.
They're rotating now.
They're rotating this building.
Yeah, they're rotating to the bottom.
They might fight.
I don't see them going inside, but they went this way.
Yeah, I saw.
No, they're not fighting.
I think we're just chilling.
We'll just get a bunch of ammo.
Oh, yeah, they're inside.
That's fine.
They're fighting here at the north.
Okay, I'm looking behind us just in case.
I need a heal.
Full heal.
Let me know if you need me to help poke.
Because I'm looking at the team in front.
I think try and look with me here, Doki.
Have Gerard look at the angle.
Look behind, look behind.
Look at this area.
Okay.
Oh wow, they're shooting over.
Which angle do you want me to look at?
Enemies here, enemies.
Let us know if they're pushing.
I don't have an angle here.
They're up top here.
I see them.
They're getting pushed back, yeah.
Yeah.
I'll look back with Gerard.
Alright, they're not pushing us, right?
Oh, they took away our door.
I think that has a Rampart.
Yeah, they do.
Oh, someone's shooting.
They're pushing up a little bit.
Oh wait, no, no.
What characters do they have?
They have Rampart, Valkyrie, and I think Gibby.
I'm not sure.
I'm not sure if they have Gibby, but...
I'm gonna purposefully...
I'm just watching the door.
You need to arrest me, like, right away.
You want to arrest me, like, right here in the middle.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Close,
close, close!
On us, I think.
Yeah, on us!
Place ult, place ult!
Just hold up top.
Throw a castle wall down.
I couldn't.
They pushed me.
Oh my god, why did they push us?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Is that a different team?
Oh my god!
I did 14!
That's so great!
Big, Jirard, big.
That's an improvement.
That is an...
They died for that!
I did so great!
Jirard, that's an improvement, Jirard.
We're going up!
We're going up there!
Going up!
Eventually!
Oh god, we got sandwiched hard!
No, yeah, no.
I don't know why they pushed that.
That's like, such a weird push.
Oh man.
They went so fast, I couldn't put down my ult.
The best I could do was just put my Q down.
Yeah, that's rough.
I think the team, oh my god, they've just been 1v3'd.
Yeah, what the fuck?
They just pushed us, just carred in.
They just boosted into our house.
They just all in'd it.
Oh my god, they all in'd that shit.
That's crazy.
Damn.
I think it's out of lifeline.
I think that's...
Yeah, you just put down the walls, and then that's...
Yeah, I think we have walls blocking the door.
I need some actual strats here.
I need some actual strats.
In order to improve my survivability.
So all I have to do is stay with all of you, right?
Yeah, yeah.
So we're gonna put you on Rampart.
Have you ever played Rampart before?
Yes, I have.
All we want you to do is just put walls down at a door, and then just survive.
Okay, alright, good enough.
At least I have some sort of experience.
Also, how many walls does Rampart have?
Because I don't remember.
Three.
She can have three just on her, but she can place down five.
Okay, so...
So you just make sure you can place five...
You just tell him where to place his walls, and he should be fine.
Okay, okay, alright.
I believe in you.
Yeah, okay, alright.
You still believe in me after everything that happened?
Look, that wasn't on you.
That was just... we just got pushed.
That was literally not on you.
We could not do anything about that.
Okay, alright, alright.
I've been apologizing.
This is the last time I'll apologize.
Last time.
Flame was like getting shot.
Wait, what even was your strat there?
Like...
So if you get res'd, everyone gets a hundred evo points.
So the strat usually in comp is to just get knocked with your armor off, and then have your new cast flame to res, and then you can pick up your armor, and you heal like full health, you know?
Yeah, so we were trying to do that strat, and then we got pushed because you were already low.
That's so unlucky.
If only I knew.
If only I knew that.
My god.
What would you have done, Gerard?
I'm the one that has to res it.
You just have to watch.
What would that information be for you?
I don't know.
I guess you could have watched the door while we were trying to do this.
Just watch the door.
Yeah, if we do that again, you just watch your surroundings to make sure no team does that to us again.
Okay, alright.
Got it, got it, got it.
That's fine, that's fine.
I'm sort of getting like the rampart gameplay here, because the majority of the players that we've been up against are like just using her shields.
Yeah, okay.
Gerard, are you spectating their rampart right now?
Uh, no, I'm Gibby.
Okay, so you should spectate their rampart.
Okay, learning, learning.
Just doing my homework now.
Five armor swaps.
Okay, alright, alright.
Just learn what she's doing.
Analyze her.
Do a VOD review right now.
We're literally VOD reviewing right now.
But not your VOD.
We're VOD reviewing this random rampart.
Oh my...
During the tournament?
I could've...
I should've done this before the tournament.
Or did a warmup or something.
Wait, it's okay.
I played one game of Marble Rivals before the tournament.
I'm so locked in.
Also, maybe Flame, for you, don't play Marble Rivals, because like I actually got a couple of pro players addicted to Marble Rivals.
Is it nocturnal?
No, it's effect.
Oh, no.
What have you done?
I was like, hey, have you ever played Marble Rivals before?
And then I made him download the game.
And then he messaged me today and he's like, Doki, it's bad, I'm addicted.
The game is good!
It's not my fault if Elias doesn't do well.
It's not my fault.
I just wanted people to play Marble Rivals with me.
Alliance is number one off.
I appreciate you, Doki, taking out the competition.
I might have to give you a cut of our prize pool.
Griefing Alliance.
Unintentionally Griefing Alliance.
Unintentionally.
Details, details.
Flame, flame, flame.
Have you ever played Marble Rivals?
I've played a few games.
But he hasn't got to rank yet, so he's not there.
He's not there.
Because that's what happened to Effect.
I made him play Quick Blit and he's like, oh, it's pretty fun.
And now he got to the rank part and now it's over for him.
So for the sake of your career, you should not get into Marble Rivals.
I mean, there is competitions based on marbles, right?
I mean, there is like a tournament, so maybe.
My teammate is literally playing in a Marble Rivals tournament.
Oh, wait, who?
Which teammate?
He's been scrimming with a team in there.
They already have a full stack.
Oh, Player K.
I heard there's like a lot of tournaments going on right now for Marble Rivals.
I mean, it's literally an Overwatch tournament, so.
Oh, yeah, yeah, that's right.
That's right.
The game is made by NetEase, so you know they have a lot of money to throw into Marble Rivals, right?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
They have a lot of money to throw into it.
Alright, are you watching the ramp part?
Yeah, I am.
I'm literally watching it right now.
Build that wall and you just shoot.
Just shoot through.
If you had that wall, you could do times two of that damage.
So instead of fourteen, you would have done twenty-eight.
If I was just behind a wall, I would have done twenty-eight damage.
Great.
That's literally times two.
Okay, I'm going to double.
Next goal?
I don't know how far we're going to go.
Double that and give it to the next person.
Literally, for real.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God!
He's cooking!
Gerard, you could totally do that, too.
Next time, next time.
I'll definitely.
Can you still give turrets to other people?
Or is it locked again?
Okay, Gerard, you put your turret on the ground.
Okay, Gerard, when you get your ult, put your ult on the ground and then me and Flame will do that.
I mean, as long as people can use it, then sure.
Yeah, yeah, we can use it.
Easy enough.
I hope this team dies before they get top ten.
It'll be so funny.
Dude, I never usually think about team compositions mostly.
I just, like, choose whatever, what character I want.
Yeah, yeah, but now it's the big league.
It's the big leagues now.
I can't believe these are the type of things that you're, like, supposed to be prepared for, man.
Oh, no.
I've never been into a tournament.
This is, like, my actual legit tournament.
Because in the customs, we were just fucking around.
This is a legit experience.
You're learning so much now.
You're learning the other side of gaming.
Watching Flame, like, holy crap.
Oh, yeah, I know.
That was crazy.
Maybe, just maybe.
I'll give it a dabble.
But not gonna lie, after the customs, I did kind of have a craving again for Apex.
Just a little bit.
Yeah, because it was just so fun.
Yeah.
It was just so fun.
That's why I joined Apex through a tournament style in customs.
I know, like, for a lot of pro players, rank has just been really boring lately.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, is it?
You gonna say that again?
Yeah, like, because it's just Yeah, what happens?
Does it get boring after hundreds of hours?
Because it's not competitive enough.
Or there's, like, hackers.
So there's not Oh, yeah, you're right.
You're right.
Because, like, if you queue into a pred lobby, you don't get mostly pros.
You get, like, diamonds and plats.
So, like, it's just mowing lobbies down.
Oh.
You don't actually it's not really competitive, competitive.
From my perspective, I think it's way too competitive.
Like, for me, because it's already too aggressive.
You're a little baby.
You just have to keep on fighting.
You're literally learning the game as we go.
Guys, I think we can get top 10, guys.
If we get another top 5, that has to give us top 10, right?
Yeah, so then, if we get top 10, we don't have to wait, no.
It probably won't.
Top 10 is gonna be around like 30 points.
And I think we got we got, like, 12 points.
We got 12?
So we just need another we just need another 18 points.
Yeah, yeah.
I believe in us.
You're technically two people.
So, like, we're a full team.
You're right.
He's just made up of two people.
But we're still a team of three, technically.
If we add you, me, and Gerard, we're three people.
You're gonna just take these insults, Gerard?
Come on, man.
Stand up for yourself.
14 fucking damage, bro!
Gerard, you did 14 more damage than you did last game.
You know?
Yeah!
Stand up for yourself, bro!
More damage than you did last game.
Stand up for yourself, Gerard.
Yeah, Gerard!
Come on, Gerard!
I can't do shit, man!
Okay, okay.
Next round.
Okay, what should Gerard say?
What should Gerard... like, you should coach him.
What should he say back to me?
He should say, Shut the fuck up, Doki.
I'm better than you.
Oh, so he should lie.
He should lie.
I'm way better here.
I'm way better.
Like, I'm hiding my true power, actually.
Start the delusion.
Actually, you're kind of right about that one.
Delusion starts everything.
Yeah, fake it till you make it, you know?
Yeah, yeah, fake it till you make it.
What the fuck is this?
What the... Oh my god.
That is a crazy push right there.
Rampart, you can do this!
Rampart!
Oh, this Rampart's good, though.
I know, just hopping in and...
What is he doing?
What have I just watched him do?
Yo!
I got the Rampart slowly clutching it.
Oh my god!
What?!
Bro!
No fucking way!
Bro, check his check his points!
There's no way!
That was crazy!
That was...
Dude, okay, no, they deserve that.
I was rooting for that!
That was a crazy play.
Holy shit.
Jared, that's what you're gonna do.
That's what I was... That's what I'm gonna do!
That's a lot of expectation onto the guy who just got here for like six hours ago.
We literally bot reviewed it.
You can do this.
You can implement what we just saw and do it yourself.
I'll try, I'll try.
Thank you for believing, though.
See, like what Flame said.
It's all about the delusion.
Okay.
Alright.
You gotta fake it till you make it.
Okay, alright, alright.
I gotta put in my ego here.
I gotta pump myself up.
You got this.
I believe.
I got this!
I'm with two people who's actually way better than this!
I got this.
I'm reassured.
Okay, as long as you believe in me, both of you, I got this.
I pumped up to the max.
I believe in you, Gerard.
Yeah, keep on believing.
Keep on believing.
I believe in you, too.
I'm actually starting to see it.
I'm actually starting to see the vision.
You're starting to see it?
You're starting to see the game plan?
Yeah, I'm starting to see it.
Do you remember what that rampart did?
Okay, do you know how to do all of that, though?
Like, do you know the buttons to do all of that?
Yes, I do.
E, throw the shield.
Z is the ultimate where it's like a... the thingy.
The machine gun.
Yeah.
Yeah, I know it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I knew you could do it.
Yeah, I'm familiar with the controls, yes.
I can do it.
It's just, uh, it's just a matter of, like, um, like a positioning because I think I suck the most at positioning.
Like, I keep running around, like, where I'm not supposed to.
Like, earlier in the round, I was just running in front of you.
No, earlier... No, Gerard, you were going outside.
No, positioning was...
THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT!
I'M RUNNING OUTSIDE!
We were like, Gerard, we were like, stay inside, Gerard.
And then you went out.
I was like...
You can't blame me!
What do you mean?
We gave you one instruction that was to stay inside.
And you went outside.
I'm panicking.
I was panicking.
Okay, panic.
The panic, like, gets to ya.
Uh, this is my first time.
I appreciate... That's okay, you're learning.
You're learning as we go along.
Now you know, if we tell you to go inside, you stay inside.
Stay inside, stay inside.
Are we also gonna do the same situation for the next one?
Stay inside?
Well, it depends on...
Just listen to what Flame says.
We're in a house.
Your job is to just put walls up.
Great!
Okay, keep my walls up.
Okay, okay.
If we're not outside, how do I position my fucking walls?
Like, just randomly put them around us?
Uh, yeah.
I mean, you wanna think about it like, if we get pushed, um, where would we want to play, right?
Like, where's the angle that is most likely to be pushed, and then given that angle, you just gotta place walls around that.
Yeah, game sense.
You gotta lock in on that game sense.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're basically getting game sense as we go.
Like...
Yeah, I'm not...
Like, I mean, during the actual tournament, I mean, I could've at least practiced, but it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
It's okay.
We'll be fine.
God gives his toughest soldiers the greatest battles.
This is it.
I got a calling from this one.
Maybe I can actually be as great as you two.
Unfortunately, I think the saying goes like, God's favorite soldier faces the toughest battles.
Oh, okay, okay.
Even I fumbled that one, but you know, you get the point.
You get the point.
You tried, that's all that matters.
I tried, yeah, yeah, see?
Tried, I tried, I tried.
I definitely got, um, actually.
Um, actually.
This stream is going off to a bad start.
What do you mean?
We got third!
It went off a great start!
That's the best start we could ever get.
Third place?
No, you're...
I thought I could Don't get those in dreams.
Okay, we're gonna get even higher after this.
Higher.
Yeah, that's true.
Higher than third?
Are you trying to say we're gonna get second?
Yes.
Oh my god.
Rampart, um.
Oh wait, wait, no.
Rampart, rampart, rampart.
Right side, right side, right side.
No!
I forgot about, I don't have rampart!
You don't have rampart!
Wait, wait.
I don't have rampart!
Oh shit, that was my different account!
Oh fuck!
You don't have rampart?
I forgot about that!
Oh my god.
Wait, do you have enough currency to buy a character?
Do you have enough currency to buy a character?
I'll loot the back.
I'm looting the back.
Now I have to unlearn everything that I just saw!
It's fine!
It's fine.
Listen, listen, listen.
We got third because of my skills.
We got third because of this one.
So have some more faith.
We were on this map last game too!
Yeah, you're right!
Yeah, it's fine!
It's fine!
I like that we had all this long-ass talking and you never even had fucking...
Out the window!
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
You still got me, right?
You still believe in me, right buddy?
He's literally choking.
You still got me, right buddy?
I won't lie to you, man.
My confidence is wavering.
My beliefs are shaking.
I don't blame you!
You spent 10 minutes watching the Rampart just to find out you never even had it unlocked.
Well, I did have her in my other account.
I just forgot about it.
Whoops.
Whoopsies.
We can do this, we can do this.
If you guys don't have faith in me, I have faith in all of you.
That's alright.
I believe.
Keep on believing.
We'll get this cash and then we're going to Yeah, I think I looted everything on my end.
Did we loot the top here?
I'm gonna check.
Wait, we don't have a scanner though with this comp.
That's the only bad thing.
We have console.
Oh, that's true.
Okay.
We just go echo.
Yoink.
Okay, I got a bunch of heavy ammo if you guys want some.
Cool.
Thank you for providing us.
I got it.
Just saying.
I'm just carrying everything I see.
Is there an evac here?
Yeah, I have an evac ready.
Got it, got it, got it.
Can you grab that cash?
Oh, yeah, I can.
I'll head over there.
If you guys have any bags, anything, that would be helpful.
I know there was one, but I can't.
We gotta go now anyway, so we can't go back.
I'm grabbing this cash.
Yeah, just follow him and you should be fine.
We want to be at Stormcatcher here by the time this ring closes.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, wait, I'm gonna try...
Oh, from where?
It's fine, fine.
In front of me, in front of me.
This way.
Coming to us, coming to us.
I think it's grabbing cash.
They're grabbing cash.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm coming back.
I don't know if they're... Look at them, look at them.
Bubbles fading.
Oh, they're gone, they're gone.
Yeah, they're fucking gone, gone.
I just popped my Q when we lived.
Alright, where do we go?
Just go Echo.
Do you have enough currency to buy Rampart?
Yes.
I saw shots in front of us.
I think they're shooting at...
I don't know what they're shooting at though.
Can I buy inside the lobby room?
The private lobby?
Can I buy?
We'll just be like...
Sorry, he's restarting.
You just have to leave for a little bit.
Yeah, it's literally like 30 seconds.
We should be fine.
We need to hit the console.
I can...
give you a Q.
I'm right in front of you.
You should get close to us.
You're just in his.
There might be a team.
It's okay, we can find one here.
There's a res here.
There's a bag here.
Blue bag here.
I'm gonna hit the console.
You guys just stay here and look around.
I can just...
Get that blue bag here.
I should get the...
helmet too.
Yoink.
There's a blue bag here in front of me.
Okay, thank you.
I'm looking in front.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
What's the plan?
I think the zone pulls around here.
We wanna go back up here.
Come on, Droid.
Let's go.
I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming.
We can make it.
We can, we can.
Okay.
We're not last.
Some team is gonna die soon.
We're not gonna be last.
They're not dying fully, but like...
two people got knocked.
Nice, nice, nice.
This is a scary cross.
Flame not gonna lie.
It's okay, just believe.
I'm believing.
Droid, you gotta believe too.
Believe!
Everybody believe!
If we get shot, we just send Droid to run forward and bait the shots for us.
Yeah, exactly.
I mean, I could actually...
I'm looking back, I'm looking behind us.
Yeah, just let me absorb all the bullets.
Come hit this, but...
I'll absorb all of them for you.
I think we're going left.
Follow us.
Okay, yep, yep, yep, following.
I wanna go here.
I think there might be people there though.
Yeah, there is.
Okay, go back.
Alright, back here.
We gotta teach you how to...
It's fine, it's fine.
Teach me how to what?
Teach you how to do it.
Can you heal my armor, Doki?
Ow, ow, ow, ow.
You're fine, you're fine.
Yeah, okay.
Just rip another evac.
We're landing right here in the corner.
Just evac us anywhere, Doki.
Alright, we're going on this...
You see my yellow ping, where it's at?
Yep.
Okay, look up when you...
Look up, look up.
Just look up and then you do it.
Keep following me, keep following me.
Okay, and then after you get off...
We're landing here in this corner on the left.
Be careful.
Nice, good job.
Just get our wall down, Slime.
Anywhere.
Oh my god.
What?
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
No, it's not fine.
They're coming in.
Oh, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Oh my god.
Where did this come from?
MP, MP.
They just pushed us from the house.
No, I got hit by two nades.
I couldn't do anything.
Oh no.
Oh, look at that.
That was such a good nade.
Holy sh...
I don't even think it's like...
I don't even think that was the...
Wait.
This is the original team that pushed us?
Uh, it should be.
You got zero damage?
See, I'm not that bad.
I got naded.
I couldn't even fucking register.
Zero damage is zero damage.
You gotta do better, man.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm not teaching you anymore, Jirai.
Wait, how did you hit him, Flame?
Come on, come on.
I just sat between my rampart covers.
You just...
He just sat between my rampart covers.
I was just chilling.
I was like, I landed and I landed into two nades.
I was like, okay, I guess I die.
Yeah, we got squished real hard.
They died for their efforts.
What's wrong with you?
They literally died for it.
Wait, what place were we?
We were not...
We were not 20th, if you want to know.
I think we were like 17th or something.
How does the points system work here?
It's placement and kills.
So we didn't get either.
We get zero points for that game.
But we're off of Storm Point now.
I'm good.
I love World's Edge.
I know how to play positioning for that.
World's Edge is where I got prepped.
I'm very well versed in World's Edge.
I'll just say yes to everything.
Can I leave the lobby here?
Yeah, you can.
You can leave the lobby.
But there is a lifeline on this team.
If you want a VOD review.
You're playing Rampart.
You'll be fine.
You don't need a VOD review.
I'll do this later.
I'm just going to watch their gunfight or something.
Just to get me a little bit inspired.
You can play some pubs while we watch this.
I think you'll get more damage in there.
Than in these lobbies.
At least it'll keep me motivated.
Yeah, it'll keep you motivated.
You'll be like, you see that chat?
That's what I'm going to do in the lobby.
That's what I'm going to do.
I mean, we did the exact same thing.
By the way, in the customs.
We just did a bunch of damage.
In the pubs.
And after joining that, we did literally nothing.
I thought we had a chance.
It gave us hopium.
Just for a little bit.
Look, I believe in you.
You survived a very long time in hide and seek.
Right?
I mean, you did.
Just specifically that one.
Do we have extra points for the next one?
What do we exactly need?
For us to survive.
We need around 20 points.
We need 20 points.
We need another top 5.
We have 3 games to get a top 5.
That's not that hard.
Go for it.
That's not that hard if you think about it.
It's not that hard to survive out of these fucking beasts.
Beasts that are all over me.
If you think about it, it's not that hard.
What ranks are we fighting against, actually?
All of them diamond?
Technically, I should have got a...
I needed a gold or below.
And when they say a gold or below...
I found a bronze player.
Great choice!
You only found one of the worst.
You have no idea how hard it was to find anybody that's gold, silver, or...
It wasn't a privilege being found out at all.
I asked so many people.
And I even did an open call.
And then someone in my twitter replies was like...
You should Asteroid.
And I was like, you know what?
I may as well just Asteroid.
I thought I was special.
You went to everyone else first.
You were the last.
They were like, what's your rank?
And they were like, oh, I'm plat.
Or like, diamond.
And I'm like, when were you plat?
What was that season?
Season 12?
Fucked up so many ranks.
I'm getting a little bit pissed here.
I'm gonna prove you wrong.
I'm gonna go ranked.
And I'm gonna get to your level.
You're gonna go ranked and not be bronze?
Then you won't be invited to anything, John.
If you're too high ranked, you won't be invited to anything.
I WILL DESTROY EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THESE ASSHOLES IN THIS RING.
AFTER I GET BETTER.
THAT IS A PROMISE.
I WILL KILL ONE.
AT LEAST ONE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY TOURNAMENTS I'M GONNA BE IN, BUT I WILL BE ENTERING ALL OF THEM.
JUST ASK YOUR SENPAIS.
AND BE LIKE, CAN I GET A TOURNAMENT INVITE?
CAN I GET IN?
COME ON.
THIS IS FOR A VENDETTA.
I NEED TO PROVE TO THEM.
THAT I AM NOT.
FUCKING.
BRONZE.
BUT YOU ARE.
NO I'M NOT.
NO I WON'T BE.
I WON'T BE.
I WILL BE SOMETHING ABOVE.
SOMETHING GREATER.
I BELIEVE IN YOU.
I BELIEVE IN YOU TOO.
THIS WILL BE YOUR MOTIVATION ARC RIGHT THERE.
BUT IT WOULD BE EVEN MORE AWESOME IF A BRONZE PLAYER ACTUALLY TOOK SOMEONE DOWN HERE.
IT WOULD BE.
IT WOULD BE VERY AWESOME.
THE GREATEST THING EVER.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE THE START OF MY JOURNEY.
IN APEX.
FLAME, DO YOU THINK HE WOULD BE ABLE TO DO IT?
YOUR HONEST OPINION.
I MEAN YOU HAD...
YOU STARTED LIKE ME RIGHT?
WE ALL STARTED FROM ZERO.
FLAME?
WHAT?
WERE YOU BORN WITH IT?
THE FUCK?
WHAT ARE THE REQUIREMENTS?
MY FIRST...
MY FIRST TIME PLAYING APEX.
I GOT PRED.
YOU SON OF A BITCH.
WHAT THE FUCK?
WHAT A FLEX.
WHAT WAS YOUR FIRST FPS GAME?
WERE YOU LIKE A FUCKING BABY WHEN YOU WERE PLAYING FPS GAMES?
THE FUCK?
YEAH, I STARTED OFF REALLY LATE.
I PLAYED SPLATOON.
IT WASN'T AN FPS GAME.
YOU SUCKED AT FIRST, RIGHT?
THAT'S GONNA BE ME.
I'M GONNA BE...
YOU'RE LYING.
YOU CANNOT POSSIBLY BE GOOD.
NO, I DID.
I GOT SPLATOON 1-3.
OKAY.
SUDDENLY MY CHANCES OF ACTUALLY GOING THROUGH THIS IS LOW.
I THINK YOU HAVE...
MAYBE I DON'T HAVE WHAT IT TAKES.
THERE'S LIKE TWO DIFFERENT TYPES OF PEOPLE.
THE ONES THAT WERE BORN WITH IT.
AND THE ONES THAT TRY REALLY REALLY HARD.
I'M GONNA BE TRYING REALLY REALLY HARD.
YEAH, I BELIEVE IN YOU.
YOU GOT THIS.
AS PEOPLE WHO...
I'M GONNA BE A MOTIVATOR FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE STARTING OFF THIS GAME.
YEAH, EXACTLY.
THE GAME WILL EXPLODE BECAUSE OF ME.
YOU'LL BE AN INSPIRATION TO ALL THE BRONZE PLAYERS.
I'M DEFINITELY SAVING APEX LEGENDS.
YEAH, YOU'RE GONNA SAVE APEX LEGENDS.
BECAUSE THE BRONZE PLAYERS...
I'M JUST IMAGINING THESE PLAYERS ARE ME RIGHT NOW.
NOT GONNA LIE, I'VE BEEN DREAMING ABOUT THIS.
LIKE, WHEN I STARTED PLAYING APEX, I'VE BEEN DREAMING OF JUST SQUAD WIPING LEFT AND RIGHT.
SQUAD WIPING LEFT AND RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, I BELIEVE.
IT WON'T BE A DREAM.
IT WON'T BE.
WE HAVE TWO DAYS TO DO THIS.
SO LIKE, I BELIEVE.
BELIEVE.
WE ARE THE DREAM TEAM.
YEAH, IT CAN'T BE THAT DIFFICULT.
WE MAKE THINGS INTO REALITY.
IT'S NO LONGER A DREAM, EVERYBODY.
IT'S FINE, I BELIEVE.
YOU'RE GONNA BE LIKE MARKIPLIER IF HE PLAYED APEX.
LAUGHING.
HE DOESN'T EVEN PLAY APEX.
EXACTLY.
YOU'RE GONNA BE MARKIPLIER IF HE PLAYED APEX.
YEAH, I'M GONNA BE DIFFERENT.
I'M NO LONGER GONNA BE COMPARED TO HIM.
I'M GONNA BE DIFFERENT.
THIS IS MY NEW JOURNEY.
YOU'RE NEW JOURNEY.
I AM SOMEBODY ELSE.
I AM ME.
LAUGHING.
STOP IT.
WHATEVER, WHATEVER, WHATEVER.
NEXT ROUND.
FOR SURE.
IT'S FINE.
THE NEXT GAME, WE LEARN EVERYTHING.
IT'S WORLD'S EDGE.
I'M COMFORTABLE ON WORLD'S EDGE.
IT'LL BE SO FINE.
WE'RE SO HEALTHY.
IS THAT THE ONE WHERE THE RASENGAN THING THERE'S A VORTEX IN THE MIDDLE OF THE MAP OR SOMETHING?
IS THAT IT?
NO.
LAUGHING.
I DON'T REMEMBER.
WAS THAT IT?
THE VORTEX IS...
OLYMPUS.
OH, THAT WAS OLYMPUS.
WORLD'S EDGE IS THE ONE WHERE THERE'S LIKE CITIES AND WILDLIFE.
NOT WILDLIFE.
CITIES AND GRASS.
OH, YEAH.
OKAY.
NOW I REMEMBER.
AND LAVA.
OH, YEAH.
SHIT.
CITY, GRASS, AND LAVA.
THAT'S WORLD'S EDGE.
IT'S AN OG MAP.
OKAY.
ALRIGHT.
ARE WE ALSO GONNA BE PARTICIPATING IN A SEASON ZERO MAP?
NO, NO.
IT'S JUST THESE TWO MAPS.
CAUSE THEY'RE THE MOST COMPETITIVE MAPS, BASICALLY.
ALRIGHT.
OKAY.
IT'LL BE FINE.
ARE YOU DOING A PUB RIGHT NOW, JERROD?
NO.
I'M ACTUALLY JUST WATCHING SOMEONE HERE RIGHT NOW.
YOU'RE WATCHING THIS RAT.
JUST HIDING IN THE DIRT.
I MEAN, I GOTTA LEARN HOW TO FIGHT.
BRO, HE'S DRIFTING AND HE'S TRYING NOT TO.
HE'S TRYING TO CONTROL HIS DRIFT RIGHT NOW.
HAVING A CALM STATE OF MIND, I THINK THAT'S WHAT MATTERS HERE.
BECAUSE I WAS PANICKING.
AND MY GAME WAS, LIKE, EVERYWHERE.
I LITERALLY WENT TO A PUB, LIKE, PROBABLY JUST RIGHT BEFORE THIS THING, I THINK.
Or was it a practice round?
I don't remember.
But, you know, I did some damage.
A little bit.
OH MY GOD, HE CRAFTED?
HOW IS HE GONNA REST?
HOW IS HE- Oh my god, look, boobs.
Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Okay.
He's gonna get fucked, isn't he?
OH SHIT!
It'll be fine.
There's no way somebody's just gonna walk out of that area and look at him.
That'll be funny.
Maybe, maybe not.
Oh, wait, six squads.
Oh, shit, okay.
Alright, six squads left.
I think it's consistently the same teams winning, so, like, we still have a chance for top ten, guys.
We still have a chance!
Keep on believing.
And it's different people all the time.
We still have a chance.
I mean, the best chance that we have is actually hot drop and kill the best players.
We can't hot drop.
I don't know about that one.
I don't think that might not be the case.
Yeah, I don't think that's the case because they have teammates.
They're the most vulnerable.
You're right.
They still have teammates.
Hey, we're a team!
What do you call us?
We're a team, right?
Yeah, but if you drop on one person, I don't think there's enough guns for two people.
Sorry, I had to correct myself.
Whatever.
Whatever, it's fine.
Oh my god, that's good.
I didn't know there was a hole there.
Yeah, can you shoot through that hole or is there an invisible barrier?
No, you can't shoot through the holes.
God damn.
If you're on top of a building, you shoot under the roof because there's holes there.
I think this world's it.
No, that's not.
That's King's Shadow.
You got triple take.
And it's over.
Stuck between a rock and a hard place.
Numbers fixed though.
You tried.
Oh my god, this is...
This is what we're gonna do.
Did you buy Rampart?
You should buy Rampart right now, this game is about to end.
Oh shit, okay.
So like, you know, when they come back, they'll have to wait for us to buy Rampart.
Yep, yep, yep.
Like, one of my worst fears is they actually start immediately after this.
They'll be like, there's two people there.
Alright, that's good enough.
That's fine, he's barely even done any damage.
2 out of 3 is like, almost a pass.
This is rude.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna leave.
Legend Locker or Rampart.
Um, okay, there we go.
Controller, okay.
Unlock Legend.
Wait, if we do Rampart, do we run Pathy?
Or like, Gibraltar?
Uh, I'm probably gonna go Gibraltar.
Oh wait, can we swap?
I'm better at Gibraltar than Newcastle.
Sure.
Alright, nice.
Hopefully they don't change the...
Machine gun fucking shotgun.
Yeah, is there the same people winning the top 3?
Are you kidding me?
I recognize the names for the top 3.
Oh my god.
Look at him go.
Look at... oh, goodbye.
He did some movement.
Oh man, how many more people left?
Um, zero.
Oh.
Game over.
Hey, it's over?
Hey!
Did you get it?
Oh yeah, I got it.
Yeah, Rampart, make sure you're on Rampart.
Yep, got it.
Okay, yeah.
Good, alright.
We did it, guys.
We did it, we did it.
We did it, everybody.
We accomplished our first goal today.
Just buying Rampart.
Every game we learn something new.
Okay, alright, alright.
Okay, I'm confident in this one.
For real, for real.
Me too, I'm so confident.
I just realized my chat was dead this entire time.
Sorry, chat.
I don't know why, but I think it's my CSS, my custom code for my chat.
Oh shit, you're right, mine too.
I always have to input my code again.
Not input the code, but I have to refresh my...
I mean, it's been like that for the longest time.
Oh, so it's just a YouTube update, right?
Yeah, it's always been like that.
Let me get this pop-out chat.
Are you excited about Japan?
Did you get your visa done?
Oh, you're going to Japan.
My visa appointment is going to be on the 24th.
Oh, because Tempo was telling me about how a lot of pros were really lazy with their...
Oh.
Tempo was telling me how a lot of pros were really lazy with their visas, so I hope you got your visas done.
I think that it's like that for everyone.
I definitely stalled it a couple of days at least.
Are you going there for vacation or what?
No, championships is in Japan.
That's why we win this.
We get to go to Sapporo because that's where it is.
Oh, shit.
Are they paying for your ticket?
They definitely should.
Like the event ticket or the plane ticket?
I think the event, plane, and hotel.
I could be wrong.
Damn, now we gotta win.
Okay, guys.
Realistic expectations, Daraad, please.
No, no, no, no, no.
Aim high!
Too high, Daraad.
Aiming too high.
We gotta go!
Where is this?
We need the optimism here.
You need to go there.
I'm doing this for you, man.
I'm doing this for you.
Oh, shit, Daraad, really?
Yeah, I'm doing this for you.
I'm doing this for you, buddy.
I'm gonna drop out as soon as we win every single tournament here.
But, like, Flame's gonna go there automatically.
It's just, fucking things paid off.
Wait, is it paid off by you already?
Oh, shit, really?
It's fine, it's fine.
I'm doing this for him anyway.
I'm gonna dedicate this win to you.
He's literally competing in the championship.
Fuck, but you know what?
I still, I don't care.
I'm gonna dedicate this thing for you.
You know what?
No.
He can get those tickets and then ask his org to refund it.
It's like paying his pay in advance.
I'm doing this regardless of anything.
I'm doing this for you.
Thanks for teaching me.
I'll do this for you, man.
I'm not gonna disappoint you.
What about me?
I appreciate that.
Fuck you.
You've been dissing me this entire time.
I ain't doing shit for you.
I'm doing this for Flame.
Yeah, fuck her, man.
I'm doing this for you, buddy.
Whoa, my god.
You taught him to fight for himself, Flame.
You did it.
Yeah, that's what homies do for each other, you know?
Thank you.
Thank you for defending my pride.
Yeah, you got me.
I knew you had it in you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just needed that one push.
I'm good.
Is this your first time in Japan?
Flame, is this your first time going to Japan?
Yeah, like actually being in Japan.
Oh, dude.
I gotta warn you about the trains, though.
The trains are so confusing.
You gotta bring in a map or something.
Yeah, it's very confusing.
When I went there, I was lost.
And you gotta bring in a fucking internet connection or something.
Like a data.
Yeah, you need to rely on Google Maps a lot.
I should be able to just use roaming.
Oh, wait, Rampart.
Am I still going for Rampart?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's gonna go Newcastle.
We got this.
Don't worry about it.
My passport was gonna expire tomorrow.
And I literally renewed my passport today.
I literally went to the passport office.
I have no appointment.
Renew my passport.
They just let you in?
I had to wait three hours.
But I still got it done.
Usually that doesn't work.
What the fuck?
I didn't know you could do that.
Yeah, you can do that.
I'm more of an adult than you guys.
We got the entire fragment.
I'll loot here.
I'm starting on left here.
I'll have my own building.
Thank you very much.
Your own building?
In this economy?
Get out of here.
You guys got the good stuff.
It's time for me to have the good stuff.
He gets paid really well.
Shut the fuck up.
Is that what I meant?
Flatline.
I got my weapons here.
Let me know.
Triple take.
That's an electric...
Energy ammo thing?
Yes.
I don't know the lingo.
Shut the fuck up.
You said that to Flame.
I don't know that.
Flame, I'm sorry.
I'm pretty sure he said that to you.
I'm pretty sure he said that to both of us.
I think he said that to you.
I don't even know who I said it to.
He heard one voice here.
And then he just fought back.
Any insult is automatically redirected to me.
I'm sorry.
It's just an automatic defense system for me.
I have to defend myself somewhat.
I thought we got all Fragment.
Fragment is separate from Monument.
Oh, that's Monument?
That's why Fragment is not really as good.
Because we have to wait for this team to leave.
Before we can take their console.
Alright, we want to start...
Oh!
I did shoot them.
I think they're mad.
That was my bad.
I did shoot them.
Let's start walking towards the console.
The team on the left is holding Con.
We have to be careful of Epi.
But I think we should be okay here.
We need you to scan.
Alright, I'm heading over.
I need you to scan the road.
Scan?
Yeah, you're going to need the console.
Oh, where is it?
Just follow him.
We'll teach you.
Someone might be coming to us.
We have to be a bit careful here.
Give me a sec.
I'll pop in a bubble.
A little bubble.
Okay, just hold E.
Okay, hope they don't shoot me!
Don't worry, they cannot.
Thank you.
Okay, we just go.
Come through this bridge here.
Which one do I get for Gibraltar?
I'll do the ult increase.
Because I don't need the shotgun thing.
You should tell Jara what he should upgrade.
Left or right?
Probably just the left.
Left, okay.
Ult, okay.
We'll just go train the geyser here.
I have my bubble if we need it.
We have to be careful.
Epicenter might be close.
They could have rotated towards ghost town here on the left.
I don't know where they're at.
Oh wow, you guys are far away.
Were you looting, Jarad?
I was looking for a bag.
Okay, I'll be back.
I'm here, I'm here.
Focus, focus, focus.
I thought you said you got inspired to lock in.
Yeah, I am, and I have no ammo.
I can't shoot peeps.
We need to hit this carry out on my way.
Hopefully no one's holding this choke.
I have a 3x so you need it, Flame.
I can trade you a 3x.
Close to my left!
Maggy ball!
You need bubble?
Yeah.
I'm gonna ult.
I'm gonna get shot by a different...
I'm on my bubble right now.
This is my ult.
My bubble's gonna go off soon.
My bubble's gonna end.
Can you guys slide down to me?
Yeah, I'm sliding, I'm sliding.
Slide, slide, slide, slide.
I'm getting shot from behind!
I'm over.
I'm fine, I'm fine, I'm fine.
You're fine, you're fine, you're fine.
I can rez you here, I can rez you here.
I'll put a bubble.
We need to get in the house.
Okay, I'm going in.
I'm up here.
Yeah, I got in, I got in.
Let me in, let me in!
You're fine, you're fine.
Set up the walls, set up the walls.
We might be getting pushed.
Yeah, we're getting pushed.
Put some behind us here.
They're coming!
Move back and put rampart covers down.
Put covers, put covers!
Cover, cover, cover!
Watch Q and just left click.
They're behind us, they're behind us.
They're throwing nades.
We're okay, we're okay.
I have to use a bubble.
There's a frag.
They might push after this.
They're close, they're close.
They're trying to push.
Get 150.
I don't have any nades, so...
They're shooting behind!
I'm looking at the door.
They're pushing!
One guy outside!
Push, push, push!
Just heal, just heal!
Rampart here on the left.
I cracked the Pathfinder.
Flash, flash, flash!
Nice!
Where's the Pathfinder?
He left, he left, he left.
Just heal, heal, heal, heal!
Go, go, go!
The other team is locked up.
I'm climbing up to the roof here.
I thirsted, I thirsted.
I need help.
Just heal, just heal.
Oh, I died.
Can you come outside and rez me?
Just jump outside.
I can give bubble.
Thank you.
I don't know if they're pushing though, so...
We can loot them here.
They backed up just now.
We should be okay.
I don't have bubble, so I'm going to wait until my bubble is back.
They're still kind of outside here on the right.
I'm going back inside just in case.
60 on the Magi.
Gibby!
I couldn't get in time.
Can you climb a roof on me?
Yeah.
Oh my god, I fucked up my roof climb.
In the open here, Magi.
I'm getting shot from the heights though.
There's a charge rifle on the heights though.
We can't play the roof.
Alright, I have bubble.
Is he above me?
Gibby is above me.
Want me to come over to you?
There's another team over there, so careful.
I'm heading over to...
Just stay there, Gerard.
Stay there.
Anchor that point.
Magi is running.
They're gone.
I'm going to loot the box in front of me then.
Yeah, go ahead.
I'm going to put bubble.
This guy is so good at the game.
I have heals.
Do you want heals for it?
Guys, I'm surviving.
I'm anchoring.
I only have shield cells here.
I have one shield cell left though.
It just ran over at overlook.
Should I go over there?
Just stay there for now.
We need to go into geyser, guys.
There's a triple take.
I think I'm going to...
Let's just go in the choke and go in the geyser here.
I'm going to run a triple take too.
Actually, I'm going to run a nemesis.
I trust myself on nemesis more.
Just come over, Gerard.
Just come over.
Now you can head over.
Do you need heals?
I have heals.
I dropped the syringe.
I dropped another one.
We need to get shield cells.
I only have one shield cell.
There's extra.
We should rat in this tunnel.
Come inside.
I'll close the door.
Just come to me.
They're going to come in from the top side here.
We just rat in the outside.
Outside this door.
Don't make sound.
Don't slide.
Just crouch if you can.
Or walk.
Yeah, just...
I have my walk unbounded.
So I gotta crouch.
Where do I place my shields?
Don't place anything.
We just wait until they come.
Oh shit, I hear them.
We just kill the first guy that walks down here.
Let me know when to peek.
I'm hiding behind a rock.
Yeah.
Get ready.
Peek, peek, peek!
I got him.
Push, push, push!
Push for that!
One by one!
We got the other!
Knocked out, bitch!
Knocked out!
Okay, Droid.
When you charge that up...
Am I 28?!
It makes a lot of sound there, Droid.
When you charge that up...
We can hear it.
Oh my god!
Oh shit, sorry!
They realized you were there because you charged it up.
You charged it up!
That's why we're like, go, go, go!
Whoops!
Sorry about that.
Okay, I guess we go now.
I didn't know!
Where did you kill the other guy?
I'm so sorry, I didn't know!
We learn, we learn.
Droid, Droid, Droid!
He's fucking gone!
Let's go, guys.
Okay, okay, wait, wait, wait.
I'm following you, I'm following you.
Where'd you go?
Just come outside.
Droid, Droid, Droid!
Get down, get down, go downstairs!
The wrong way!
It's okay.
Okay,
going, going, going.
Man it out, man it out!
Oh my god!
I think there's just one demon geyser in this house here.
I think we want to kill them.
Can you guys come to me?
Don't peek, don't peek.
We wait for Droid to get to us.
That is still the wrong way, Droid.
Droid, Droid, Droid, look at the map!
Just go through here.
Droid, Droid, Droid, follow my pings!
Follow this ping right here.
You can run fast, it's fine, you don't take a lot.
Other way, other way, other way!
Other way, other way!
Okay, stop moving, Droid, stop moving.
Okay.
Look to your left.
Left?
Yeah, go there.
Alright, got it.
It's like a mouse in a maze.
My direction!
Oh, whoopsies.
For a job well done, here's a medkit.
I did it, I moved away!
Yay!
Okay, okay, wait, wait, wait.
Healing myself, healing myself.
This is going to be a little bit rough.
We have to evac from my red ping here and then land inside the cart.
Okay, that's fine.
Just start coming to me.
I'm coming over, yeah.
Oh, they're set up there.
That's why it's going to be rough.
We have to fly over that team and not crash into anything.
And if you crash into anything, you die, pretty much.
That's why I already got 3kp.
I have to heal, I have to heal, I have to heal.
Just give me a sec.
You should be fine, Droid, you should go.
You don't have to play with me.
I got hit, so you have to play fast.
You don't have to wait for me.
Yeah, okay.
Just come over, guys.
We just have to go here.
You should go first without us.
I can just fly.
It should be okay, just come.
1, 2, 3, go.
Be really careful.
You have to go straight here and then you have to turn left.
Okay, it's fine.
It's not fine.
Just heal, just heal, just heal.
Just heal, you will just...
Come inside, come inside.
Okay, we're perfect, we're okay.
We're chilling.
I have the bubble.
Healing myself.
Wait, you made it?
I have no heals, by the way.
Oh, fuck me.
Come with me, we're okay.
Just fight right on me, I think.
What heals do you need?
On me is the only safe spot.
Don't use the syringe, stop using the syringe.
Stop using the syringe.
Oh, okay.
Okay, zone is on us.
We're in a really good spot now.
We're in a really, really good spot.
Cancel the medkit, use the syringe.
Okay.
We have to make sure no one pushes us.
Like that game in...
I'll look northwest.
Yeah.
Gerard, you just live.
I'll look northwest though.
Yeah, put a wall.
Gerard, put a wall right here for me.
Right here, in front of me.
Come here.
Put a wall right here so I can look out the wall.
Here?
Yeah, that's good.
And then you put a wall right here.
Right here, where I'm peeing.
Put a wall right there.
That's good.
Nice.
That should be fine.
Put a wall in my corner here, Gerard, facing like this way.
So we can back up to the wall.
Back up to me, Gerard.
Back up to me.
No, no, make it closer.
You can press X on it.
And then...
Back up to my corner and place it like right in front of you.
Okay, okay.
Back up to my corner, place it right in front of you.
Make it as tight to the wall as possible.
Make it even closer.
Yeah, you're learning.
I'm learning, I'm learning, I'm learning.
Here, tight to the wall.
Nice.
Okay, this is good.
I'm gonna look right here.
I'm looking northwest.
I'm gonna look out northwest the entire time.
Okay, I'm gonna look out through this window here.
Gerard, can you move this wall?
Move this wall here a little bit forward.
Still make it on the doorway, but put it on the very front side of the doorway.
So we can still use the doorway.
Wait, um...
Put it at the absolute most front of the doorway.
We can still move left.
Here?
Yeah, just...
That's fine still, I think.
Can you put one outside here on me as well?
Yeah, make it...
This is the last wall, just put one outside.
Uh, no, no, no.
Make it face, like...
Make it angled slightly towards, like...
This one?
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh my god, he's learning!
You can replace this wall here over at the left, Gerard.
Can you be cracked here?
Yeah, I can't see him.
No, it's okay.
Yeah, I can only look at...
Only one person can look through that.
Even top of big mod, getting killed.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm just looking at here.
There's a team still shooting from up there.
Cause they're safe.
Oh, we're not in zone.
We're not in zone.
Yeah.
We'll be okay.
There's a spot right here that we can play.
Okay.
We'll be okay.
Do you want me to give you anywhere while we rotate?
No, we're okay for now.
Doki, you okay?
You're getting shot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They shot me through like the one hole.
This is the only team we have to worry about here.
We cannot let the team on my red ping walk up on us.
I know.
Yeah.
Oh, be careful, Doki!
We're getting shot from behind mod.
Yup.
Be careful.
We have to be careful of big mod as well.
They can walk out into us.
You generally don't want to use your ulti.
Okay.
It's like...
Gerard, you have to be careful with the ulti.
Because you...
You're like really slow.
So only use it for emergencies.
So get your gun out if you need to.
You're ulting the team behind us?
I think we should just set up.
Guys.
Can you come to me?
I think we should just set up here right away.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm poking.
Going, going, going.
I'm here.
I'm ready.
Put walls now.
Put walls.
They're fighting.
Just look up.
Look up towards the truck there.
Someone look towards the truck.
I'm looking.
I'm looking here.
Give me a shot.
They're fighting on the truck.
I'm looking behind us.
I have to look behind us.
It's just the truck.
Can we see if anything is going on on the truck?
I'm thirsting.
Oh, he's full HP.
He's full HP.
Oh, he's mine.
Look behind.
We're getting repped.
You can come play on me.
I'm here.
Enemy is over here.
There's people in this truck.
There's a guy playing on this box here.
They're fighting.
Get the kills.
I got one.
They're fighting on the back.
I'm here.
Killed one.
Gibby.
It's just Gibby.
Bubble.
I'm putting bubble.
Nice.
We need to go back.
They're pushing us.
I hear something.
On our left.
They got me.
Just chill.
I'm chilling.
We're okay.
Wait until next bub and you're going to rez.
Okay.
One bubble.
I'm rezzing.
Cover me.
I have to...
You're okay.
I'm good.
I got the rez off.
Let me know if I'm dull.
Okay.
Revived.
We need to kill...
We need to make sure this team on the left dies.
I want to get that loot.
Yeah, we can.
I don't think I can.
It's fine.
I can ult this.
They're going to just bubble.
They're kind of fighting up top.
I'm not really sure what's going on.
Just don't die.
We have to kill this Rampart team.
Blue armor Gibby.
Gibby.
Rez.
E.
Behind you.
We're okay.
We just heal here.
We have time.
Just relax.
I'm right behind.
Oh shit.
100.
Gibby is one.
Be careful.
You're 1v1.
Behind you.
No.
I got him.
Oh my god.
You can rez me.
Rez me now while they're fighting.
I'm behind you by the way.
Careful Doki.
You might walk in the zone.
We have to try and third party this soon.
Just walk up to me first.
Fall heal.
Just fall heal.
I have nothing.
We're going to have to bubble up soon.
Take any ammo you need.
I don't know what your ammo is right now.
Oh you have energy.
You have to bubble up towards the left.
When we're about to go out.
Or if we get naded.
All left?
Bubble up left.
Oh my god.
Just heal.
You're okay.
I think it's just one guy.
Yeah, it's just one guy.
Yes!
Oh my god!
Your clutch is clean!
We're so much better!
Oh my god!
This is insane!
We did it!
I told you!
I told you World's Edge is my map!
It is!
It's my fucking map!
We have 11 kills!
Oh my god!
I'll be right back.
No!
My heart was racing!
I was like, you walked past me when I asked you!
My heart was crazy!
I'm so sorry!
My hands are still shaking!
I was like, Trey!
Please receive!
And you walked away!
I didn't know!
I'm so sorry!
I know!
You were overloaded!
You were so overloaded!
I know!
I'm so sorry!
But we did it!
We won regardless!
Congrats!
Thank you!
Oh my god!
That was a crazy game!
I know!
Oh my god!
I'm gonna remember this forever!
Holy crap!
Thank you!
No more boy failure!
No longer pregnant!
My hands are on T-Rex fur!
I survived at the last thing too!
You lived!
You did it again!
I lived!
See?
I told you!
This is the start!
Flav, I told you!
He's not here right now.
He's back!
Flav, I told you!
This is for you!
This was for you!
We're gonna win this!
Yo!
That was actually insane!
That was insane!
I know!
Insane!
And I got that on stream too!
Holy crap!
Thank you!
Dude!
He's just like, oh my god!
I'm never gonna do better than that!
I'm never gonna do that ever again!
It was crazy!
You didn't even get to look at your damage because we won!
We didn't even know what your damage was because you won!
Wait, what?
How do I...
You can't!
People will see at the top right.
You have to wait until the VOD's over to see!
Oh god!
But hey, I think I did...
Last time I checked, it was like 99 or something.
That's improvement!
Yeah!
It's way better than 14!
Dude, that's huge!
Yeah baby!
Good job!
Oh my god, that was scary.
That fucking clutch there was fucking scary because I was like...
I had a fucking alternator.
I was like, I need to swap this gun.
The moment before the clutch when Doki's just screaming Terron, rez me!
Terron, rez me!
Rez me, Terron!
And he's just walking away.
He's just walking away with his minigun.
And then I was like, okay.
That's so funny to watch.
Okay, we can erase that.
We won.
Barla is the one.
Barla is the one, shut up!
Oh my god.
No way!
Listen, the future might have changed if I had revived you.
That's true, that's true.
It's like a butterfly effect.
If I had revived you, maybe I would have been shot.
And we would have been all dead.
Wait, wait, wait.
Gerard didn't get in.
Oh, Gerard.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
DM reset, okay.
How do I go?
Hero, please reset.
Gerard didn't get in.
Wait, what?
I'm here.
You didn't get in.
No, you're not.
Wait, I'm still here waiting for everybody.
Yeah, you didn't get in.
Just reset your game right now.
Maybe they'll reset.
They have to nerf us after winning.
Maybe they're just like, fuck you guys, now you're going to play with 1.1 players.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Same code?
Is it the same code?
Yeah, it'll be the same code.
I think they are resetting.
I think he just got a thumbs up.
Alright, alright.
Why is it not resetting?
I'm just going to loot.
They have to get rid of our momentum.
Yeah, what the hell?
We were on that grind.
You won, we're taking one person away.
I mean, it's understandable They took out the strongest guy.
My favorite was also Guys, we gotta be quiet.
And the truck charges this fucking machine gun.
It's a big mini gun going And they ran away!
Yeah, yeah, okay, okay.
That made sense.
But you know, we won.
Let's just forget about that.
Shall we?
Forget, forget.
Okay, there we go.
I'm inside.
Okay, let me drink some water.
Holy crap, that parched me up.
Oh my god.
Okay, here we go.
No, no, no.
I'm not satisfied.
We gotta get even higher.
We're gonna get you that one.
We're gonna get you that dub again.
Oh my god.
Now, okay, now.
Oh my god, okay.
Someone says we really got Gerard Apex champion before GTA.
Is it that rare of a sight to see me win in life?
You guys, before GTA 6.
Oh my god, that's true.
I can't believe we got Gerard a champion before GTA 6.
Listen, Gerard, nobody's questioning if you will, like, if you win in life, you know, but winning in Apex.
That's hard.
Not everybody wins in Apex, Gerard.
This is, like, very rare.
Yeah, I, this is a privilege.
Thank you.
Thank you for inviting me.
I'd like to thank my family and everything.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Okay.
Okay, I'm on a roll.
My adrenaline is up.
All right, let's go.
Now all the teams will actually kill us for real.
All right, I'm looting the left side.
I'm looting this side.
Going super saiyan, huh?
Now he's, now he's motivated.
Undergoing through that right now.
I like how all our mistakes are actually helping us.
Like, the spiders gave us free kills because we forgot to finish it, and then the delayed reds let us, let us third party.
Because I think if you res me instantly, we would have fought again.
But because of that, we didn't fight after.
We just waited.
Thankfully, it was, uh, it was all coming together.
Yeah, everything just came together.
Can we do it again, though?
We can do that again.
I believe.
Yeah, we can do that.
Yeah, that's what I like to hear.
You can do it again.
We can do it again.
I think it'll be pretty easier.
Yeah, yeah.
Winning another game won't be that difficult, right?
Yeah, we've got it in our veins.
Yeah, yeah.
We literally, like, we've downloaded the, the system.
Yeah, the VOD is in our brains.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We just gotta do that again.
It's in our genes.
I need a backpack.
There's another back here.
I don't have a backpack yet, so I don't want to pick it up.
Oh, nice.
All right.
Uh, we wanna hit monument scan here again.
Yep.
Checking, checking.
Shit, I got nothing here.
Just, uh, you have to look at monument first, make sure they're gone, and then we can go.
All right.
If they're still over there, then we can't go.
I'm, like, don't have a backpack.
Whoa.
Which is not great for me.
There's a blue helmet.
I can give you mine.
No, it's fine.
It's okay.
You can hold stuff for us.
You need it more than I do.
Come on, here.
No, it's fine.
I could, I don't see anyone yet on the scan, but it is looted.
I'm gonna go to the left house now to loot more because I'm running out.
I need more stuff.
Look, we, we won champion and we were landed in fragment.
I got backpacks.
How many points does that give us?
A lot.
I think it gave us 23.
Yeah, we got 23, yeah.
So we're, like, 30 something.
I think we should go now.
I think they might have left already.
Okay.
Let's go.
I'm heading over.
I need a scope for a carbine.
If you guys find any too.
There's a really good, there's a really good chance the zone is pulling this way.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah, follow us.
So, yeah, they're, they're already flying out towards right here.
This might be an overlook zone, but just, just come here, Gerard, scan, and then we can go.
Yeah, I'll bubble him.
Wait a minute, I think I've seen this thing before.
All right, we're doing the same thing as we've done before.
Dj vu.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
We're doing the same thing.
It's as if, like, competitive Apex follows, like, a, like, a routine.
Oh, what the heck?
What the fuck?
Okay, uh, do we go down here?
Hit this, uh, cache?
Towards my yellow, I guess.
Let's go now.
Yeah.
Okay, we go there.
Where did it go?
Overlook, then.
I don't know.
I guess that was just climatizer going overlook.
Uh, yeah, okay, we need to hit this cache and then just be in one of these, like, houses here.
Oh, I'm queuing.
I'll give you a bubble too.
There's a triple take here.
There's a triple take right here.
Oh, that guy is crazy.
Yeah, grab that.
Yo, taking out the champions right at once.
Do you need the 3x?
Okay.
I don't have a bubble.
Alright, we go, we go.
We just, we just want to run up here.
Yeah, just run, just run, just run.
I have another bubble in 12 seconds, so we need it.
Yeah, I have, uh, Newcastle slam.
I have, uh, the ulti.
I'm fine.
Just keep running.
Let's try and, like, move left, right.
I'm gonna get the cache.
Just move left, right.
Yeah, we need to grab cache here and then we just rotate.
We can run through Harvester Choke and just...
Wait, why don't I just get as deep in as possible?
You go, you go to get the cache.
I'm gonna loot this real fast.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm looting.
I'm, I'm, I'm healing, I'm healing.
Let me know.
They're on the tracks, on the tracks.
They're running away.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, they're on the train tracks.
Nope, they're not running away.
I lied.
I'm looking.
They just, Rampart, uh, just start putting Qs down.
They're trying to fight us, I think.
Trying to fight us.
Okay, I'm gonna ult this.
They ulted us.
1 HP, Rampart.
Right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, below, below, below, below, below, below, right here, right here, right here.
Newcastle one, Newcastle one, in your ulti.
He's dead, he's dead.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm pushing up.
You guys win this.
I'm pushing up.
You can play aggressive, you can play aggressive.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm pushing up, pushing up, pushing up.
Be behind her, Doki.
Uh, Druid, rezzing right here, rezzing right here, rezzing right here.
I know, I know, I'm pushing, I'm pushing.
Peek this, peek this, peek this.
There's a Rampart looking at you, Doki.
Druid, come fight.
I need him fight, oh!
Just run, just run, Druid.
Just run, just run, just run, just run.
I could, I got shot by it.
Just run, Druid, that's alright.
I don't think he can run anymore.
Just run, just run.
Oh, okay.
He's heavy focus, he's just in his zone.
God!
I went the left side.
Yeah, it's unfortunate.
It's okay.
Oh, that was so close.
Man, but that was alright, that was alright.
I think I, oh...
We won, though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We won a game.
We don't need this game, technically.
We don't...
We were top four, apparently, with that game.
Oh, my God.
Wait, we're top four with that one game?
Yeah!
Really?
No, it's crazy!
That's crazy!
We lost every one, but, you know...
Wow, we're top four.
Okay, the last game, we...
You guys did great.
You did awesome.
That's crazy that we're top four with one game.
You did great, Druid.
We believed in you.
Yeah, a little bit, but you guys did most of the damage, so...
Yeah, great, great, great.
I'm actually curious, though.
What do you hear when we say, just run?
Um, run, but to them.
I was like, okay, I think I can take him.
My brain says, I think I can take him.
I was like, what's in your...
His brain was like, just run, just run.
And then you, you like, ran.
I was just like, okay, I don't know if he's muted or anything.
I don't...
Okay, not gonna lie.
Sometimes, like, I don't hear any words at all.
It's like, I'm just so genuinely focused.
And I, like, cast, like, words, like, come out the other ear.
I'm so sorry.
That's funny.
It's just the way Gerard T.
Rexford's built.
I'm sorry.
I'm built different, and I'm sorry about that.
We won, though.
It's okay.
Yeah, we won.
We won.
It's okay.
We literally...
I don't know if we're actually top four.
I saw someone in my chat said top four.
So they could be gaslighting.
We might not even be.
We might not be.
We're gonna get...
Next one.
For sure.
We're definitely not last.
That's for sure.
Not last.
Okay, I'm gonna learn from that.
It's like, I'm not, I'm not gonna fight when you say run.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm gonna apply that to my, my AI.
AI of a brain.
I'm gonna do that.
I think, I think...
Yeah, like, just run.
If I'm down, you fucking run.
Yeah, I'm running.
I'm definitely gonna run.
Do I pick up your stuff or...
No, no, you fucking just leave.
Just leave?
Just leave.
How do I revive you?
You can craft.
You craft this.
Okay, okay, okay.
It doesn't matter anymore.
You don't have to pick us up anymore.
You just gotta craft this.
Oh, okay.
All right.
Watch this rampart.
It's time to VOD review.
You watch this rampart.
Yeah, I'm watching it right now.
Checking the six.
Okay, also, Gerard, you gotta not rely...
You need to stop relying on your minigun.
I'm sorry.
It's just so cool to bring it out.
I know, I know.
I feel like every time we're close to anybody, you just bring out the minigun.
It's a quick problem solver.
Like, health gone.
That's me.
That's my brain.
Shooty, shooty, bang, bang.
Okay, okay.
Learn it.
Got it.
Note taken.
All right.
My chat is at that part where we're yelling at you to run.
And everybody in my chat was just like, no, not to them.
Yeah, that's what my chat says.
They're giving chance to others.
Yeah, yeah, because we won.
Yeah, exactly.
Won other teams that have a chance too.
Exactly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It wouldn't be really fun if we actually won another one.
Just saying.
I'm okay.
Not gonna lie.
I'm still caught up on the win, though, because my heart is still racing.
You're still thinking about it.
Yeah, because you guys are having wins and dubs every single time.
Me, this is like a first time.
Like a legit thing.
Like, I only won five times in like throughout my entire life.
Just five times.
Wait, apparently.
Apparently, the team that won a 1v1 against was Estelle's team.
Yo, you beat your senpai!
You actually predicted that shit!
Oh my god!
I didn't think we'd be running into them!
Holy crap!
Oh my god, you did it.
I'm going to be a senpai!
Holy crap!
How do you feel, Droid?
How do you feel?
I feel so fucking pumped.
I sure do hope that they don't get angry at me.
Because there's this fucking bronze guy inside this very serious tournament.
I am so...
Aste-senpai, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
I didn't mean it.
I was just here to have fun.
I didn't think we'd be actually winning.
My god.
I'm just here to fill in a role.
You just have to believe, Droid.
You just have to believe.
You believe.
Yeah, believe.
The power in believing in yourself.
I get it now.
My chat caught up.
We are top 4.
Yeah, top 4!
I don't think we're top 4 after this, though.
We're not going to be top 4 anymore.
I don't think anymore.
But like, we were top 4.
Great, great, great, great.
What are the requirements for us to actually...
Top 10.
...win to go to top 10?
Wait, we need...
No, well, to go to Japan, we have to win-win.
But that's on the day 3.
That's on day 3.
But right now, we gotta get to top 10.
Okay, all right.
All right.
Gotcha, gotcha, gotcha.
The top...
That's crazy.
We're 16 points behind first and 16 points ahead 11.
Oh, so it's very close.
Because we're only 16 points ahead of 11th place.
Great, great.
I'm feeling good about this one.
It could be anyone's game here.
All right, I think we might need to play safe for that then.
Because the lead is not that far off.
Flame, what's the strat for the last game?
Is it still the same map?
We just do the same thing?
Yep.
Yeah, same map.
We just do the same thing and hope we don't get ran at again.
I mean, we almost won that fight.
See, the Rampart's using the thingy, the machine gun.
Okay, but...
They're using it, why can't I use it?
Jirai, do you think she's bronze, Jirai?
Everyone is!
I'm sorry to make mistakes, Jirai, but they're not bronze.
You need to know when you can use it and when you don't.
Like, when you can't use it, you know?
But I feel it, though!
I feel it in my bones!
I think they know, and I don't.
I'm not sure if you do, Jirai.
Oh yeah, I do.
I'm not sure if you do.
I know.
Jirai!
You just have to believe.
What happened to believing in me?
Jirai, you bring out your anger!
I'm sorry, Jirai.
If believing was all it took to turn someone into a pro player, I think we'd have a lot more pro players, Jirai.
We have to believe!
If we don't believe, then there's no way we can do it!
Yeah, but he has to give you rea- Jirai, there's delusional, and there's delusions!
Our delusion is actually worse than theirs!
There's confidence, Jirai, and then there's delusion, okay?
I'm just saying!
I think you're- We won, and despite everything, I think we can do this!
You're a little bit past- I think you're a little bit past confidence, Jirai.
Yeah!
I think we need to give you a little bit of a reality check.
The reality is- You're a pro player, and he needs to give you a reality check right now.
No, no, no, no.
The reality is, anything is possible.
It could be anyone's game, right?
Okay.
It could be anyone.
Jirai, I also think that- Jirai, okay, so like- But the thing- The difference between this Rampart- You see that she has her regular gun out?
Yeah, you see that?
Uh-huh, yeah, you're right.
You see- You see she has her normal gun out?
But I'm different, though!
I'm different!
Where's the- I'm built different, Jirai.
I'm built different.
You see how she's shooting with her triple take?
Listen, listen.
As long as we believe, anything's possible.
If you- If she brought out her minigun, do you think that would have been a smarter idea?
It's all right!
A gun's a gun!
Man, anything's possible.
But okay, fine, fine, fine.
That's true, anything's possible.
We did win first!
I will concede.
For the sake of win- Okay, I won't bring out my machine gun.
I will, I promise.
Just don't bring it out every time.
You gotta limit yourself.
You gotta know the scenario.
When they're like, you know, when they're all up in our face, then you bring the machine gun.
That's what I did in the last one!
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, like the 1v1 thing.
I was like, okay, okay.
There's no reload in here.
So, yeah, it's great.
See, situational awareness!
My brain's growing!
Oh, shit!
Headcrack!
Oh, that was a good shot.
That was a really good shot.
Yeah, headshot too!
From that far off!
That was- That damage was basically...
Okay, I shouldn't- What?
What?
What are you guys saying?
That was 102 damage.
So...
I don't think you're gonna say something nice.
What she made in that one shot...
I said I knew it!
I knew we were gonna say that!
I fucking knew it!
I fucking knew it.
I had a hunch.
Thanks for being on my team.
You're welcome, you're welcome.
Anytime, anytime.
No, it's an honor.
I drove this.
Yeah, we- I mean, we won!
We won first.
Yeah, we won!
Top 4 from that last game is already more than enough.
More than what I expected.
Yeah, more than enough.
I think this will top most of my memories here in Hall of Stars.
But you're- In 20 years, you're just gonna think about- I think this is the most memorable one so far.
In 20 years, you're gonna think back to this game.
Yeah?
Remember that one time when I actually won at something in Apex?
Yeah, this is it.
You get flexed to your- Like 80 years old and I'm still thinking about it.
You get flexed to your armist members and be like, I won a game!
I won a game.
You guys were dragging me down!
That's what!
You fucking know it!
You guys are a bunch of failures!
I could do shit alone!
Hey, you see- Oh my god!
Oh fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck!
Ayyy!
She lost though.
That was nice!
Okay, but like, this rampart we're watching?
She didn't bring her minigun out.
The rampart that died brought her minigun out and she died.
Okay, now, okay, okay.
That was me.
That would have been me in alternate reality.
I'm learning, I'm learning.
See, see, see, this is good body review.
This is a really good body review.
You're getting better.
Yeah, I'm actually learning.
It's like watching YouTube videos.
Or like, uh, yeah.
It's like I'm watching a stream.
It's like people watch Apex streamers to get better.
Whoa!
Yeah, I will usually watch.
It's Timmy.
Is It's Timmy here?
Uh, oh, sorry.
No, he's addicted to Marvel Rivals.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, whoa!
Oh, this team.
Oh, no, there's a rodent!
Oh, God!
Oh, yeah, goodbye.
And they got top ten though.
Oh.
Top ten is pretty good.
Nice.
They got points for that.
Do they have another...
Oh, they have another rampart.
What the fuck?
It is the meta.
No, everybody's running rampart.
Well, they ran Valk.
That's interesting.
I didn't know if Valk was still good.
Oh, my God, this team.
Yo, they're behind a door!
No, this new castle is locked in.
Oh, my God, it's so funny.
Oh, my God.
No, that's Sakura.
It's so chaotic.
Are they still in...
Yeah, there's...
They're barely outside, barely inside a ring.
Oh, my God.
Flame, have you ever played in these JP tournaments before?
Oh, I think he left.
I think he left us.
Oh, no!
You mean like a VTuber one?
Yeah, yeah, these...
No, this is my first one.
Your first one?
What do you think?
This is like a Manday game or something.
Oh, yeah, yeah, I was there.
Yeah, I think there were VTubers in that one, but it's not a Japanese one, right?
Yeah, yeah, no, that one was more like casual.
Because that one was like non-Apex VTubers.
We're participating in it.
But this one is like majority are like...
They play Apex.
Because it's like...
Except for my teammates.
Oh, yeah.
Did you have two pros on your team?
Yeah, our third, like, didn't show up.
So they...
Yes, empty.
Yeah, I was like, the fuck?
I was like, I saw that.
I was like, this is bullshit.
Your VTuber literally didn't show up.
Wait, really?
Yeah, there was a...
There was a...
Not my custom, Jared, but like there was a different custom that was like VTuber, content creator and pro player.
And then like their VTuber didn't show up.
So their team was literally just an Apex team.
And there was money involved, too.
No, listen, listen.
I had a...
I had a restriction imposed on me.
I could only use one gun.
Yeah, you had only one gun.
Oh, no.
Forgot about that.
No, this is a different...
This one was a different...
It's not my custom, Jared.
It's a different one.
Because every team still had a VTuber.
They didn't.
Oh, OK, OK, OK.
Yeah, I was like, holy fuck.
I can't believe this team...
I remember because I was like, why does this team have empty and flame?
I was like...
No, I think that was fair.
I think that was fair.
Oh, yeah, it was...
Bro, Apex team had like Chibidoki and Nags.
What the fuck do you mean?
Like, what the fuck do you mean?
They play Apex, but they're not at like...
OK, listen, listen.
Listen, you're like complaining about my team.
But did you see Phony's team?
What was Phony's team?
And Zero's team?
What was...
Oh, wait, Zero's team was actual full Apex players, too.
No, they're...
Yeah, yeah, look.
JPeebs is a dip, but he was doing OK.
And Eliyup was cooking.
Eliyup was so good.
How does that balance out?
She's like a Phony.
She was a full...
Yeah, yeah, she's a full Apex player.
Hey, Phony was playing with Stormin and like an X-Pro.
I forgot which one exactly, but he was playing with Stormin and an X-Pro.
And ours, it just is.
Yeah.
OK, to be fair, that custom, like, I think 50% dropped out in less than a minute.
Literally, they were grabbing people on the last hour.
Oh, God.
Yeah, it was Mandy's custom.
I know, like, they were asking so many random people if they wanted to join the custom because so many people dropped out last minute.
Just random people just looking for more because everyone just dropped out.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
OK, so...
That's crazy.
All right.
What map is this?
It's still World's Edge.
We never change maps when we're still there.
Yeah, OK, OK, OK.
All right, all right, all right, all right.
A video just came on my feed.
Apparently, someone did 52 kills solo.
What?
In this?
In Apex, yeah.
OK, so there's two things.
He was on console.
He 3-stacked with a Lifeline and a Newcastle and they were dropping him armors and...
And I think the third most important part, I think he's literally cheating.
He's using like some sort of recall script.
It does not move at all.
Nice.
It's disgusting.
They could be in a bot lobby.
They could have glitches.
It's a...
Oh, it's a different one.
Lobby.
Oh, it's a ranked lobby.
It's in ranked.
Yeah, it's in a ranked lobby.
Oh, it's...
Oh, man.
It is like flat at the end of the season.
So it's like it is really bad.
But 52 kills.
That's crazy.
I didn't even know that was possible.
Yeah.
Isn't there like 60 people in the lobby?
I think even if he is using like recall scripts, 52s.
That's an insane jump.
Did everybody just drop fucking like near him?
In his surroundings?
No, I don't.
I think nobody, just nobody fought.
Nobody fought.
Nobody can ricochet to every single one of them.
Everyone just fought him.
Everybody...
I guess it's like...
It's like...
In ranked, everyone does just run away and craft, you know?
Yeah.
It reminded me of like...
52 kills, I think that was like...
It reminded me of when like Apex didn't have a custom lobby and scrims were just...
Were just gotta be like 3, 2, 1 and then queue up and quit.
That's what...
Oh, my god.
Yeah, that's how they...
That's how they do scrims.
Like they literally...
There was no way to have custom lobbies.
So everybody was like 3, 2, 1, queue.
Was this like season zero?
Yeah.
Do you know how I knew about that?
I accidentally got into a scrim.
No!
And you were just like 3, 2, 1...
No, it was back...
No, I literally was just queuing...
Queuing quick play with a friend.
And then we were so confused because we were like...
Why isn't anybody fighting?
Like we were so...
And then...
And it was back when Aceu was still in the team.
So that was how long it was.
It was when Aceu was still playing.
I remember what team he was on.
And then we were like, where is everybody?
So we locked ourselves in the house because we were so confused.
Because literally first ring close, no one was dead.
And then we saw the names and we're like, wait, aren't those pro players?
We're like, wait a minute.
Those are pro player names.
We're like, oh my god, we're in a fucking pro lobby.
But what are the odds though that you managed to like time it right exactly during the tournament?
Yeah, I know.
I think that was a calling for you.
I knew Aceu was in the lobby because we died to Aceu.
We were like...
It was back in like the original...
I don't remember what frag the city.
It was in the city.
And you know that door with the house with windows on it?
So we're just sitting in there.
And then we saw a team run up at us and we were just like sat looking at them outside the window.
And they were looking at us because...
And then they were like, what the fuck are they doing?
It's just like, what the fuck are they doing?
Just standing there in the house looking at us.
That is crazy.
So like...
Oh, Jarrod didn't get in again.
I don't feel lucky or unlucky with that.
Did you at least win?
You didn't get in.
We got to get you back in.
What?
I was just here.
Jarrod didn't get in again, I'm sorry.
I'm literally outside here.
The fuck?
Dude, look, look, look at my screen.
I'm literally just waiting for everyone.
What?
Oh my God, look, look.
I'm suddenly holding back everybody again.
Okay, wait, I think I'm in here.
I think I'm in here.
No, no, no.
We know you're not.
Oh, wait, wait, he got in, he got in, he got in.
Wait, wait, wait, I got in, I got in.
He just loaded in.
Oh, stop, stop, stop, guys, guys, don't cancel the match.
I think I might still restart anyways.
They've already said it.
Jarrod is in lava siphon.
Wait, what?
Yeah, I am.
No, no, he's in siphon.
Oh, what?
Okay, they separated me from all of you.
The fuck?
What?
This is insane.
I just got here.
Oh my God.
What?
What the?
Jarrod, did you not, did you, did you like not want to play with us that bad?
Bro, what are you doing over there, man?
I just got here.
What are you doing over there, bro?
Siphon, we need to siphon.
Dude, dude, I said it.
Oh my God.
You should say that in chat.
What the hell?
I didn't, I'm not rigging this.
I got this thing on fucking stream.
Okay, we don't say anything.
They won't know who, let's not, let's not say anything.
So they won't know it's our fault.
They won't, they won't, I'm in fucking siphon.
We literally got evidence of it on stream.
How much did you get?
Oh no.
Oh my God.
I don't know.
It always seems to happen every single tournament.
Okay, match starting.
Okay, I can see it starting.
There we go.
We're starting.
We don't say anything.
They won't know it's our fault.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, we're just going to shut up about it.
No one's going to know.
This is between all of us.
Thank you again.
We don't know how he got to, don't know how he spawned in siphon.
Oh, most players respond at invalid POIs.
Oh no.
I didn't know that was a thing.
So see, it wasn't our fault.
It wasn't our fault.
That's crazy.
He just didn't want to play with us anyway.
He wanted to join a different team.
No, that was not me.
Okay, fine.
Fine.
Whatever.
Okay, you bullied him too much.
Wait, me?
You were part of the problem too.
No, no.
You gave him a reality check.
Stop pointing the finger at me.
You're the one who started this, Doki.
He's just enabling.
Wait, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Turat looked up to you and you gave him a reality check.
I mean, that was helpful advice.
Yours not.
There's a difference.
Well, you were not happy when he gave you that reality check.
I remember that.
No, I was happy.
I was happy.
When you start saying shit from your mouth, I don't appreciate that at all.
You just hear my voice and you're like, I'm not happy.
My criticism comes from a good place, right?
Doki's just...
Wait, I just want you to talk to me.
My criticism comes from a good place, right?
Doki's comes from like, just a very negative, like...
Yeah, that's right.
He just wants to put you down, you know?
I would never do that to you.
No, but I do it for content.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I believe in flame.
Droid, droid, droid.
But I do it for content.
Like, that comes from a good place.
That's just unbelievable.
That's unbelievable.
That is just an admission of guilt on the highest level.
See, I knew it.
Like, she sacrificed your well-being for a content.
My mental health?
Unreal, unreal, unreal.
I'd never do this to you, Droid.
But Droid, you're sacrificing your mental health for clips.
Oh yeah, you're right, you're right, you're right.
Clip farming, clip farming, you're right.
You're clip farming.
Yeah, that's right, that's right, that's right.
You got me on that one.
Yeah, see, there you are, as if you don't want to get a clip farm.
Don't fucking lie to me.
Be a little nicer to me, please.
You know you want to get clip farm.
Don't fucking lie to me.
Oh, you're right.
You know my grind.
You just, you gotta watch your back, Doki.
I'm gonna come out with a bit longer of my experience with Doki Bird.
Which was all lies, by the way.
Doki Bird, my experience.
My experience, not if I come out with it first.
Oh, shit.
Nah, that's just landing.
We have that on tape, blackmail.
Mutual assured destruction.
My favorite.
I need, like, an actual gun.
I have a headlock.
I don't have anything here.
Do you want a Prowler?
That's all I got.
No, no, absolutely not.
I have a 3x.
I don't see anybody there yet.
I want a headscan near a monument.
Yeah, I'm heading over there now, but I don't see anybody on it.
I don't know if they scanned already.
Should we go, or no?
Yeah, you can go.
Okay, I need to wait for...
I'm just following Flame.
Gonna go on his way.
No, no, no, no, no.
Go, go towards...
No, no, no, go to me, and then...
That's the same thing we've done.
I just need...
There's a, uh...
Someone needs to hit the blue bin up here.
Um...
Okay, okay, okay.
I can get it.
Uh, they redeploy, they redeploy.
Yeah, that's good.
We can just run straight at them.
Okay.
All right, let's go.
They're flying, and they're fighting through the choke.
Yeah.
All right, Jiraiya, come, come, come, come, come.
I'm gonna do a bubble for you.
Coming, coming, coming.
Uh, I'm gonna get the cache while I...
I'm waiting for it, Jiraiya.
Wait!
Oh, that's you, okay.
They're coming on us, flying on us!
In the open, Pathfinder!
Come here.
I think we just fight this first.
Okay.
Is there a last game, though, Flame?
Are you sure?
Uh, yeah, he's just really close.
I don't know where he's going, though.
Oh, he ran him off.
I'm gonna get the...
Oh, he's gone, he's gone.
He's... you can... you can scan, you can scan.
Okay, I'm gonna get the cache.
Uh, just go back, Jiraiya, and scan this.
Yeah, Jiraiya, go back to the... go back here, go back here.
Look at this.
I'm gonna go up top and look for you guys.
You guys just hit scan.
Jiraiya, are you here?
Yep, yep.
I'm waiting, I'm waiting.
I don't want to waste my cooldown here.
I need a scope here, guys.
I have a 1x on my mouse.
I have a colo, that's it.
Yeah.
Oh!
Okay, he's really close.
Oh, Jonas.
Okay.
Where should we go?
I'm...
If we can be in one of these chokes, that'd be really good, but I don't think we can.
I don't know if we can cross it at this time.
Anymore?
Yeah, just... just come over, like, to the left side of Fragment here.
We might have to play underneath the bridge on my ping.
Okay.
But we'll see.
Just come up.
All right, I'm gonna wait for Dryad a little bit.
Okay, here I am.
Yeah, I think it's buff taken already.
Just, uh, come up this way first.
All right.
We need to be really careful because I think Epicenter Overlook could be on us here.
All right, I'm with you.
I'm...
Following through.
Battery...
Okay.
Don't need that.
I think we just go in the geyser here.
I have, uh, a vault key.
Uh, are we safe to rotate with Overlook in?
Uh, I think we should be okay.
I think Overlook's rotated out.
Okay.
We want to get the Respawn Beacon here and just look around, make sure we're actually safe first.
Uh-oh.
Sniper.
Sniper?
Where?
It's probably...
Oh no, I think it's just, like, uh, I heard it.
Okay.
No one's shooting at me.
Oh!
Oh, there it is!
I got shot in.
Just come sit down.
I can work it.
It's fine.
I'm just gonna grab this and...
Let me know if you find light ammo.
I just grabbed the... I changed my loadout entirely.
Yep.
All right, so I don't have a lot of ammo.
Also, Jared, you don't have to wait for me.
Just go for it.
If I'm looting something, just go for it.
Okay.
All right.
So don't...
You don't loot, I loot.
You just go for it.
How many batteries do you have, Jared?
Uh, I have one.
Uh, I'm gonna drop you two here.
Okay, thank you.
Uh, Doki, I think you hit this...
Thank you!
Hit this cache.
Thank you.
Okay.
Uh, get the... get the small bubble.
The small bubble?
Reduce tackle size and cooldown, baby bubble?
Okay.
Oh, on us, on us, on us!
All right, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
You're by yourself, you're by yourself, Flame.
You're by yourself.
I have to loot.
I'm here.
He was on the small door.
He's... run back.
Hit 30 on this.
Oh, shit!
Someone's shooting from here!
There's people to the left, too.
On the left door.
There's two in front of me.
Okay.
Careful.
I'm okay.
Pushing!
I'm pushing!
I'm covering!
He grappled back.
They're getting shot in the back!
We can walk up.
Okay.
Come.
Careful.
Flush!
Walk up!
I got him!
I'm healing!
Oh, I got slain.
I flushed!
I finished him!
Nice!
We want to fight this!
Okay.
I'm pushing up.
You're only drive next to you.
I had to...
Um...
I had to get that angle to get him.
They went to the left.
They went left.
They went... I think he went to this house.
Did he?
He might...
No, no, no!
On me!
Okay, okay!
Go to him!
Go to him, Jord!
Are you sure we have to save the chase this far?
No, no, no.
We stop right here.
I'm covering.
I'm trying to cover.
That's his teammate shooting me with the triple take.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's fine.
I'm gonna stay here.
I'm staying here.
I'm entering here.
I'm just getting the thirst here.
Yeah, we just go back.
I'm walking.
We just go back to red.
Go back.
Okay.
Ow!
Fuck!
Fine.
I'm gonna go bubble this box for loot.
Yeah.
Uh, there's a scout here.
God!
Ow!
Okay.
There's a scope.
I can drop a 3x.
You want it?
No.
Uh, I got the 3x.
Okay.
Oh, shit!
There's no more.
There's more.
Just...
Yeah, just be careful.
We don't want to lose this here.
I'm gonna bubble that again.
I don't... What guns do they have in there?
I don't remember.
Uh...
I'm gonna check, actually.
I don't need a bubble for this.
It's an EVA-8.
I'm fine.
All right, where do we go?
Uh, we just sit here for a while until we see zone.
If the zone pulls like this, uh, the other side, we might have to go into geyser.
Okay.
And just wrap the back.
Hit a Newcastle 100 in here.
I have 53 on him.
Oh my god!
He destroyed my door.
Maybe I should get a G7 scout.
No, I can't 1v1 with a G7 scout.
I don't know if that's worth it.
Is it worth it for Lasky?
You might run whatever you want.
I know, but is it worth it though?
Probably.
Eh, I'll run... I'll run Carbide.
I'm more familiar with it.
We got kills at least.
We have...
What?
I hit 50 on the Gibby.
Let me know if you guys see energy.
Okay.
I might just go loot this box, I'm not gonna lie.
That car box?
Yeah.
I'll look for it for a bit.
Like ulti back?
Fine.
I'll scout them while you do that.
Yeah, okay, you had energy.
Perfect.
They're fighting over in Fragment?
Mmhmm.
Oh, that's perfect.
They got an evac.
I'm looking.
Oh, Mythic.
Supply bin is out.
I got an ultimate accelerant here if you guys want.
Hold on, we don't need it yet, but hold on to it for now?
Yeah, definitely hold on to it, it's really good.
Yeah.
Okay, get ready to move here in 30 seconds.
Yeah, I'm looking at...
Are they just fighting in Fragment?
I'm looking west side right now.
I'm looking at Geyser to see if anybody's sneaking up there.
I wonder if there's a team in Geyser.
That's what I'm afraid of.
Yeah, definitely probably is.
Get ready to move.
Oh, I didn't see them there.
Oh, oh, but we can cross their zone.
Yeah, we have to go through Geyser.
Yeah, Dry, come, come, come, come, Dry.
We have to go now.
We're wrapping behind Geyser.
Yeah, you have to come, come now.
We want to be under the bridge here.
There's batteries here.
I don't need batteries, I have four.
You should grab batteries, Druid.
What's going on?
Got him.
We don't have much time.
Yeah.
Yeah, we want to be under that bridge.
That's like the only safe spot pretty much.
I'm looking to our left just in case.
There's a gold...
There's a blue cache here.
Nice to go.
All right.
Keep going, keep going, keep going.
We do not have time here.
We gotta keep going, keep running.
Oh, you're fighting in front of us.
That's really good for us.
Just full heal, full heal right away.
I have the syringe.
Yeah.
Syringe, syringe the moment you get in, Dry.
Yep, yep, yep.
They're fighting right here, here.
Just walk up.
I'm walking behind you.
I'm a gunner just in case.
No, no, no.
Come, come, we're hitting this Geyser.
Should we do it still?
Just hit the Geyser, hit the Geyser.
Where do we go, where do we go, Geyser?
We have to wait for Gerard.
All right, come on.
Come to me.
Here, here, here, come here, come here.
Come here.
Okay, going, going, going.
Yeah, the reason...
Run, run, run.
I'm ready, I'm ready, I'm ready.
Just...
Oh, he can watch us, he can watch us.
Okay, go, go, go, go, okay.
Land, land underneath here.
Just keep, keep running with it, keep running with it.
Yeah.
Yep, keep running.
Go straight, keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going.
Slide if you have to.
Keep going.
In the open here, Maggie.
Okay, I'm looking.
On HP, dead, dead, dead.
Lifeline.
Florescent, florescent.
Nice, good, there's...
Wait, just sit here, just sit here and look for these kills, look for these kills.
I'm looking behind, I'm looking behind, just in case.
I'm gonna look behind.
Okay, go ahead, yep.
Just come, someone else look here, heal skills.
One more, one more.
In zone, in zone.
Gibby.
He's dead.
Oh, wow.
Oh, we didn't get that kill.
It's fine, it's fine.
I'm gonna look, I'm gonna look just in case.
Listen, we need to make a run for this.
We should go now, we should go now.
You have to be careful of the buff, get rid of your bubble.
Come to road, stay with us.
Hug right, hug right.
Just hug right.
We're safe on me, safe on me, just keep going.
Keep going, keep going.
Full heal, full heal.
Just full heal and bubble first.
Go as soon as you're done healing, I'll look for you guys.
I'm right behind you, I'm right behind you.
Yeah, we're okay, just keep going.
There's a team, but they're getting the guy.
I think...
Do you want me to come to you, or no?
I think the safe spot is like...
Yeah, I think it's on me, I think it's on me.
Okay, I can stay here for now.
And Jarrad, you go to flame, you go to flame, Jarrad.
I have bubble, so if anything happens, I can just bubble.
And we have a crafter here.
Yeah, I think we're okay here.
I'm gonna look behind, I'm looking this way, I'm looking this way.
If you need me to shoot something, just tell me, I'll turn around.
Because I have my crafting as a cover.
Okay.
We have to be really careful of teams like flying on us.
That's probably our biggest threat.
Yeah, I'm looking, I'm just looking this way.
We can play above us, but I don't...
I don't think it's safe.
I don't know if it'll be worth it.
I don't think so.
It'll be safe for sure, because we have rampart and new castle.
But I mean, I don't have wall.
I hear something on my left.
I think that's above me.
We could get pinched really hard.
Yeah.
No, I'm peeking.
Is there a team right here?
I think it's just better.
I think we should just go up top, to be honest.
Jarrad, you go up top.
I'll go last.
And you just set up.
And I'll go now.
We just set up right here on my corner here, Jarrad.
You just have to start like, putting rampart walls.
Like, uh, put rampart walls towards this way.
And then put some towards the left.
I'll stay in the bottom for now.
And I'll come up later.
I want to make sure there's...
Put another one like...
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm here.
Don't box us in.
Two seconds.
Yeah.
Don't box us in.
Make sure we have...
No, no, no.
Move it a little bit more forward.
So we can like, walk like right here, you know?
They're pushing.
They might push.
They're walking up.
They're slowly walking up.
They're right here.
Just look.
Okay, no, no.
That's fine.
Just come up.
It's okay.
I'm coming up now.
They're fighting right here.
We might have kills right there.
As soon as smoke fades.
Look at this.
Okay, okay.
I'm here.
There's enemies over here.
Uh, he's totally down.
Right here?
There's a guy right here.
Yeah.
He's...
Oh, they're rotating.
They're rotating.
Nah, nothing, nothing.
Uh, Jarrad.
If we're shooting like that, you have to look at the other angle.
Okay, Jarrad.
Uh, look at zone.
Look at zone.
Fuck.
Okay.
Is it over here?
Um, wait.
I'm walking forward here.
Okay, come over there.
Come over there.
Okay, I'm coming over here.
I'm okay.
Just chill, chill, chill, chill, chill.
We're gonna walk for the crane here.
I'm looking behind us just in case.
Yeah, we just...
We just go back again.
Go back again.
Listen, we need to hold our northeast side here.
And then our play is to jump towards the crane here late.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm looking back.
There's a guy right here.
There's a guy.
There's a team.
There's a team right here.
Okay, I'm looking in front.
I'm looking in front.
They threw a rez beacon out.
I'm looking.
They're planting a rezzing.
Oh, they're rezzing.
I think we maybe just drop down here.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You drop down.
You drop, drop, drop with it.
You go now.
Come with me.
Come with...
No, no.
Come with us.
Okay.
Uh, zipping.
No, that's fine.
Go now.
Come with me.
Just keep coming.
Keep coming.
Landing on us.
No, above us.
We're okay.
Just sit here.
Get ready to bubble.
They might drop on us here.
Send, send rampart covers.
Anywhere.
Just put, put walls.
Put walls, Gerard.
Put walls.
Just start putting walls.
Yeah.
We need to look up here, Doki.
I'm looking up.
Okay.
Uh, I'm, I'm walling towards the left here.
There's a team out in the left.
We have to get...
They have...
We have to kill this team.
Okay, okay, I'm looking.
Gerard, you have to just sit behind the rampart.
Hey, yeah, give us walls.
Give us walls.
They're right here.
They're right here behind us.
They're behind us.
One second, one second.
There's a team right in front of us.
I'm going to look.
Be careful behind us.
There's a team right in front.
I'm, I'm shooting.
I'm shooting this team.
They're in the open.
We just have to spread attention here.
I'm safe.
Okay, okay.
I'm shooting this team.
I'm shooting this team in front of me.
There's a, there's a full team in Gibby bubble in front of me here.
They're going to walk at us.
This team has to die, Doki.
This team is walking.
I'm, I'm ulting.
Walking at us?
Yeah, yeah.
Fuck.
Just chill, chill towards us, Doki.
I'm, I'm bubbling.
I'm bubbling.
There's a team literally in front of me.
I have to, I have to ult it.
They bubble too.
I knocked one.
Just crouching here in front of me.
There's two teams on us.
Okay, okay, okay.
I think, I think we have to focus towards Doki's side.
Go, go, go Doki's side.
He's rezzing.
Just push this.
Push this, push this, push this.
Push this.
Get in.
Do you have bubble?
I used it, I used it.
Two seconds, two seconds.
Okay, okay.
Oh shit.
I got, I got the bubble.
Bubble, bubble.
Nice, nice.
There's a Kraber there, Doki.
I'm not gonna take it.
You got that, I believe.
All right, we're gonna go back here.
We're gonna go back.
Go back, go back.
Actually, uh, I'll take the Kraber.
I'll take the Kraber now.
Yeah.
It's four bullets though.
They're fighting the other side of our wall here.
Just, just set Rampart, uh, set, set Rampart walls on me.
On me, on me, on me, on me.
Yeah, yeah, just set.
No, it's the right and the left.
There's a team just playing on the other side here.
Doki, can you come bubble up on this?
We swing this team.
Ready?
Yeah, bubble.
One, two, three, go.
On me, on me, on me, on me.
Bubbling.
It's a solo Newcastle.
Get this kill, get this kill.
Dead.
Nice, nice.
Come back, come back.
Come back in the bubble.
Full team, full team now.
Go back, go back, go back, go back.
Go back and then heal.
We have to look left here.
They ulted again.
No bubble, no bubble, no bubble.
Come to me, come to me, come to me, come to me.
Crouch on me, we're okay.
We have to look left here.
Just full heal first.
I'm looking left, I'm looking left.
Okay, look with me.
Yeah.
They're behind, they're behind this box here.
One down, one down, I think.
I'm peeking this, I'm peeking this.
I need a bubble, I need a bubble.
They ulted us, they ulted us, they ulted us.
I killed one, I killed one.
Oh, I got hit, I got hit by the ult.
Yeah.
I have no shields, I have no shields.
I have no shields.
Gerard, give me shields, Gerard, give me shields.
Drop shields.
Okay, uh, here.
Thank you.
That's all I have.
That's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
I have bubble on A, I have bubble on A.
I'm just pushing.
I got him.
Nice.
Look above, look above, look above.
I have to heal, I have to heal.
People are gonna start dropping on us soon.
Get ready.
Okay.
We have end zone, guys.
Come, come set up on end zone here.
Gerard, put rampart covers on the outside.
On me, uh...
On me, Gerard, on me, facing this way.
Facing the left.
There's a team top crane!
Team top crane, we can fuck!
I can't see, I can't see, I got hit!
I can't see.
Okay.
I naded them, jumping, jumping on us, jumping on us!
Jumping on us!
Kill this, kill this!
One HP, give me!
Ah, god, ah!
Hey, chill, chill, chill, chill, chill.
I'm okay, I'm okay.
They're fighting up top, top floor.
I can push, I can push, I'm pushing.
Fuck.
Oh, they're fighting up here, okay.
There's a team on our left.
Above us, above us.
On our left.
I killed one.
I got Gerard, I got Gerard there.
Just chill.
We have to walk forward.
We have to walk forward, yeah.
Oh, I quit!
Oh, we got third, though.
MT, MT, MT.
I think, yeah, yeah.
Ah!
MT.
We got third!
That's a good game, though, for us.
Yeah, it's nice.
That's a really good game.
Yeah.
Ah.
Surviving is fast.
Oh, that was intense, though.
So true.
They just had high ground, we couldn't really, they just had high ground.
Yeah, it's really rough.
Yeah.
The team on the crane, instead of thirding the team that's, like, fighting under them, it's just, like, completely pushed us.
Yeah, that's fine.
I got, I got two kills off of that, though.
Nice.
Hundred damage.
Again.
Whoa, that's all I could do.
That's good!
That's solid!
Okay, I think we got top ten.
I think, with those places, we must have got top ten.
We got ten kills!
Oh, my gosh.
Yay!
We should be top, we could even be top five.
You'd be what?
We could be top three, but we should be top five.
Whoa, top five!
That's crazy!
Bro, Flame's IGLing is insane!
Are we actually, somebody back check that one right now!
Yeah.
Guys, you gotta check out Strafe and Flame on Twitter and YouTube and Twitch.
His IGL's fucking insane.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, follow his journey.
He's gonna win every tournament, please.
Follow his champion's journey.
Anyway, Strafe and Flame, you should totally try out Marvel Rivals rink.
Yeah, you should.
Yeah?
Yeah.
What do you have against me, huh?
How do you want to see me fail so bad?
What's going on?
It's fun.
Go ahead, try it.
Man, it's so fun.
At least you're not solo queuing.
You got dokie once you get used to it, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
You can play with me!
But only for your GM, though.
When you hit GM.
You can able each other!
That's great!
Okay.
That's fine.
It's okay.
I mean, we did so well.
I'm actually so proud of us.
But because we did so well, we might need to play another six games today.
Holy fuck, are you serious?
Yo!
But we don't have to play tomorrow.
Oh, that's great.
Okay.
Yeah, we don't have to play tomorrow.
If we win those six games, by the way.
If we're top 10 in those six games, we don't have to play tomorrow.
All right, all right.
It's just like ALGS.
Isn't that great?
Wait, is tomorrow's like loser bracket, right?
Yeah, it's loser bracket.
Okay, okay, okay.
So as long as, you know, we win those six...
We do great.
We're not going to be playing again tomorrow.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
So that's motivation, right, Flame?
Uh, I'm not gonna lie.
I have one review plan for like, uh, APMS GTs.
I have to cancel that first.
Give me one second.
Yeah, I thought we only had six games.
You're like, we have something more important.
This is a lot more important.
That's fine.
I mean, it's a free trip to Japan, you know, just saying.
Yeah, it's a free trip to Japan, just saying.
I mean, you already got yourself booked in there, man.
I don't think you need this.
Wait, but what about us?
I thought we needed it.
I thought you were gonna do it for him.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
Okay, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
My believing mechanic is like, wavering right now.
Yeah, I thought you wanted to do it for him.
What happened?
Yeah, I'm gonna do it for him.
I'm gonna.
Okay, cool.
Yeah, that's why we're gonna do great this time.
We're gonna do so well.
I mean, again, we're gonna do great again, so we don't have to play again tomorrow.
Exactly, exactly.
Yeah, we're gonna finish this thing in one fell swoop.
So we don't have to do anything anymore.
No, we still have to show up on day three.
If ever we do lose, if ever we do lose, like, um, what time?
Um, what time?
I think it's the same time.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
It should be the same time.
We better not be there tomorrow because I have something important to do tomorrow.
Oh, yeah, yeah, you have.
Uh-oh.
I have a bunch of stuff that I need to do.
Yeah, you do.
So we better do great.
Flame, no pressure, Flame.
No pressure at all.
No pressure, no pressure.
If I miss tomorrow's something, it's all your fault.
Just saying.
No pressure, no pressure.
Whoa!
That's so fucked up!
I think I'm gonna play with a monitor turned off challenge, guys.
No, no, no, seriously, let's do it.
It's fine, it's fine, it's okay.
You think it's too easy?
No, you're right.
I should play with a computer turned off challenge.
Oh, no!
Bro!
Wait, wait, how many people are here left?
So one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Oh, wait, there's someone alone.
No, it's because the lobby, we're resetting.
We're waiting for the scores.
Yeah, we're waiting to know what group we're in.
Oh, we're fifth!
Yeah, we got fifth.
We got fifth, we're top five!
Let's go!
We won the tiebreaker?
We should have, we should have.
Yeah, we did!
We won with 11 kills.
Oh my god, we won the tiebreaker, that's crazy.
Whoa, insane!
Oh my god, we're top five.
Oh my god.
What does that mean?
So we're in the winner's bracket, so we gotta play six more games.
We won!
So we get to play!
No!
Yippee!
I don't hate this punishment.
Oh, it's even worse than I thought.
We're gonna be playing with these...
What do you mean?
These great people.
So basically, we play against the other top 10, group B's top 10.
Oh god, that's even worse.
And then, so they're the... yeah, so then the lobbies are a little harder now.
Just a little bit harder.
But you're learning more in each game.
You're improving more in each game, so it should be easier.
Do you think we can secure another dub though?
I don't know.
We have to ask Flame that.
Flame, do you think we can secure another dub?
Do you think you can secure us a dub?
Flame.
Uh, I mean, people win the lottery sometimes.
WHAT?
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT, YOU IDIOT?
YO!
At least it isn't zero!
Believe!
BELIEVE, FLAME!
The chances load a lot, man, you know.
It's not zero.
Gotta keep trying.
You're a real gambler like that.
I like that about you, man.
As long as it isn't zero, we're gonna keep going.
Is that true?
I mean, I don't have high hopes for us here.
It's gonna be so funny if we actually win this thing.
It would be pretty funny.
I had zero hopes for winning.
I'm not expecting us to win, but it would be really funny though.
It would be very, very funny.
Because all of us have, like, none of us are in Japan, so all of us have high ping in these lobbies, so it would be very funny.
The fact that we made it into the top 5 with our ping, like, I'm very, like...
Dude, a while ago at the first match, I was seeing you guys teleport.
I was like, oh my god, can I say this right now?
No, you should have not told me that, but that's okay.
That's okay.
Also, like, by the way, guys, there were scrims for this, but I figured, like, you know, I figured we were all busy for the scrim.
So, the fact that we got top 5 without, like, the scrims or anything, I'm really proud of us, honestly.
I'm really proud of us.
Yeah, I'm proud of whatever abomination we just did.
I can't believe we had scrims and you just decided, like, nah, I'm too good for this.
We didn't even have a third, Flame!
We didn't have a third!
I've been trying to find a third!
And you got me!
Yeah, we got Droid!
Would you really go to scrims when you had your own chat scrims to go to?
No.
Our teammate was going back from Thailand.
Oh, you don't have, so you can't do chat scrims?
You couldn't play.
Oh, so you would have used this as practice?
You could have said something!
Oh, you didn't even know, so...
Yes, that's the problem!
Nobody's informed me of this.
Nobody said, no, this scrim is good.
You didn't know, that's true.
I just made the executive decision for us that we didn't need it.
We were all too busy for scrims.
Unbelievable.
But we got top five!
Yeah, that's insane!
Without even informing anybody, we got top five.
Yeah, good job, everybody.
Good job.
Proud of us.
I haven't touched Apex in a while, and we still got top five.
How long is this?
Because I don't want to...
I want to piss.
No, you can literally go pee right now.
We haven't drafted the POIs yet.
Okay, all right, I'll be right back.
We have to draft POIs for the next one.
Be right back.
Go pee.
All right, Flame, are you...
I don't know how to say this, you know, in a way that's not so rude.
But I think you should let me draft the POI.
I didn't draft it!
It was a sign!
It was a sign?
No, yeah, but this time you can draft it.
I would have never picked Kosuke!
I know how dogshit Kosuke is!
I would have asked my friends to be like, which one are you?
I apologize, I was under the wrong impression.
I would be a little rude, but like, those jobs...
Wait, we still got top five with the dogshit drafts!
Just, I mean, come on!
Everything was against us, but we still did really well.
Imagine if we didn't have Kosuke, we would have come first, you know?
Yeah, but it wouldn't matter, because like, no, top ten, first in this part, it doesn't matter!
You don't get anything!
We get better drafts for winner's bracket, do we not?
Wait, do we?
I don't know.
I'm pretty sure that's how it works.
Oh, oh yeah, I mean, fifth place draft spot, that's...
Okay, wait, but then we have to...
Yeah, and then if we do better in winner's bracket, we get better drafts in finals.
That's true, that's true.
It's not like a massive advantage, but it is still a pretty good advantage.
Yay!
I'm so excited, I'm so excited.
He gave us coastal fragment, that is just like, not okay.
Yeah, to be fair.
I'm on, like, Cito, Cito landslide.
Like, that's literally my POI, man.
Well, you can try and get your POI, get your POI!
Yes, and then you can really...
Are they doing drafts now?
Because I have not been looking.
Oh, you can look at the, just ask in our channel.
To be like, how this draft works.
Because I don't know how they're...
Because I didn't think we'd make it this far, so I don't know how the drafting works.
Honestly.
I'm glad to know you had a lot of confidence.
You never had any hope for us actually winning.
I didn't, you know, I was so surprised.
Like, okay, you're right.
You be honest with me.
Do you really think we're going to get top 10 in the first?
No.
Exactly, exactly.
So I didn't...
I was going real hard.
Just maybe a little bit, but I didn't actually think it would manifest.
But we didn't go...
So what are the chances now?
Like, given our playthrough, do you think we can actually do this?
The chance is low, but not none.
Yeah, yeah.
As I've said, thank you for being consistent with me.
You had to think about it.
You thought about it for a while and be like, what do I say?
How do I break this unfortunate piece of news in a way where it's not...
Look, look, look, look.
You told me, you told me a while ago that we are not going to win.
Like, we would not do anything.
But look...
Wait, you said that to us?
We're top five.
I just realized I had no foogie on.
Realistically, and you said...
Oh, oh, you do.
You do have foogie.
No, I know.
I mean, I realized I didn't put it on my stream.
Oh, I'm sorry.
You must have been like, who the fuck is talking?
So that's what you meant.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay, all right.
All right, what are you going to say?
What are you going to say, Gerard?
What are you going to say, Gerard, before I interrupt you?
I forgot what I was going to say.
Oh, sorry.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
It's just my brain.
I know, I'm proud of us, though.
I'm so proud of us.
What number are we?
What team number are we?
I know, I know.
Uh, team eight.
Okay, team... where the fuck is team?
Oh, there it is.
All right.
We're team five, I think.
Oh, we're team five?
Yeah, we have to change discords, too.
You have to scroll down.
So in a giant map, like, oh, we're just going to be running...
finding these, um, like how many?
Yeah, yeah, okay, okay.
What is my teammate?
There's so many...
Wait, what do you mean teammates?
I'm like... I'm like looking through...
Oh my god, I'm looking through, like, the...
Discord overlay and streamer kit.
And if you look at that, there's so many teams.
There's, like, several teammates.
So I'm like, which one's my teammate?
Is it this one?
There's, like, a drop-down that says what it is.
Like, winners round, losers round, group B.
You see that?
Are we group stage?
Okay, teammate.
Oh, that's not it.
We're looking for team five for winners.
Okay.
No, we're team... we're on channel eight right now, so...
Yeah, but they moved us to five.
Oh, okay, they're moving us there.
Okay, I'm gonna look at all the teammates for now and I'll find five later.
I'm trying to find our icons in team eight.
Oh my god, why is there so many numbers?
I honestly don't know what you're looking at.
Like...
Oh, like, okay, so...
Is it in Discord?
No, I'm using the streamer kit, the stream kit Discord overlay.
And then, like, when you do the drop-down, it tells you, like, what the voice channels are.
But, like, there's so many hidden voice channels that we don't have access to, but it shows it to me on this.
It shows it to me.
So, basically...
Okay, I'm gonna post it in the Doki.
They're gonna... the staff is gonna be, like, what the...
Oh, wait.
Oh, they translated it for us.
We'll be holding after...
Oh, thank god.
1950.
Therefore, we're like, please decide.
Oh, okay, you got...
They told you how to do it.
Okay, so, uh...
You have to be at that channel.
My POI draft is supposed to happen right now.
Yeah, yeah, go to your... this channel.
Goodbye, Flame.
Which channel?
The... you click on it.
You just click on the thing.
Oh.
Oh, I need to write it.
Oh, representative.
Strafing Flame is representative for Doki Bird.
Oh, what's gonna happen?
Oh, shit, where'd it go?
They're getting the draft.
They're drafting it.
Oh, how does that work?
There is, like, two people in there.
There's, like, two people in there.
You're like, I don't want to be there by myself.
This is what it looks like.
So, I'm, like, trying to find it and I'm like, this is not my teammate.
Like, there's so many numbers in this area.
Which one's mine?
Oh, there is.
I found mine.
Yeah, it is.
I realized I never had a Fugi on here.
And I'm like, oops, sorry, guys.
I guess you're not gonna see anybody.
My bad.
Okay.
Okay, this should work now.
There we go.
You fucking icon, Gerard.
What's wrong with it?
It's so dumb.
It's cute.
And then Flame is just a dog.
I'm not judging anybody's fucking icon, bro.
Mine was made of love.
I made it.
Like, very first time in debut, I made it.
My own Fugi.
I appreciate myself, bro.
All right, I finally found it.
Okay, so you can check the status of each team's declaration in the dedicated spreadsheet.
Oh, there's a spreadsheet.
Yeah.
Okay, we are ninth pick.
That's not bad.
They first picked Klimatizer?
That's crazy.
Oh, is it bad?
Like, are the items usually that bad?
It's just not first pick POIs.
Yeah, it's not a first pick POI.
Oh, bro.
Go up to the, like, that's a crazy POI thing.
Damn.
I feel like if you're gonna go Klimatizer, you just go SkyWest.
It's just, like, so much better.
Let's see, when it comes to the order of nomination, we will move you to standby and then to the caster.
Please declare.
Oh, you're gonna be on the main stream.
You're gonna, you're gonna, like, you're just gonna be, like, this.
And then you're gonna be, like, there'll be, like, the one person speaking English after.
How does that work?
You just declare it.
I think, I think it's, like, direct trans.
Like, I mean, Klimatizer?
Yeah, all I have to say is, like, Cito Station.
Yeah.
I don't know, that kind of sounds like a racist.
There's, like, Japanese words that, like, are, like, phonetic to English words.
Checkpoint is one of them.
My experience at Doki Bird.
It's true!
I'm gonna see how he pronounces checkpoint.
It's so, it's, checkpoint is one of the Japanese words that sound like an English word.
Oh, you can't pull this on me.
You can't.
Uh-oh, looks like we're getting cancelled.
It's checkpointo!
It is!
Oh my gosh, it literally is!
It does!
And I'm gaslighting you.
You're the racist one!
Oh,
well.
I fucking knew it.
I was like, there's no way I'm wrong.
There's no way.
Is it, wait, is it in, like, um, English alphabet or what?
It's literally checkpointo.
And I was like, checkpoint, checkpointo.
And then I was like, I'm pretty sure it was actually how it's pronounced.
I mean, yeah, that's right.
That is what it is.
Yes, and then he called me racist.
I was literally reading it.
My God, my God.
We're already throwing fucking racist cards.
I can't believe it.
And I was like, no, this is not checkpointo.
I was like, did I just make that up?
I have no idea what you guys are looking at.
Where are you guys looking at that?
I'm looking at the spreadsheet.
Okay, here's, I'll link it to you.
It's in the, it's in the...
Is it in Japanese or is it...
No, it's in the, no, it's in the channel.
So we could see what they're picking.
It's in the, um, the top 20, like...
Holy shit, you guys are looking at these documents?
Yeah, we're looking at exclusive documents right now.
Oh, okay, okay.
So where the fuck did you read?
Uh, thermal station, uh...
No, I'm literally looking at checkpointo.
I'm literally looking at this.
It's the first one.
You're right.
No, yeah, you're right.
It is checkpointo.
Yes, but oh, I get called racist for reading the fucking characters.
I mean, uh...
Did you really say checkpointo?
I'm like, yes, because that's what it says.
I'm going to make the twit longer now, Gerard.
I'm going to make the twit longer.
No, don't cancel each other, no!
We just literally...
There's a little first calamity where someone's going to get cancelled already.
We're going to make sure we don't get top 10, so you got to cancel.
Yeah, come...
No, fuck's sake.
My God, I think this is going to take a little longer.
Is it going to take a little longer?
Well, this is going to be another, uh, two and a half hours.
Two and a half hours?
Oh, God.
Yeah, I mean...
That's what we get for winning, Gerard.
That's what we get.
Okay, now I kind of regret a little bit, but we might win, though.
You regret a little bit?
I thought this was the best day of your life.
I know, it is the best.
It is the best day.
It is the best day of my life.
What happened?
But, like, I didn't expect we'd be going for long, but it's okay.
I didn't either.
That's why I was like, don't worry, it's okay.
I didn't expect it either, because I didn't think we were going to get top 10.
But now we're here.
But it's...
It's fine.
Like, what's your longest stream, anyway?
My longest stream?
11... almost 12 hours.
Oh, wait, no, past 12 hours.
I think, like, 14 hours.
Holy crap.
Yeah, me too.
I've been going for fucking 11 hours.
I can take this thing on.
I can do this.
You can do it.
Each game you're getting better, remember.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I gotta remember it.
Like, are we still gonna go, by the way, with the regular setup?
With the regular setup?
With these people?
Well, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
I thought we were gonna...
Yeah.
Better not fucking...
I swear to god, I better not fuck this up.
I better not.
Like, I gotta show for something, at least.
Like, I'm getting better and better, gotta say.
Getting better and better.
You're getting better and better.
I gotta also be careful.
Because I don't wanna be the first down again, I swear.
Who else would be the first down?
I am the only bronze player out here.
I don't wanna be at lea...
Go, go, go, go.
Like, hey, hey, did you know, did you know, by the way, I killed, like, one...
I killed, like, two people.
Wait, that's, like, double what you wanted.
Yeah!
You were like, I hope I get, like, one kill.
But you already got two.
Yeah, correct me if I'm wrong.
I'm like, you know...
You got...
Oh, nice!
Cito Station!
Let's go.
Is that good?
Yes.
That's his...
That's literally his ALGS land spot.
So he knows exactly how to play.
Now we have to win.
Usually, like, the top three pick.
I don't know.
Oh, my God.
I don't know what's going on with this draft.
Well, to be fair, you're the only ALGS player in here.
What, am I?
You have to be.
You're the only...
Like, we were so lucky.
That's FD on Mainy.
Yeah, but...
Oh, wait, there's FD...
Oh, shit.
I mean, those...
But I was gonna say Group A.
Nah.
Not gonna jinx it or anything, but the moment when Doki just said that she was, like, very professional at, like, the world's edge.
And now you're very good at this map.
So I think we're gonna win again.
We're gonna win again.
Yeah, now that we have you on Stormpoint on Cetus Station, it'll be fun.
Yeah, we're gonna win.
This is it.
We're not gonna jinx it.
This is a declaration.
Oh, my God, Flame.
That means we placed higher than FD on.
We did?
Yeah, because they got 60 to pick.
Oh, yeah.
They got 60.
Oh, my God.
I'm so proud of us, guys.
I'm so proud.
Oh, my God.
Are they actually that correct?
They are.
And they're...
You're right.
The thing is, all these players, except for us...
And no, not all of them, because I don't think it's not.
Majority of these players are in Japan, playing in Japanese servers.
I get 100 ping, 120 ping.
Oh, my God.
Holy crap.
I can't believe we did it.
Holy shit.
And then none of us are in Japan, so we all have ping diff right now.
We have a ping disadvantage and we still managed to reach it this far.
Holy shit.
It's pretty good for us.
This is actually really good.
I'm fucking hyped.
I should be, like, fucking nervous right now, but I'm actually hyped.
I'm actually running through my adrenaline.
Like, this is a good thing.
We still have to wait for it.
We're still waiting for the draft fix.
It's fine.
Optimism.
I wonder how we're gonna do the Worlds...
Or is it going up?
Down?
Or, like, down-up?
Is that how the draft works?
For the other ones?
Okay.
Okay, so we don't get good picks for Worlds Edge.
Nah, we're at, like, 30th pick on Worlds Edge, but it should be okay.
Well, 30th pick isn't that bad.
So we should just not even be...
We should've just been, like, 8th place, just to have the middle.
Oh, should've been...
Wait, what?
8th place puts us at the 32nd...
Wait.
If we were in the middle, then we would have been, like...
We don't have to worry about the picks too much.
I mean, I guess we got Ceedo.
We get the idea of Ceedo Station.
I mean, what the fuck is Ceedo?
I mean, the higher up you go, the better.
Because it doesn't...
It doesn't go like that.
It's not draft.
It goes...
Um...
Like, the first person to pick is the 21st person to pick.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
So if we get, like, 5th place, we would be 25th pick.
If we were at 9th place, we would be 9th pick.
Oh, okay, so we still get good picks then.
Woo!
All right, guys.
More Apex.
Yeah, this is taking a while.
Sounds like you were held at gunpoint.
Let me put a Marvel Rivals on this.
Get the Marvel Rivals.
Let's go, let's go.
Crouching your forearm like a drug addict.
Yeah, I guess we'll play Marvel Rivals.
Yes, just a quick game.
We can play, like, while we're waiting.
Oh my god.
Oh, wait, we could do a pub.
Let's do a pub.
Yeah, just pubs.
Yeah, let's do a pub.
We might as well.
Okay, I don't have you guys.
Wait, let me give you my...
What's my...
I'm back in the lobby so we can send you a friend request.
Yeah, I'm gonna...
Wait, are you actually...
Yeah, let's do a pub.
No, George, we need a pub.
We're, like, worn down.
We don't start our matches until 25 minutes.
I think we can fit in a pub.
All right, I'll put in the DokiBit channel.
That's my Steam friend number.
All right, let's get a pub going in.
I'll put us on JP servers too.
All right, okay.
So, like, we get the...
Very nice.
We get the Tokyo experience.
JP pub servers are kind of brutal, I can't lie.
No, I think all pubs are pretty fucking brutal.
I'm pretty sure all pubs are, like...
People are saying that rank is more chill than pubs now.
Yeah, it probably is.
Because, like, everybody's just doing movement shit.
Where is...
Guys, where is the friend request, guys?
Oh, there...
Yeah, I'm trying to, uh...
Oh, you're doing...
Oh, you just invite me to the party.
Wait, no.
Yeah, I'm gonna invite...
No, I...
And then you leave.
Oh, wait, I lost you.
Okay.
Wait, oh, wait.
Blaine, did you...
Are you in Tokyo server?
No, no.
I was gonna send you a friend request.
Oh, you're gonna send me a...
Okay, that's smart.
Okay.
Yeah, I don't know how to...
Just...
Can I send you one?
No, I'll go to Tokyo.
Are you on Tokyo?
Oh, yeah, I'm on Tokyo right now.
Oh, shit.
So that's what you're trying to do, Gerard.
Whoops, sorry.
Yeah, I was trying to add you and then, uh...
And then...
I was like, what are you doing?
Okay, there we go.
Sent you.
Tokyo, very judgmental.
There you go.
There we go, there we go.
All right, nice.
We're all in here.
There we go, there we go.
Nice.
All right.
Oh, and the...
And pubs in Stormpoint.
Let's go.
Are we gonna get disqualified?
I swear to God.
We better not get disqualified.
We can leave a pub.
You're fine.
Okay, okay, okay.
We can leave a pub.
I'm afraid we might miss it.
Okay, great, great, great.
I'll be fine.
We can't, we just can't leave a drink.
Okay, fine, I can breathe here.
Thank God.
Yeah.
I can breathe.
I can just relax.
I can do whatever.
And this is good practice for me.
Great, great, great.
Exactly.
And you can, like, actually...
Shoot your gun without getting shot at by, like, a Pred player.
Yeah.
Like, you can actually shoot your gun and potentially survive.
Dude, uh...
One thing I hate about sometimes, like, um...
Playing Apex is, like, I get shot down immediately.
That kind of demotivates me, like, um...
Like, at the beginning, when I was starting out in Apex, like, God damn, these guys are fucking fast!
Like, they got guns and I'm just, like, dead already.
Dead on arrival.
I'm so sorry.
I'm not like all of you, okay?
I'm so sorry!
You can't empathize with me!
That's why SPMM was invented.
So now, not everyone else, like, now we suffer.
People like me, they suffer.
No, because...
Because the reason why you got those matches is because SPMM didn't exist.
So that's, like, stand...
What was it called?
What's the...
What's the definition for SPMM?
It's something something matchmaking.
And...
So, like...
Skill-based matchmaking.
Yeah, yeah.
I forgot the first two words.
Anyway, so basically, when you first started playing, they didn't have that.
So you're put in a queue with us.
Because we wanted to have fun.
But now, because you guys weren't having fun...
At least we get to have fun.
Yeah, at least we get to have fun.
But now, now we don't get to have fun.
And you guys get to have fun now.
Okay, I'm not...
You choose, you choose.
I'm not confident.
We can just...
Yeah, I think we just land where we're gonna land here.
Yeah, we're gonna land and then just, you know, practice looting.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, Gerard.
Well, what happened to rap part?
Oh, yeah.
What happened to rap?
I'm just trying to aim my shit.
I'm just trying to aim my shooting.
Whoa, whoa, yeah, but rap part's just great.
Dude, you're already...
Dude, dude, I need to practice my aiming.
Yeah, I think we're gonna have a meeting.
We might need a...
Yeah, we might be getting dropped.
Let's be real.
Dude, dude.
You might have to be an LFT soon.
I guess you're a black guy, where'd this fucker go?
Wish I ran.
Fun's not allowed, fun's not allowed.
We can win now, fun's not allowed.
Fun's not allowed, this is a fucking...
This is a practice pun.
No wonder, no wonder I dropped this game.
We're scrimming right now.
Yeah, we're scrimming.
Lock it in, buddy.
My god, okay.
We have like a few minutes anyway.
This is a problem with scrims these days.
The quality of scrims are dropping.
People don't take it seriously.
These lazy pro players.
Yeah, these lazy pro players who don't take it seriously.
Unbelievable.
They're just in this building.
Walking out, fun.
Oh, I'm heading over here.
I hit the catalyst 100 under me.
There's a guy under us, I'm gonna drop on him.
Do it!
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Where is he?
He's like in the secondary height, I think.
Okay.
Gibby almost cracked here in the bub.
I'm in the secondary height now.
I don't see him.
Gerard is pushing.
I'm with you, Gerard.
Oh, wait, wait!
Wow, look at him go!
What?
Oh, Gerard, you're cold!
Told you, told you.
He's in the crack!
He's here, we're all here to have fun!
Chill time, chill time.
He's him!
See, I am him!
I'm him!
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
Oh my god, I'm not him.
Oh, oh wow.
Whoa!
Time to save it, Doki.
What happened?
I'm just not him!
I'm not!
That's a full team.
Back up the Doki, back up the Doki.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That guy literally, like, fucking gunned me down.
I was confused.
Yeah, he's fine.
No way!
Nice.
Hey, I'm back.
What the fuck?
Am I just used as- Oh, oh!
Oh!
He's him!
I am him!
Told you!
Look at me!
Look at you!
We're gonna die if you do that.
Stop holding me down!
I was waiting for somebody to shoot us, not gonna lie.
Oh my god.
I completely forgot we were still in draft.
Oh, they just dragged me over to the draft.
I was- I was not ready.
I was not ready.
Did you grab us a spot?
Yeah, yeah, it was okay, it was okay.
You were just like- It was okay, I'm alright, I'm alright.
You were watching Jirard pop the fuck off and you were like, Whoa, whoa!
I was gonna say- Again, subversion of expectation.
Yeah, I was gonna say, why do you have zero reaction to Jirard popping the fuck off?
I was like, damn, tough love right there.
He was not impressed.
I gotta- I gotta say though, that actually helps.
Tough love gives me the reality check that I need.
I gotta improve even harder.
It's just like, for Flame, he's like, you should do better.
I'm the unimpressed tiger parent.
Yeah, yeah, you're just like, no response.
It's just not enough.
Not enough to do better.
But thank you though, thank you.
Feels bad, man.
What did you get us for the second?
I got Epicenter, Voltage.
That's nice.
All the- all the POIs on Voltage were like, kind of digging.
It was all like- Oh yeah, all the good ones.
Yeah, yeah.
Hey, at least it's not- it's not Ragnarik.
Yeah, I mean, it's- it's between- it's between uh, like, Geyser or Epicenter.
But I think Epicenter is better because we want to like, rotate.
Yeah, and they're like- Where are they fighting?
Oh, they're fighting over there.
Oh, I see it.
Oh my god.
What if we oop this team on the right and then just kill them?
Do it.
No balls.
Yeah, I'm right behind you.
Okay, we don't- I don't think we- no, we do- Yeah, I'm doing it.
You totally make it.
I'm doing it.
I don't think I can make it.
You're- you're a prof- oh, I make it.
I killed one.
I'm gonna die.
Nope.
Uh oh.
Oh, he's on the left.
It's all you.
It's fine.
Pushing on the right.
Horizon on you.
Oh, you win this.
I don't- Okay, Dorade, you have to run away, Dorade.
Run away, Dorade.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Wait, come- come up, Dorade.
No, no!
No, there's 19!
There's 19!
The other team!
No!
We got - we got thirded!
Yeah, that's- you see, we're practicing now to not get thirded.
Yeah, yeah.
Now, we won't get thirded now because we know- we- we know.
It's fine.
I'll be okay.
I like- oh, did they like- they automatically dragged you because you didn't show up!
Yes, I did.
They're just like this- this EN team.
They're just -
Okay, did you guys go back to the lobby?
I'm sorry, Dokkaebi.
We might be getting blacklisted from future performance.
What?
What happened?
And I'm dragging you all down with me.
Wait, where are you guys?
Did you guys like, uh- No, we're cute.
We're cute.
No, no, we- We're cute.
We're- we're all cute.
Oh my god, Dorade, get off that mistoki!
Oh my god!
Wait, what'd I say, what'd I say?
I got two kills, too!
Oh my god!
Oh yeah!
All right, all right.
But, Dorade, now do that on Rampart.
Okay, fine, fine.
I'm gonna- Now do that on Rampart, Dorade.
I have a fucking big-ass hitbox.
Okay, fine, okay.
I'm gonna queue this time for Rampart.
Okay, fine, fine, fine.
Have you guys watched season two of Arcane?
No.
Oh shit, yeah!
Dude!
Did you finish it?
Yeah.
Oh god.
Ah, dude, Toki hasn't watched it.
I don't want to spoil it.
No, you can spoil it.
No, no, no, no, spoil it because I might not- I might not watch Arcane.
I never even watched season one.
Really?
I don't- Dude, it's great!
No, because I don't want to play League.
I don't want to- No, you don't have to play League.
I don't want to play League.
Dude, there is no relation.
You don't get to learn about- No, I'm too scared.
Dude, I never play League.
I did play League.
I only played once.
That's what they all say for shows adapted from video games.
Because people are like, people started playing League because of Arcane, and I'm scared that's going to happen to me, and I don't want to play League.
I don't want to- You're afraid of what Marvel did to you?
Dude, it's okay.
I'm scared.
No, because it always happens.
The Fallout show came out.
I played Fallout.
Well, isn't that great?
No, it's not.
It's League.
Oh yeah, you're right, you're right, you're right.
You do lose a piece of yourself forever.
Oh shit, I forgot.
Oh god, Rampart.
Oh fuck.
All right.
Wow.
This kind of behavior will not be tolerated further.
Wait, can we- We can quit, right?
You have- No, no, I'm not quitting.
It's okay.
No, it's a fucking pub.
We're not quitting a pub.
So I can go with Rampart.
I forgot we were talking about goddamn Arcane.
I was like so out of it.
All right, spoil me about Arcane.
What do you want to say about Arcane?
The echo, like having to go back from the alternate reality, that breaks my heart, man.
Yeah.
Oh, that's probably the single worst moment in Arcane for me.
Dude, I've been seeing, like, theorizing- What, what?
When they cut to the scene where he, like, lights out the paper in the same spot where, like, Kim and Powderkiss and the other, like, alternate reality, that hit, bro.
Dude!
That hit hard, man.
Yeah, what could have been?
It's like an- Oh, no.
Dude, he had a crush on her this entire time.
Oh, it's so sad, man.
Yeah, now it kind of made me look back to, like, the first season while, um, while Echo was, like, choking out, like, Powder because, like, you know, they were fighting.
Like, dude, that must have been so painful just to see your crush, like, just, like, uh, get so demented and crazy, bro.
When he goes back, he has to literally stop her from offing herself, like, 15 times.
That's, like, insane.
What?!
Oh my- see, this is why- Yeah, because every opportunity that he gets to talk is just like, she pulls the fucking punch.
Yeah, it's just- Yeah, oh, okay.
Oh my god, that sounds crazy.
Yeah, god.
That sounds fucking crazy.
Anyway, are you two League players?
Do you guys play League?
Anyway, no, no.
Crazy, denied.
Are you a League player, Gerard?
No, no.
Okay, so they didn't get you.
I have been tempted to play League because of that.
See, you've been tempted.
Yeah, tempted, but I never gave in to my urges.
For now, for now.
Oh, for now.
You've never- I mean, if I had friends to play it, then yes, I would definitely.
Wait, does Armin stop- I played it once, just, like, the training, but that's it.
Does no one in Holostars EN play League?
I mean, they do, of course, it's just like- But they don't invite you?
I mean, they do, but I just didn't have the time for it.
Yeah, I don't know about time.
You just have the self-respect, you know?
Yeah, I think, I mean, I streamed it, and I invited some of them, and then, oh, shit, I don't want to play this thing anymore.
Like, it's only during, like, moments where, like, I don't want to feel like playing League today or something.
Stuff like that.
See, I'm scared of it hooking me.
But I am interested.
It's like- What?
I'm scared of League, like, unlocking something inside me.
I'm scared.
I have- I'm, like, very easily, like, influenced.
So, I'm worried.
You're a victim to capitalism.
Yeah, I'm a- No, it's like, the thing is, when I get addicted to something, it's really bad.
Like, when I got addicted to Marvel, right?
Okay, I still am.
I literally did nothing.
I got yelled at by my manager, because I- Who I paid for, by the way.
I paid this manager.
Because I literally did zero work for three days straight.
Because all I did was just play Marvel Rivals.
And then they're like, you need to do this.
And I'm like, okay.
And then I just put up Marvel Rivals.
Oh my god, gamers.
Yeah, like, I feel that.
I had a deadlock addiction for a little bit.
Deadlock, yo.
Deadlock's pretty fun.
You guys play Deadlock?
I play Deadlock, yeah, yeah.
But then Marvel Rivals came out, and then I stopped playing.
Same!
Honestly, same!
I stopped as soon as something funner, like, came out.
Whoa, fun?
More fun?
Whoa, to be fair, true, because Deadlock's a MOBA.
I just hate- I hate the MOBA part of the- Wait, who shot you?
Uh, in front of me, on the rock.
It's a full team.
What the fuck?
He sees me.
Holy shit.
We could teleport behind him.
He gets this peek?
I'm ulting Roran here.
Oh, I don't know about the peepee!
Oh my god, Jarod!
Jarod, what the fuck?
Octane's one, Octane's one on the rock.
I know, I know, I know.
Jarod, that was a crazy- I netted him Luckman.
I have to use my bubble.
That's a crazy thing you just did in front of me.
Oh, I might be getting pushed.
I can- I can walk back, I'll be fine.
I'm looking for you, I'm looking for you.
They're not pushing it?
Oh, shit.
I have to back out, I have to back out.
Oh, I killed him!
Oh, yo!
Nice headshot!
Holy fuck, that's insane.
I'm looking.
Bruh, bruh, bruh, bruh, bruh, bruh, bruh, bruh.
I have 56.
I don't have a scope for this triple take, so...
What?
There's a team right behind- Oh!
Is that- is that their third?
It's a different team, it's a different team, it's a different team, it's a different team, it's a different team.
Nice, nice, nice!
Oh, no, please die.
I usually remember when the wingman was so fucking OP.
Please one, no.
Oh, goodbye.
You're so fucking dead.
Yo, yo, yo- Oh, I have the last!
It's a team!
Oh my god, he's doing it again!
No!
My Nessie shot him for 24 damage, though, and did his job.
He did his job.
That's all that matters.
Oh, that rampart is crazy, man.
I didn't hear the footsteps, he just showed up.
Oh, man.
Oh, this is Care Pack L-Star, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah, they have the special thing.
All right, we get to have one more- I died so quickly.
Uh, we should move to the winner's bracket.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
Yeah, but no one else is there.
Wait, there's like 10 teams in there.
I think- oh, is there?
Oh, okay.
Are we with five, right?
We're team five, yeah.
All right.
Hello, I'm back.
I need to fix my wingman if we're team five.
Hello, hello.
I gotta- oh, I don't think he knows where it is.
I don't think- I'm sure I was trying to figure out where the fuck it is.
Oh, no, this is not a good sign.
We've been through this before.
He doesn't know where team five is.
Oh, no.
Jirai.
Jirai, just scroll down, Jirai.
You know what kicked me off my deadlock addiction?
What?
I was playing in a- an Aeternus ranked lobby.
And there's this, like, guy that I was queuing with.
A friend of a friend.
And I was playing so bad.
I think I went, like, zero on six, two games in a row.
And then it was over.
And then in the second game, he told me, like, he told me- This is- this guy's Chinese.
Please stop queue.
Like, like, please stop queue.
Bro.
Oh my god.
That just hurt you?
That hurt me in my soul.
If he told me to uninstall the game, I would have- I would have just laughed it off.
But he just told me, please stop queue.
I've never been insulted like that in my whole life before, man.
What happened?
I actually- I stopped playing the game after that.
Like, I straight up stopped.
I didn't come back from that.
Tea happened?
What the fuck happened?
What?
You'll never know, Jaron.
You gotta wait until the stream- You gotta wait until the stream's over.
I'm sorry, Jaron.
I'm not gonna repeat it.
We're right- we're here right now!
Say it to me!
I'm sorry, Jaron.
No, that's not- that's a story you can't repeat.
He was sharing his, like- He was sharing his deepest, darkest regret to me.
It just brings out too much painful memories to say it again, Jaron.
Yeah, wait until the stream's over.
As soon as I got here, like, I will never play Apex again.
Crazy to hear!
After we're inside the tournament, like, huh?
Did somebody fight in here?
Jaron, Jaron!
Pick, pick, pick!
Oh, yeah, yeah.
You're right, okay, there we go.
It wasn't Apex, it was Deadlock.
It was Deadlock.
Stop talking about fucking tea while I'm picking characters.
I can't focus.
I don't know if we can play this game.
Code is out.
I don't know, I wasn't listening.
Okay, where's the code?
It starts in five minutes.
Oh, it starts in five minutes?
Okay, five minutes?
Okay, we can leave then.
We kind of have to hot drop and then just- Yeah, we can just hot drop.
Hot drop and then die.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If we're late again, they might actually blacklist us.
Okay, so I'm dropping down, dropping down.
Drop down now.
That's right.
Oh, there's a lot of teams here.
Let's go.
I'm going bottom floor.
I'm going- Hey, there's another person with a Pred trail too.
Let's go.
Jarrad, you fight that guy.
I believe in you.
Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, okay.
Whoa, look at him go.
Okay, down.
Whoa, you meleeed somebody.
Oh my god.
I was doing a finisher!
Okay, that makes more sense.
Ow, ow, ow, they're shooting at me!
Oh, he's one, he's one, he's one.
Got you.
Okay, he was not one.
That was- No, okay, now the lifeline, the lifeline.
Oh, your lifeline, okay, I was gonna say.
The lifeline was not one.
Literally, you were like, he's one.
And I shot like a full HP guy.
I was like, okay.
No, just straight gaslighting.
Yeah.
Straight gaslighting.
All right, leave so we can join.
Oh, Jarrad, we did more damage than a pro player.
We should be proud of ourselves.
I gotta be proud.
Hey, I'm feeling pretty lucky today.
What the hell?
Hey, look, we're not.
We're not the last people in the lobby this time.
We're, we're getting better.
Let's go.
Unless, unless, Jarrad?
I'm joining, I'm joining, I'm joining.
Jarrad?
Jarrad, please?
I'm joining, wait, wait, wait.
Jarrad?
Wait, I can't go.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
People are coming in.
I'm like, where's the code?
I've been here before.
Where's the code, where's the code?
Oh, this is K-Jammu.
He doesn't know where the code is.
It's not like- K-Jammu.
Here you go, I gave you the code.
I gave you the code, Jarrad.
Okay, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
What the fuck?
It's not letting me in.
We were flaming out.
We were so happy.
We were like, oh my god, I couldn't make it.
And then we're like, wait, where's Jarrad?
Where did he go?
Oh, whoops.
It's okay, guys.
We're still not last.
It's fine.
All right, I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back, guys.
Yeah, all right.
All right, okay.
Here's another deep, dark secret to Jarrad while I'm gone.
So you can feel like he feels like he'll fit in.
Bro, you cannot just stop me playing.
You can tell him a different secret.
You tell him a different secret so he feels the experience.
Uh, I don't have any...
You know what, you tell me.
You tell me what happened, bro.
We can build from this.
We can have a great chemistry from this.
I think I feel like we're gonna connect some more.
If we share each other's deep, dark secrets.
What do you mean?
No!
There's another one.
Oh, there's another one?
Does Toki know about this?
No, no.
Okay, okay.
This happened like a few months ago.
I was at a mall, right?
I was driving.
I was trying to get out after I bought something.
And in Indonesia, you need these like flashcards.
They're essentially like kind of debit cards specifically for parking and like all that stuff.
And I didn't have like enough balance in mine.
Oh, you have to charge it, right?
Yeah, like I have to fill it.
And I don't usually drive.
So I don't know how to actually fill it.
Like I've never really like done it before.
So you were there alone?
No one to guide you?
Yeah, no, it was just me.
But I was trying to leave, right?
And then I tapped my card.
And it's out of balance.
Oh, no!
Whoa!
I don't know what it was, but whoa!
I was out of balance.
Were you arrested?
No, but I don't know how to fill it, right?
And so I had to press the help button.
And you would think the help button just kind of like alerts the workers that, you know, someone's stuck.
Because I'm like holding up the line here.
Like there's only one exit.
And if I'm there and I can't move, everyone behind me is like...
stuck.
They just stuck behind me.
Oh, God.
So imagine my social anxiety when the help button just blares a fucking tornado siren just really loud as I'm pressing it.
I'm pressed, dude!
How can you get out of that?
Look, and then I'm pressing it.
And I'm like, wow, this is fucking loud.
And then I stopped pressing it.
And the people behind me just start, like, they just start blaring their horns.
And then eventually the guy did come, like after like two minutes of just absolute hell.
And then I'm like, uh, hey, how do I, how do I fill this card?
And let me tell you what he looked at me.
I looked at him and I have never felt such fucking shame.
Like, he, I don't, he took his card and he just tapped it on the machine and said, just go.
Bro, I didn't know someone was capable of delivering such shame, man.
Like, I might have left that place without paying the fee, but I lost my dignity that day.
I lost my dignity.
It was, it was traumatizing.
Dude!
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I think I have a similar experience because when I was in Canada, like, um, in here in South Elysium, like, uh, we, we don't have cards.
We don't use like debit cards type of like charge for like a transportation.
Like, uh, I, I held up a similar thing as you, like, I held up a line to the bus.
Like, I was, I was like, um, going like, uh, inside and then you have to tap this, this thing so you can charge it.
And like, uh, you can, you can basically go now much like yours.
And then like, uh, my card wasn't being read.
Like, oh my God.
Oh my God.
And like, and like the conductor was like, dude, hurry it up.
And like, I'm like, I don't even know where I put my wallet.
Like, oh my God.
The debit works, right?
Yes.
And like the dudes at the back were like scratching their heads.
Like, no, no, I got this.
I got this.
You know what?
You just, just sit down.
Just sit down.
I got this.
I got this, don't worry about it.
I know.
Like, I'm so like, I'm so sorry.
I just looked out the window thinking like, uh, nothing, nothing bad happened to me.
Like, just let me off.
Let me off, man.
I don't want you to run.
You're just like, I'm just going to walk.
It's fine.
I'll just walk.
I'm just thinking about just making me cringe.
Oh my God, good timing.
Our match starts.
Oh, we're world's edge first this time.
Okay.
All right.
It was time to lock.
We shared our darkest secrets and trauma.
Now we're so locked in.
We bonded as a team.
Yeah.
We're so locked in now.
Trauma bonding is what you call it.
Yeah, trauma bonding.
Exactly.
We're one.
Look at my trauma.
We understand each other's feelings now.
I like how my trauma was just my addiction to like Marvel Rivals.
We started off with that.
It's a good thing.
At least you're enjoying yourself.
It's just my trauma.
Yours is like actual public humiliation.
Hey, don't shame us on that.
That was a very vulnerable moment for us.
We're trauma bonding.
Trauma bonding.
I'm going to loot the bridge here.
I'm going to call yours trauma bonding.
It is trauma bonding, my guy.
It's so traumatic.
Durai, why did you land with him?
You're not supposed to be here.
Just loot into Eppy.
You can get the bottom of Eppy.
I'll go get the top.
Sorry, I forgot we were not playing in public.
I was like, what are you doing over there, Durai?
I don't know, man.
Suddenly the tournament feels so crazy and silly.
This is the part where it shouldn't feel that silly.
Yeah, I know, I know, I know.
Okay, this time, this time.
Lock in, lock in, lock in, lock in.
This is a high-tier lobby now.
Stop dead, baby.
Maybe trauma bonding was a bad idea.
We became too silly.
Do you need a triple take?
I found a triple take for you.
Uh, I will take that.
All right.
Nice, all right.
I got energy ammo, if you guys want it.
Uh, yeah, I'll probably take all of that.
Oh, wait, no, no, that was a mistake.
I don't need too much.
Uh, any caches?
Okay, we're...
Closest this way, right?
Uh, we're gonna hit this cache here and then go into Monument.
All right.
Oh, there's a PK here.
We can start going now.
I'll take the PK, actually.
I'm gonna get, uh...
Hey, I got G7 Scout.
You guys want it?
No, I'm chilling.
No, I'm good.
I have, uh, 30-30 and PK.
Okay.
So, we better get a place where I can poke because I don't know what the fuck else to do.
All right, let's go.
Let's go up here.
Yeah, I'm going up.
We'll start leaving.
Come up, Druid.
We hit this cache and go into Monument.
I'm gonna... I'm looting these bins right now.
If you find any attachments for a...
If there's stuff here for a 30-30, let me know.
Yeah, I need a scope for my triple take as well.
I have a 1x.
I don't have any scope.
We can hit this zipline down here.
Just go straight into Monument.
All right.
I'm here.
Let's go.
I have to be a little bit careful in case Monument is still here, but it should be okay.
Just run left with me.
Yeah, I'm here with you.
They didn't loot this yet.
Yeah, I think they might have just already looted it then.
You guys go ahead and scan here.
Yeah, I mean this is top 10, so I won't be surprised.
Yeah, I saw people like over here.
There's a scope here, but not for us.
Okay.
Yeah, they're rotating to a sand site.
Just hit this console and we might go up this way.
I have a scope for you.
I found a 3x.
Oh, perfect.
You can just drop it wherever.
Yeah, I'll drop it here.
I'm waiting for Jared.
Yep, yep, yep.
Okay.
What?
I see you.
It won't let me.
The ping!
Oh my god!
Ping!
Oldie.
I'm holding it!
The ping isn't working!
The ping is going...
Oh, Jesus Christ.
There we go.
Oh my god, ping!
Guys, we got top five.
Remember that.
Listen, we're gonna hit this skip back and then we're rotating right here.
Remember we got top five.
Oh my god, it's literally failing me right now.
We want to be underneath this, like somewhere in countdown here.
Yeah, we just want to be like there, I think.
All right.
Okay, okay, okay.
All right, all right, all right.
Grab this cache.
Okay, I'll grab it.
Okay, it's you.
That's a gold Elstar.
An Elstar, yeah.
I'll take the Elstar.
You're not... I'll take it in.
I need to go up and grab this cache here and then we'll evac.
All right, I'm good.
There's someone scanning over at the hill house there.
All right.
Just climb up to me.
Oh, I'm heading over.
Not last!
Yeah, you're great, great, great!
They scanned over at Fragus wall.
Okay, I'm right behind you.
That cache is...
You guys can just...
We want to go to the pink?
Wait a little bit.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Jump up, jump up, jump up!
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna, I'm gonna.
No, it's taken...
Is above them free?
Can we line up here and just bubble?
Okay, I don't know if Gerard can, but I can.
So...
Okay, wait.
Oh, shut the fuck up!
I can!
Okay, I made it, made it, made it.
Oh shit, they're shooting at me!
Yeah, bubble, bubble, bubble.
We have to drop down.
No, no, no.
Gibby, Gibby, Gibby!
Kill this!
He died, he died!
Chill, chill, chill, chill, chill.
Wait, wait!
Chill, chill, chill.
Two seconds, outside.
Okay.
That's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
Oh, fuck me.
I might be dead.
I might be dead here.
Yeah.
Oh my...
There's people downstairs.
Just don't jump down, don't jump down, don't jump down, don't jump down, don't jump down.
There's people, there's a full...
Oh, what?
What?
What happened?
It was the last.
And again, zero deaths.
Oh my god!
What?
Everybody was here!
Goddamn, again.
Why did they push?
Nah, nah, that's on me there.
We definitely shouldn't have done that.
I wanted to stabilize up top for two seconds, check if that spot was free, and if it wasn't, we just dropped down.
But then the Gibby...
I kidnapped the Gibby.
He walked out the door and I closed it behind him.
So we got the kill, and I was like, I think we can fight this.
Oh man.
Yeah, no, that team, that team died.
Dude, three teams died in that fight.
That one fight, we started three teams.
Really?
God, oh my god, they're so aggressive.
We literally started something.
If we go down, we're gonna take a few with us, you know?
We literally started something there.
Holy shit.
No, I was so surprised they still pushed in the end, the two solos.
Because they could have just...
What is going on with that team up there?
Oh man, I had such a good...
Oh man, I almost downed the two of them there, but they like closed the door back and had no nades.
Because I did like...
Yeah, they were like flesh, but then they closed the door.
Yeah, the Ashe was so low.
Yeah, I did...
Yeah, I did the hundred and...
I did 112 on the Ashe.
Good job, good job, good job.
You know what?
Oh, I did more than flame.
Let's go.
That 37 damage more, I'm proud of that.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
It's not 37.
Proud of you, proud of you.
28.
28 more damage.
The 28 damage.
28 to 28.
I'll be right back.
Give me one second.
All right, all right, no problem.
All right.
You know what, Jarod?
That's fine.
It's just...
Remember, that's...
It's just game one.
Yeah, yeah, I think...
I think it threw me off when we actually went to the pubs.
Like, suddenly the focus just went out the window.
Yeah, I suddenly...
Okay, okay, I gotta be careful.
All right, now after...
That's like a wake-up call.
Game one is like a wake-up call.
Do we still have a chance though?
Yeah, yeah.
Of course.
Yeah, of course.
I mean, we literally did well.
I thought we were gonna get kicked out after that horrible performance.
We only did well in three games out of the six.
So like, it should be...
And we got top five from that.
So it should be fine.
Jesus Christ, the way they shoot.
It's so insane.
They can just...
Oh, man.
They're shooting from far away.
That's nice.
And they're hitting their...
I can never...
I can never do that.
That's nice.
How do you even train your aim?
Like, do you just keep playing?
You just play...
Well, some people do aim trainer.
I just play the game.
I know I should do aim trainer to warm up.
Or like...
What's that...
What's that 1v1 R something?
Yeah.
Yeah, that program.
There's like 1v1 training.
Is it like free on Steam?
Because I remember like...
No, you have to download like the client.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Okay, so there's like Apex 1v1s.
But that one you had to download.
That's not a Steam thing.
But there's Kovacs and aim trainer.
And I think one of them is free, right?
Aim labs too.
Yeah, aim labs.
Aim labs is free.
If you want to...
That's like...
Oh, yeah, yeah.
That one.
I've been using aim labs like before.
Yeah, yeah.
But now I just don't.
Okay, all right.
But it is so good to use, right?
Yeah, I mean, I don't.
But like others do.
I just like...
Okay, all right.
At least it gives me a...
Okay.
I just pure grind the game until I get better aim.
Oh, shut the fuck up.
But like...
No, I mean, no.
It's a viable thing.
I don't.
I'm built different.
I'm just a goalkeeper.
Until your aim adjusts to it.
But like other people...
If you want to be a consistent aimer, you just do aim labs or Kovacs.
Because like it helps you consistently.
Because like when I grind out a game, my aim only matches the game.
So like...
You're right.
Okay.
But then like...
But then like obviously it does translate well to other games, but not as good as it should.
Because I'm...
Mostly I'm...
I focus on tracking.
So when I do like project...
I can't do projectiles.
Because I'm...
I don't know the projectile speed and stuff.
Hearing this is like mind-boggling for me.
For a guy who never plays FPS as much.
Like a...
Whoa, you got to think that hard?
Yeah.
What the hell?
So like, you know, like sniper is projectile.
So you gotta know like the drop-off, the speed of your bullet and everything.
And you gotta like...
Like and then...
And then you have high ping.
You have to do lead...
Leading.
So you have to lead your shot.
What the fuck is leading?
So basically it's like you...
If you know you have high ping, you have to aim like little to like...
You have to aim further to where the target would go.
You shouldn't have to do...
Ping shouldn't really affect that.
It would if you have really high ping though.
It should, wouldn't it?
Because like I do that for...
Does it affect Apex?
I play sometimes...
Because I sometimes play in EU servers.
So I have to like compensate my aim for EU servers.
Oh goddamn.
Because like when I swap servers to EU, I have to lead...
Do leading.
Because I get like 250 ping for it.
Jesus.
Yeah, but like I'm used to playing various servers because in Overwatch I had to swap servers a lot just to...
Do VPNs like actually help at all?
Yeah, they do.
They can, yeah.
So if you use like a gaming VPN, it'll I guess like optimize your routing.
Oh.
Yeah.
I thought like gaming VPNs like barely work at all.
Like it'll make your game lagging.
You might be using a free one.
Oh, so that's why.
I never used like a VPN before.
You have to use like a paid gaming VPN.
Or I mean you can get like a trial for it.
I don't remember...
I remember there's one that everybody uses for Apex, but I don't remember the name for it.
It's uh...
Exitlag.
Yeah, Exitlag.
Oh yeah, Exitlag.
I've been seeing so many people like um...
promoting that shit on YouTube content, whatever.
There's another one too.
There's another one that's like uh...
I know there's one where like people say they use Exitlag, but they don't actually.
There's like...
There's like another one where like people are...
Registry of Lie?
Yeah.
Oh, I use all their money.
But I don't remember what it was.
Because like I tried it too.
Because I had to try...
Because I wanted to play on a specific Overwatch server, so I had to use the VPN.
Yeah, because there's like some games where you can't choose your server.
You have to like...
But like I mean...
I mean now it's just Overwatch that you have to do that.
Every other game you can choose your own server.
You still play Overwatch?
What's your peak on Overwatch?
Uh... 4600.
Oh...
In like...
4600 what?
Ping?
4600.
4600 is top 500, no?
Yeah, it is.
Yeah.
It was early season, so...
Yo, I'm just looking at this Bangalore shoot their shots.
They're like shooting like below and they're hitting.
Yeah.
But like it was when like everybody used to grind Overwatch.
So like top 500 was literally like 5,000.
Like rank one was like 5,000 or some shit.
Which is like the limit.
Like are you an OG Overwatch player?
Like the one before two or...
Yeah.
I've been playing Overwatch since season...
Oh, okay.
All right.
Since season two.
Well, I play...
I like I try to play Overwatch when season one, but I had not...
I didn't have a gaming PC back then.
So I was literally playing Lucio at 30 frames.
And then...
And then I got a gaming laptop.
Yeah, and then I get...
I got a gaming laptop for season two.
And then so I got...
And then I got...
I was playing Lucio at 60 frames.
Oh my God.
It was crazy.
60 frames from 30.
Oh my God.
That was fucking wild.
The gaming laptop is crazy.
Yeah, I fell into the rabbit hole as well.
Like just gaming laptop.
My God, that was the worst investment of my life.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, so yeah.
And then after that, I got super addicted.
And then I got a real gaming PC after that.
Because I was just hard grinding Overwatch.
And now my addiction...
Like my addiction to Overwatch was so bad that like...
I was not doing stuff for sure.
Like I was not doing...
Like just like doing things I shouldn't be doing.
I mean, even right now.
I think it's safe to say you're a degenerate at heart.
Oh, yeah.
And yeah, I'm a rank degenerate.
Yeah, it takes one to notice one.
At the peak of my deadlock degeneracy, I straight up chose to sleep four hours a day.
Actually, actually like 17 hours of deadlock.
These motherfuckers.
When I have scrims as well.
Oh, yeah.
I literally...
Like when I got GM yesterday, I literally just played...
I played Marvel Rivals for like 10 plus hours straight.
And then like it was...
Yeah, and then it was like 8 a.m.
And I was like...
Because I was like, I'm not ending until I...
No, it was more than 10.
It was 15 hours.
I was like, I'm not stopping until I fucking get GM.
And then I got to like...
Because I started...
The thing is, I started at 2 p.m.
And then I ended at 8 a.m.
What's wrong with you?
What the hell?
Because I was solo queuing.
I was solo queuing.
So I was like, I'm not stopping until I get GM.
And then the thing is...
That's some gold numbers, I can't lie.
And then the thing was, is that I had to go to the passport office right now.
Oh, yeah, that thing.
Did you just look dead?
I was like, no, I took my...
Bangs under your eyes like, what?
Okay, by the way, I didn't take a photo yet too.
So then I went to the passport office.
They had like a passport photo place.
And I just like, fuck it, let's take this photo.
And then there's an option to choose five.
And I was like, is this a photo I want for 10 years of my life?
I was like, fuck it.
It was like, post Marvel arrivals photo for the next 10 years.
Where's my fucking passport?
No, is that an 18 hour session?
I think it might have been an 18 hour session.
I think that's an 18 hour session.
I know, there was no way.
It was too...
Oh, it could be.
It was too fucking 8am.
Did you even sleep?
When was the last time you played Marvel?
I came back after...
Wait, it was literally today.
This happened all the time.
Wait, what?
Have you slept yet?
It happened today.
Wait, you haven't slept yet?
You're still...
No, I did sleep.
No, after I came back, I forgot much.
I fucking...
I'm concerned about this.
I went to bed and then I woke up.
I made my waiting room.
And then I queued up.
That was bad.
That is raw.
And I made my waiting room.
And then I was like...
And then I DMed Surefour if he wanted to play Marvel Rivals.
He was like, today I'm solo queuing.
And I was like, alright.
And then I watched his stream.
I was watching his stream playing Marvel Rivals.
While I was heading to bed.
Bro.
No way.
I literally...
I'd like to question your dreams.
I literally slept to Marvel Rivals.
Bro.
No, I used to do that for Apex.
I would...
When I was super addicted to Apex.
I would put up Apex streams to sleep to.
That's what...
Oh my god.
If I had your dedication, I'd have won five LANs by now.
I'm genuinely impressed and scared of what you're doing with your life.
No, I have a problem.
Did you sleep to Apex Legends streams?
No, when I get addicted to a game.
That's all I do.
I have a fucking problem.
Yes, you do.
I thought it's just like...
Longer gaming hours.
But even after gaming, you're still watching it?
Yeah.
Do you not get tired at all?
No.
I love it so much.
I just...
It's so, so genuine.
I love it so much.
I cannot put this thing down.
I'm in a really abusive relationship with video games.
I'm in a really fucked up relationship with video games.
I can never understand that.
Oh my god.
If I'm tired, I just put it down.
I do not think about anything else.
Insane, crazy.
I don't understand it.
The amount of dopamine you get when you're doing good in a game like that is just ridiculous.
Yeah, you just can't stop.
You actually forget to do anything else.
You forget to eat, you forget to...
Yeah, I know.
And then for me, you really want to attain that goal.
So you just don't do anything else but that.
Non-stop.
That's me.
I literally couldn't work because all in my head was like, I need GM.
I was like, I have to get GM before I do anything.
That's inspiring as fuck.
That's motivational as shit.
Yeah, but I wasn't doing anything else.
I don't know if that's motivational or inspiring.
I have other obligations.
That is an addiction and a problem, okay?
Addiction and a problem is a problem when you don't get anything out of it.
You're winning because of that.
That is nothing, man.
What does that even mean?
You're making history.
Come on, you're making history.
Listen, listen.
It takes one to know one.
I know addiction when I see it, okay?
But you still keep doing it because you know, it gives you the good shit.
The good feeling.
That is peak life right there, okay?
You don't understand.
There is nothing that will bring you greater joy.
It's true.
There's nothing else.
I could marry and have kids and I could stare my newborn son in the eyes.
But it's not the same as when you're alive.
And I still wouldn't have as much fun as gaming for 18 hours straight.
You don't get it, okay?
You don't have this addiction.
Yeah, but it's fascinating to listen to.
Oh, whoa, it's over.
It's over.
It was very interesting listening to that.
You don't want to go into the hell hole that we're stuck in.
It's not a fun one.
Hearing it actually makes it look fun.
Because you guys are just genuinely enjoying it.
I literally played ranked for 15 hours.
No, 18 hours.
It's nuts.
But I kind of sort of get it.
You know the dopamine you get from that.
I want to have that feeling too.
No, no, listen.
You don't want this, man.
You don't want this, bro.
You see it.
You see, when we talk about the dopamine, that's like 10% of that.
90% is pure hate and frustration.
It's fine.
It's what makes the dopamine better.
Yeah, exactly.
You gotta get through the fucking pain to get that high.
That one hit of high right there.
It makes everything okay.
I guess it's worth it because once you get to that point, I feel like I won't stop either.
Just that taste of victory makes me want to keep going.
I get it.
That one victory we had there.
I don't want my addiction to be on Apex.
On something other than Apex.
Maybe something else but not this.
As long as it's not League.
Dude, okay, actually having the taste of victory literally a while ago, I know it's been long ago but I still feel it right now.
I kind of want to play some more.
Literally after the stream, I think I might play again.
It activated something.
But I'm not in a level of an addiction way towards yours but I genuinely want to keep improving because just seeing people just shoot the shit and win, I want that achievement in life.
I want that.
It actually genuinely looks pretty fun.
He has the passion.
Yeah, yeah.
We ended up doing the opposite of what we were trying to do.
I stream 11 hours every single time.
If you go to my channel, it's like fucking 11 hour streams.
It's like my third 11 hour stream.
When I got here, I was barely running.
It's today.
I thought it's literally Saturday JST.
I mean, it is also Saturday JST.
It's also Saturday JST.
If we don't get top 10, it's also Saturday JST.
No, no, we gotta win.
Okay, locking in.
I gotta lock in right now.
Oh my god, you're right.
I literally have something very important tomorrow.
And if we don't win, holy crap.
Flame, you heard him.
I'm gonna throw every game.
I think we should just start sprinting at Klamathizer without guns.
Flame had so much fun, he wants to do it all over again tomorrow.
He wants to do it all over again.
No!
Please, okay, okay.
I'm gonna focus right now.
Focus, focus, focus.
Like, I don't give a shit.
I'm gonna focus.
I'm gonna follow everything down to the fucking T.
That's what I'm gonna do today.
Focus, focus.
Alright, we believe in you.
Alright, I'm locked in.
We're sprinting at Klamathizer and giving them free kill points.
You said you were gonna listen, right?
You're really not gonna listen to your IGL?
You're not gonna listen to your IGL, man?
Okay, fine.
If it's for the sake of the team, I have to.
You gotta focus up.
You gotta listen.
When we say Rez, you gotta Rez.
Yes, Rez, Rez!
Alright, don't land next to...
Don't land next to the flame.
You have to land like here, I think.
You start at my yellow ping, like on the...
It's like underneath the construction building thing.
And then you just loot around the bottom and then hit console.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, I have 300 ping this game.
That's not good.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh, that is very bad.
I think I just have really bad routing.
Oh, no.
Maybe people will die and then things will be okay.
I don't know.
I know that's not how routing works, but like maybe maybe they'll just fix it so when more people are dead...
I got an R301.
Who needs it?
I got a Nemesis.
We're fine.
I have a purple bolt.
Yeah, I'm gonna need that.
Let's see.
Yeah.
This is gonna be a tough game.
Can I scan it?
Yeah, just scan it as soon as you can.
You got this, I believe.
There's a triple take here, too.
Oh, zone's on top of us.
Oh, we got hurt.
Yeah, I'm gonna craft and then hold.
We wanna go up, right?
Alright, I'm going up now.
Where do you wanna hold?
Right here?
No, no, no.
On the yellow.
Okay.
I'll head over then.
Jordan, you need to come with me so you can do walls and stuff.
Before the other team shows up.
Alright, alright.
I'm gonna loot those bins and then I hope everything will be fine because people rotate so fast.
Yeah.
There's a mastiff here.
I'm gonna keep a card just in case.
Actually...
I need a scope, I have no scope.
I have 3x, I can give you 3x.
I'm gonna get the mastiff just because I'm Gibby.
Here, I'll drop a 3x.
We need to stay on the height, guys.
Okay, thank you.
I took the 3x.
Just give me any sight.
I only have 36 energy.
I never got a chance to loot more energy.
I'm giving you 40 here.
Just start setting up rampart covers.
There's a redeploy but I don't know where they ran to.
Tell them where to set up the walls.
Just put them on the periphery for presence for now.
You guys have to make sure you hold this northwest side.
I'm holding east and south.
Just get walls down on the northwest first.
Make sure no one can push us and then you can start putting walls down on me.
I don't know if that's a good wall but okay.
Make it so that people from this house can see it.
Scanning, scanning, scanning.
Aw, he bubbed.
Give me a shot at.
I'm kinda far.
This one.
That should be fine.
There's people underneath house here.
Shooting, trying to shoot me.
Yep.
They're in this house.
Okay, should I go to you?
Uh, yeah.
You can start putting some covers down on me.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm in white armor so this is a bit bad.
Yeah.
Very risky setting up there, Doki.
Yeah, I know.
But I can't see properly on the other side so I feel like I'm worried that...
Oh, people behind us!
Yeah, yeah, you have to give Doki a rampart cover.
Okay.
Just sit out there.
I need a cover right here.
There's people right here crafting.
I don't know if I can cover the left side though.
I'm worried about that.
I'm worried I might get walked up on on the left.
Yeah.
You guys just double stay there and keep looking.
Careful, you're in the open, Jared, so you have to be careful.
Put a wall right here.
Yeah, put a wall next to you so you can sit up top.
I'll look to the right.
I'll look down here, you look to the left, Jared, and you look to the left.
So move your cover so that you're okay on your right side as well as your left.
So I'm on Sheila.
I'm using Sheila over on my red ping.
There's people on the high ground on Cito.
Yep.
I have like 60 energy so I'm not going to poke much.
What gun do you have?
A Nemesis, that's why.
Yeah, I thought I was going to find more energy but I didn't.
It's fine, it's fine.
Epicenter has really bad loot.
Yeah, I didn't realize how bad it was because I had a carbine on me, but I was like I can do a Nemesis.
Okay, I see someone running over there.
Shoot them so they won't come to us.
Yeah, just shoot them, show presence.
We have a really good spawn here.
All we have to do is just not get walked up on and die like in that Stormpoint game.
Yeah, so we gotta make sure I'm just looking down here and you just keep looking at where you're looking, Jerry.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Does showing presence actually bait them?
No, it stops them from coming to us because all we want to do right now is just defend our position.
It makes them scared to run into us.
That's basically it.
So it's just a waiting game now.
You just gotta... if you see somebody just shoot them and let us know.
Yeah, keep an eye on your ammo though.
You don't wanna lose everything.
Just poke.
Do you know where your R301 is?
No, I don't.
It's all the way down here, but there's a team right here.
I have an R301 if you want.
No, that's fine.
Just keep yours.
Because I don't have much ammo for my energy gun.
Actually, it might be worth just making a swap.
I'm gonna swap my gun with you and you just pick it up.
Here, pick up the gun.
Okay, here.
Just drop it, yeah?
Take it here.
Ammo.
Okay.
Okay, here.
I dropped all of it.
Thank you.
Holy shit, you have 403?
He like ran this way.
Okay.
Trying to see where they're going.
There's a team right here.
I'm gonna...
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
I actually punched it.
They're fighting down here.
Hope it doesn't break.
It's fine.
I actually punched it because I was trying to swap my gun.
Uh, can you come over here for a few seconds?
Okay, do I?
Yeah, okay.
Oh, I'll stay, I'll stay, I'll stay.
Press X on this and then place another one in the same spot.
You have to take over Gerard's angle for a little bit.
Yeah, I'm taking it over now.
Getting shot from the bridge.
You can take these two out and then just replace them in the same spot.
Just press X on them.
Take this one on the left as well.
It got shot at.
Nice, thank you.
Perfect.
What the?
Oh my
god, stop.
Don't be like, don't be him.
You're not him.
You're missing.
Oh, he- Okay, he hit a headshot.
Alright, you go back to the angle.
You're not him!
You're missing!
He didn't even get a headshot!
You're fighting a pro player there, my goodness.
The moment I said that, he knows I have white armor.
Go back, go back to- Go back over there, Gerard.
No, no, Gerard!
Look at this angle.
Okay, okay, okay.
Shoot the top.
Shoot those.
Not shoot them, but show presence so they don't fly to us.
Zone might be going towards them.
I think so.
Maybe they're flying there too.
Yeah, I mean, no matter what, we're still in a really good spot.
We're just walking in our- Yeah.
I'm getting drilled.
Oh, bins reset.
Oh, wait, but...
So, we might be able to grab some bins later.
Are you okay?
I'm okay.
Are you still with 300 ping?
Yes.
Okay, I see someone here.
They're running.
Yeah, I'm coming over to help you.
Okay, they went behind the snow.
I can't see them anymore.
Okay.
I don't have a scope.
That's fine.
Let's just poke them so that they won't push us.
They have red armor.
Oh my god, they have red.
They have red.
If they see us with white, then we're a little fucked.
Oh, yeah, they're getting shot.
There is a...
The team in Epi?
No, the bins are reset.
Okay.
There's loot below us too.
We have a crafting too.
Which team has red armor?
The team to our left right here.
Over there.
In Epi?
There's no...
Actually...
There's no team on us here.
I think there's a team.
Team on the bins moving.
They're moving left.
On your side.
They're setting up in there.
Okay.
I can't do anything about it though.
They have to move to your side soon.
We can't overfocus them though.
Wait, does he have enough walls?
I don't think he does.
He's getting shot.
Wait, you have to look there though.
Oh, shit.
You come here, I'll look over there.
If you can reset that wall, then it'll be fine.
Just reset that wall.
And then we can swap position if we need to.
There.
Swapped it.
You guys need to try and get below.
I know.
I can't.
There might be purple armor for these guys.
I'm 217.
But no one's letting me poke them.
And I have no scope.
God.
Oh, they got me.
Oh shit, they know that I'm left.
We have a crafter by the way.
Yeah.
I'm crafting ammo.
Okay.
I think they're gonna charge here because they got me.
They threw in like a star or something.
Can I look for you?
Yeah.
I'm looking.
Okay.
I'm going back.
That's fine.
There's people fighting.
I'm 20.
Bad for me.
People fighting in FB.
You can start.
You can use all of your rampart covers on that direction now.
Okay, that's...
I don't have my rampart wall now.
Okay, here.
Oh, that's terrible.
That is horrible.
What is happening?
Oh, man.
Gotta figure out how to get over the other side.
Yeah, we're fucked.
No, we're not.
They're climbing on us.
Octane, Octane.
I couldn't.
Oh, they're purple.
I'm ulting this.
They're bubbling up on us.
We just have to fight this.
Get rampart covers down.
Pushing, pushing, pushing.
I got one.
Oh, they're so low.
One down, one down.
Nice, last guy.
No, I was so close.
I think if we didn't have white, Oh, they died.
I knocked down two only.
Oh my god, Jeraud.
Look, you got 338.
Let's go.
No kills, but that's alright.
We got the map.
Oh my god.
The fact that we had white armor.
Yeah, we only had white armor.
Yeah, that's so unlucky that we had zone on us.
Yeah, oh man.
Oh man, I think that is it.
I think we're going to be playing tomorrow.
No, no, no, that's just game two.
Oh yeah, you're right, you're right.
We have four more games.
We just got very unlucky with the fucking map.
RNG, RNG.
I had no scope and white armor so we couldn't do anything with it.
It's fine, it's fine.
We can get them next time.
We were just really unlucky, right?
We had really bad RNG on that game.
Yeah, it's like throughout the round we were just whites and blues.
Every team that pushed just died so that's fine.
Oh my god, they got an R9?
Somebody has an R9?
The fuck is wrong with them?
It's not fair.
Where's my R9?
Is it like the meta?
The gun?
No, R9 is my best gun.
Oh, care package gun.
Yeah, it's my favorite tracking gun.
I fucking love the R9, man.
I wish that R9 was just as strong as it always was.
If only.
It is like the controller gun but at the same time it's just so satisfying.
Peak apex.
It's just very satisfying to kill people with an R9.
It feels so good.
Oh my god, this guy has all the care packages.
I wonder what it's like to have red armor.
Damn.
I wonder what that's like.
Sounds so nice right now.
Dude, they're all red.
We're so broke.
We were so broke.
Literally, we couldn't do anything.
Man, I wish we could just craft armor back again.
Oh yeah, true.
Yeah, we had that beacon to craft the armor.
I don't know if I had a scope I could have farmed for my blue.
I literally was just single tap carbine.
I was like 175 from blue.
I definitely should have given you my triple take as soon as I got blue.
Oh, that's true.
I think I could have farmed...
Oh my god!
Are you watching the pathfinder?
Oh my god, someone behind!
Oh no, is this it?
Is this it?
Is this over?
They had a catalyst.
Oh!
Oh, they got the shield regen.
Yeah, they did shield regen.
Oh, that's so good.
Nevermind.
Bro, this is hell.
Wait, this is a terrible zone, actually.
They played on the other side of this wall?
Yo, yo, yo!
They have a terrible zone.
Oh my god.
Who the fuck is playing Ashe?
Oh, fuck me.
Ashe, what the fuck?
Bro,
this is where everybody fucking dies.
There's no way.
Bro, this guy used his teammate as cover.
That's so fucked.
Oh god, they're all sandwiched!
I literally saw the Ashe just use his teammate as a fucking bullet shield.
Damn, I was like, damn, poor Gippy.
That poor man.
Oh my god.
He got fucking fed.
Holy shit.
Whoever... Oh my god.
I'm jealous of all the teams who had godspot.
I'm so jealous.
Like, it's just good zone prediction.
We didn't have, like, we didn't have another thing to read zone, so it's just about predicting zones.
Which is really difficult because there's a million fucking zones.
If anyone got the zone, the end here of Ring 2, they are like Jesus.
They're zero.
They're actually Jesus.
I had, like, there were a few spots I thought it could have ended, but I'm not here.
Yeah.
Because there's, like, the thing is, there's, like, basically thousands of zone combinations that can happen depending on, and, like, it's very hard to predict zones.
My god.
You studied that?
All of you did?
Well, I don't.
I play with somebody.
I thought just scanning, like, the towers would be enough to, like, um... No, you gotta predict where things are.
Oh, man.
RNG.
So, like, especially after, like, some teams don't have the advantage of being able to have zone scanners.
So, like, they have to figure it out after first scan.
Oh, do we not have that?
No, we did have first scan, but, like, we didn't have second scan, so we had to predict it.
So, yeah, basically have to guess where it is.
I mean, sometimes, even with, like, third scan, you can you still have to predict, because it can pull, like, somewhere else, though.
Yeah, it can flip.
Yeah.
The thing is, zones can also flip, too.
So, like, it's just hard.
It's very, like, if you can predict zones, like, as accurately as you can, then you're, like, fucking Apex Jesus.
Like, every team would want to have you, because you're literally game-changing.
You know where it's gonna fucking go.
Yeah, you can set up real well, too.
Like, okay, I get it now.
I get it.
Any team that figured out end zone basically has the biggest advantage, because they can set up everything and just wait for teams to walk in.
Bro, so, technically Rattstrat still works?
Well, not Rattstrat.
It's literally you show you have presence in one of the best spots possible.
Oh, okay, okay.
I thought it's, like, similar to that, where you're like, okay, I'm just gonna wait here, then.
Stuff like that.
No, it's more so, like, you have such a good location that teams coming in, you can just farm teams who are coming in.
Oh, shit, you're right, you're right.
They don't predict a zone correctly, so you just shoot the teams that are fucking running from the edge, trying to get to you.
And you just, it's just free shots.
I will never get this at all.
Like, you don't, you don't have to That's why I don't, I don't do, I don't learn zones.
I literally just play with people that know where the fuck zone is.
Cause I just, like, yeah, I'm just like, you know where the zone is, I'll just, I'll let you decide where to go.
That's why we have Flame.
That's why I have Flame here.
I'm pretty bad in zones as well, man.
I'm not the one that reads zones on my team.
Yeah, but like, you have the IG, you can try.
Yeah, you've played enough experience.
You can try.
Better than what I bring.
All I can do is just be like, Gerard, follow Gerard.
Go ahead, like, okay.
I'm just, like, blindly following because I have no idea what the strategies are.
And surprisingly, it's still held out.
We're still holding on.
Yeah, surprisingly,
we can do it.
It's just, you know, we just, we can have three games where we fuck up, but the next three we actually gotta do well.
Yeah, we have to actually land top ten.
Like, within top ten?
Nope.
Or like, top five is the requirement.
No, it's top ten.
Top ten.
Top ten, god.
Okay.
You having that bad?
Are we actually in the last this time?
Let's not think about that, Gerard.
Let's...
Gerard, let's not think about that.
Alright, alright, alright.
Let's just think about where we're at now.
Let's think about our next game.
Yeah, okay, okay.
Not knowing is...
You know, when we get a good game, let's think about it.
But now, let's just chill.
Don't look at it.
Just don't look at it.
I'm not gonna look at the chat anymore.
I don't wanna know.
Just don't look at your chat in three minutes.
Oh yeah, I forgot about that.
Don't look at your chat.
Yeah, okay, alright.
Jesus Christ.
Like, from who's... No, I'm not gonna ask.
I don't even know.
I don't even wanna know.
Like, I was about to ask, like, who killed us?
Who killed us?
I don't know.
Actually, I do.
Let me look.
It's team 16.
Is I16 or 15?
Because they died right after.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
I have no idea who they are.
Oh wait, I know Yuka.
Is that Yuka's team?
Or I don't know who Pog is.
Oh shit, it's Pog!
Okay.
Is that team 15 or 16?
Wait, apparently someone tried Japanese actors in here.
Wait, really?
That's cool.
Whoa, really?
I have no idea who it is.
We got this.
We just gotta figure out how this lobby Oh, we just gotta figure out how this lobby is like.
I thought that was, like, storm port for a second.
But I'm like, no, it says World's Edge.
I like how it says World's Edge ALGS.
We're in ALGS, guys!
Oh, um...
Uh, wait, maybe he'll get in.
Wait, so Wait, was I not inside?
Maybe he'll get in.
Maybe...
Maybe?
Gerard, I don't think you're getting in, Gerard.
Wait, I will, I will, I will!
I will!
I think he's not in.
I will, I will, I will.
You just have to believe.
No, it just says two people.
Alright, Flame, it's your turn.
I did last time.
No.
No!
Ping!
Gerard, you should tell them.
We did it.
Okay, where, where, where?
I've already told them.
Okay, where, where do I say it?
It's okay, it's okay.
It's all good.
In progress.
Okay, I'm in here.
Error!
Unable to connect.
Code view.
What?!
It disconnected me from the game!
Korean joined back because they don't know who it is.
I'm in here, I'm in here, I'm in here.
I'm in here, I'm in here.
So they don't know, they don't know who it, who's fault it is.
They don't know.
I hope they don't look at my POV!
God!
No, no one's gonna look at my POV.
Nobody knows!
No one knows.
They're like, why did they restart?
We'll never know.
I'm gonna get a cough job.
90 % of the restarts are because of me.
I don't know why to think about that.
God, please don't.
Please at least have one more person who's like, disconnecting.
Please.
Oh, I think it's just me, isn't it?
Uh-oh, are you guys like, actually playing now?
Oh, what the fuck?!
Hey!
Talk to me!
What's going on?
Jesus!
You guys are like, giving me the sound treatment!
Oh, my bad, man.
I'm like, hey, what?
Hello?
See?
Suddenly the bullying happens now?
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, Flame, are you gonna...
What?
What do you mean, bullying happens now?
Is he doing it?
What?
For a hot second.
New code.
Oh, shit, new code.
Oh, new code?
Oh, okay.
Nice.
They don't know.
Great, great, great.
Oh, is it in group A, the code?
No, it's gonna be in announce winners.
I like how all you wrote was D.C.
Yeah, that's how it usually goes.
D.C.
That's usually all you have to write.
LGS and scrims.
You're giving them the real scrim experience.
All right, code is out, Gerard.
Okay, all right, all right, got it.
It's in announce winners.
Yeah, I'm here.
Good.
I believe in us.
At least not last in terms of getting into the lobby.
Improvement, improvement.
Okay, I can feel it now.
I can feel it.
There's it, there's it.
Not last.
First.
We never got 20 in place, so I feel like at that point, you know, it's pretty good that we never got 20 in.
Yeah, at least we weren't really down first.
Oh, God.
Thank God.
It's the little things in life.
Are you guys excited to play more tomorrow?
Are you guys excited to play more?
Oh, what time is it?
Same time, really?
Let me actually double check.
In case, you know, the worst that could happen.
You know, the worst that could happen if we play tomorrow.
Oh, wait, no.
Wait, is it not?
Wait, I don't think it's the same.
No, that's the scrim block.
That's the scrim block.
Jesus Christ.
Look, it's all in Japanese.
I'm doing my best.
It's all in Japanese.
I'm looking through stuff right now.
You can do it.
I'm trying to figure out where the time is for a day for this.
Okay.
Is this day one or day two?
No, that's day one.
And then...
Where's day...
Where the fuck is...
Where the fuck is the schedule?
Okay, I can do this, guys.
Okay, POI, round robin.
That's winner's match.
Guys, I'm having trouble trying to find the schedule.
I'm having a little bit of a trouble.
I'll just ask them.
I'll be like... I'll preemptively ask them what time is day two.
Oh, matchmaking, matchmaking.
That's fine.
We still have to pick characters.
Okay, okay, alright.
Wow, you really wanted to hear her stop talking that much, Gerard?
Wow, he doesn't want to know.
He doesn't want to know what day two is.
If they tap out, like audio sometimes cut off.
I'm just saying.
Wow, you really didn't want to know what day two was.
No, I wanted to know!
I'm just letting you know.
I'm a great friend.
I let people know when things are happening.
You know he's a great friend when he says, I'm a great friend.
Why are you trying to convince me, or you?
I am a great friend.
Like to all of you, I'm a great friend.
I listen to your problems and I provide you with information.
He did listen to your problems.
He did.
Like I'm just instigating, man.
As long as he doesn't spawn and siphon, we're fine.
You're still thinking about that?
That was crazy.
I didn't choose that.
It just happened.
Yeah, I was actually I've never seen that before.
I didn't make it to the center.
That was a one time thing.
It will never happen again.
Sure.
It won't.
I totally believe in you.
You've been saying that but you don't.
Hey, purple our helmet.
Alright.
I'll grab the helmet.
There's one more bin over here.
There's a nemesis here but I'm not gonna.
If you see a repeater let me know because I'll try to run a repeater this time.
Just ammo.
Oh wait, nevermind.
There's a carbine.
JK
There's a repeater.
Okay, I'll run a repeater.
We're going through a fragment into geyser here.
Yeah, we want that cache on the right.
There's a carbine here if anybody wants it.
I'm okay.
I'm running repeater.
We have to be careful of survey camp but we'll hit that cache and then go into frag and then go into geyser.
Alright, I'm ready to go whenever.
Yeah, we can start going.
Careful with the cache there's a good chance geyser's gonna be there.
Someone needs to hit this bin.
I'll go for it.
Gerard, come towards me.
We need to look for this cache.
There's a good chance survey is going for it as well.
We have to be careful.
Do you need a 3x?
I have one, I'm okay.
Okay, I'll grab it.
I'm just running straight for the cache.
Go run back, Gerard.
Where do you want me to go?
Up towards the hill, we're just going into geyser.
Into fragment first.
I'm here.
I'll wait for you.
Do you want me to take the zip or just walk?
No, we can just go.
Anyway, it's fine.
Is your team in your room right now?
No, that's my brother and his friend.
He's watching you play?
No, they're just vibing behind me.
He's just vibing.
Gerard is very far, so...
Let me know if it gets like...
If they get too loud.
Yeah, no problem.
It's fine, it's fine.
Everything's fine.
It's okay, we have blue armor.
Things are different.
Someone's just flown up towards this truck.
Just come left with me.
There's a blue armor here.
There's a blue backpack.
I'm hearing a lot of fighting.
Can you guys come to me?
Yeah, I'm literally right behind you.
They're running kind of towards us here.
Wait, zone might be...
Yeah, zone's here, I think.
Zone's here.
Oh my god, I fucked up my climb.
Zone's like 100% here.
He's just playing on me.
He could be dying here.
Start putting walls.
There's a new castle up here.
There's a team playing under the bridge here.
Hit 50.
I need a wall back here too.
They're fighting at the house.
Put a wall behind.
That's a 3v1 already.
Behind.
I'm looking here.
Wait, I'm getting shot at.
Behind, behind.
I need a wall behind right here.
Where?
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm gonna place a wall down.
Wait, wait, wait.
Take that away.
Okay.
Got it.
That's a pretty ugly wall, I can't lie.
How many respawn?
Get a wall down like over here when you have it.
Look, look, look.
In the open.
Oh, no.
He heard me.
Oh, that rampart's flush.
This team can die.
Focus rampart.
Which one's rampart?
Behind.
Oh, I suck.
Wait, wait, wait.
Gibby on the right here as well.
New castle.
Shoot this.
On the right.
60.
I know.
Oh my god, they're so far.
60 on Gibby.
28 on one.
I'm gonna look behind us just in case.
Can you look at the back?
You look back.
Look behind and make sure nobody walks up.
So we can farm this.
Right here.
New castle.
60.
100.
Re-walled.
I couldn't hit him.
Yeah, nothing we can do.
We're getting shot from...
Oh, that's really bad.
Careful, careful, careful.
Oh, fuck.
I don't think I can look.
If we start getting naded or we have nowhere safe, just bubble, okay?
We might need you to re-wall this if you can get a shot from different angles.
Just play on me.
Right on me.
Yeah.
We need you to re-wall this if you can.
Yeah, just...
Here, I'll give you a shield here.
They're over here.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Should I deploy another shield?
Yeah, it's blocked.
So just put another one here.
You're gonna crack this one?
You're gonna crack it?
You gotta re-wall this.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Yeah, that's pretty rough, that one.
Whenever you're ready, just re-wall it.
Okay.
There's, like, nothing we can do.
Shit, they're breaking it.
Yeah, just do it on cooldown.
They're wasting their stuff.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, two seconds.
This one's more important.
Look, look, in the open, castle!
Running back.
There's people on the bridge.
Yeah.
When's your next thing?
Uh, ten seconds.
Okay.
Just put it down on my wall.
Okay, three seconds, two, one.
Oh, I'm getting shot in the back.
What's our heals?
I'm 1-5.
I'm 4.
I have a lot of bats, though.
I have three bats.
Can you say that again?
I have three bats, four shield cells.
Three, four.
What do you have?
Uh, druid.
What's your shield cells?
Shield cells, you want it?
No, just how many, how many.
Just one, just that.
That's your only heal?
Yeah, yeah, just keep it.
My heal is two, here.
You want a full medkit?
Here.
No, no, no.
Shields, what's your shields?
Cells and bats.
Uh, I don't have any more.
I just gave it.
Jesus, do you have no heals at all?
Uh, I have one.
I have two syringes.
Okay, okay.
We'll feed you one.
No, no, just feed it to him when he needs it.
Just in case.
Just don't peek.
Take it, take it, take it.
Just don't peek at all.
Just calm, calm.
This is a hard lobby, holy shit.
Keep trying, keep trying to get walls down.
Yeah, yeah, we need walls here.
I think we just ignore this west team, guys.
Pretty much don't try and peek them.
Can you get a wall down on main road?
Go to flame.
We need a wall next to him.
Just on this wall here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright, alright.
Like that.
Here.
Thank you.
I don't want to poke too much because I know they're going to destroy my wall if I look at them.
So I'm just going to wait until I get an actual good shot.
There's like a team right here that's looking to move.
Are they fighting?
No, they're just shooting each other.
They're just shooting and poking.
This team wants to move, but I don't know where they're going to move.
They don't have walls or anything.
They're under the bridge here.
Oh, right here.
They're over here now.
They're running.
They're like over here on the side.
They're peeking there.
Castle here on the right.
This guy is like walking back and forth.
Oh my god, everybody is so...
Oh.
If the zone pulls towards ghost out here, we want to just take this.
I'll just follow you whenever.
They're poking.
Nevermind, there's a team in there.
I don't know if it's just the Rampart.
Can you come to me and just use Sheila on that?
Sheila?
On that door.
I don't want to break the door.
Just break the door.
Just shoot it.
Hold it out and then shoot it with your ulti.
No, no, no.
Uncrouch.
Shoot this door here.
Nice.
Okay, that's it.
You can go.
You don't have to keep shooting.
I think it's a solo Rampart in there.
Should we rush it?
Should I give you a shield?
Yeah, yeah.
Put a cover down here.
Yeah, I'm like fairly confident that's a solo Rampart.
This zone pulled pretty bad for us.
633 to purple and this team has purple already.
These fuckers.
They're fighting on the other house.
We might want to just walk up on this.
I'm willing to walk up whenever.
Yeah, yeah.
Can you guys come to me?
Come to me.
We're just walking.
Come with me.
Go to this left row.
Okay, don't slide now.
Don't slide.
Don't make sound.
We go from the right.
Ready?
1, 2, 3.
Walking with me.
You bubble in here.
Bubble.
Yeah, it's a solo Rampart.
I'm jumping in.
70.
Where is he?
Where the fuck did he go?
He like walked.
I'm gonna get the massive.
He has nothing too.
That's good.
I don't know if there's anyone in this house in front of us here.
I don't know either.
They're all over here.
I don't think there is.
Do you want me to come over to you?
Oh, you're scouting.
There's people in this house.
I'm looking behind us.
I'm looking behind.
Okay, people are fighting over here.
We want to move, I think.
Someone just rezzed.
Oh, fuck.
There's people in our old house.
Oh, god.
They're using our...
It's fine.
You can get rid of your own.
So they don't have cover.
How do I get rid of them?
Come to me now.
Let me know if you need...
We want to go inside this house.
I need a bubble.
We don't have bubble.
I'm ready to go whenever.
Slide right here.
Come with me.
Move right.
There might be a team underneath.
No, there isn't.
We're safe.
I have bubble and 8.
Stay behind me.
I'm looking behind.
Just in case.
Nice.
Perfect.
I'm looking here.
Someone's gotta look front.
Who's looking at front?
There's an angle right here that we have to be careful of.
Look at my red ping.
Everyone, look at my red ping.
Careful of that angle.
On the other side there as well.
You just have to be careful of it later.
They're fighting here, I think.
I'm gonna look in front of us.
There's some further forward here.
I'm looking up here just in case for us.
There's a team right up here.
One ping.
Give me bubble on my red ping.
Do you want me to look?
Walking at me!
It's from the house above us.
Can you look here for us?
So I can look with the plane.
75.
100.
Oh my god, I missed every shot.
Can't really do anything.
Get more covers down here.
On my red!
Full team!
Can I kill one?
I cracked one, I cracked the other.
Gara left!
They're on the hide.
Put cover!
They're fighting on me.
I'm here, I'm here.
You stay here, Gerard.
They climbed up!
Nothing we can do.
Just chill, go back.
You just stay in your area.
You're anchoring this.
We kinda need them to die here.
They're rezzing.
Yeah, they're rezzing at the bottom.
The team above is fully healthy.
We just chill.
Look up in front, I'm looking in front.
They're fighting again.
I killed one, we just chill again.
Come to me!
I'm right behind you!
We push this!
Push this!
On me!
Bubble out to me!
Fight!
Bubble!
In the corner!
I'm here!
Dead!
We're getting pushed!
Oh god!
I got shot by too many things.
I'm using my shield.
I'm covering!
They're pushing up!
That was a good fight though.
There was just too many.
Nothing we can do.
We got top 10!
We got top 10 with 5 kills.
This team is just inting us for no reason.
They have height and they're just running at us.
Did they run down from height?
Oh my god.
That was stupid.
That's fine.
They gave up their height.
Oh my god.
That team on height was so lucky.
If they don't give up their height, they walk in for god spot.
They can win this game.
Oh my god.
This Pathfinder just took the god spot to the side.
The solo Pathfinder got the god spot.
That's crazy.
This was the team that pushed down on us.
Oh, this was the team?
This was the team that thirded us.
They would have had a really good spot.
They were a full team.
I mean, now that he's a solo, he...
Oh, never mind!
How is he alive?
Just shut up!
I was like, why did he run away?
That is crazy.
Why did the team run away?
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
I mean, hey.
That's pretty good.
Definitely not 20th place now.
Definitely.
Let's go.
That's a lot better now.
I think if we get like 20...
26 points, we should be good, right?
Like, overall.
I think 26 points would be top 10.
Hopefully.
How many points is 5 plus placement?
Plus 8th place?
That's like...
7 points.
That's 10?
Guys, we just need another 10 points.
And then we're...
We just need 10 more?
Wait, did we get 5?
No, we got 5 kills with 8.
That's 10 points?
7.
7?
Okay, never mind.
That's less impressive.
God.
That's less...
Whoa!
Okay, that was a really good nade.
Bro, everyone hit him with that.
Whoa.
That's a really good nade.
Yeah.
Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Oh my god.
I'm dead in the...
The Newcastle played it.
Yeah.
Okay.
They got like 2 shots off on his teammate.
Yeah.
Oh, it's a different time.
It's different.
Oh, it's later.
It's a bit later.
It's 3am PST for me.
So it's 7...
7.50pm JST.
So it's 8pm JST.
It starts at 8.30pm.
Oh, it starts at 8.30pm JST.
So it's a lot later.
Does that still fuck you over, Gerard?
No, it's fine.
It's okay, it's okay.
It's fine, it's fine.
It's fine, it's okay.
It's okay.
I can still keep going.
What happened to the passion?
I can't...
What happened?
The passion is here!
You're like, it's fine.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I can do this.
What happened, Gerard?
What happened to your passion?
It's gone.
Sometimes it wavers, sometimes it don't.
There are times like that.
I can still go.
You're just thinking about day 2 and you're just like, what did I agree to?
Yeah, what did I agree to?
I thought this was like one day.
I told you it's two days!
I said two days!
I thought it was on a separate day.
Oh well, it's fine, it's fine.
It's 8pm, right?
8pm JST.
8.30.
Okay, I can still make it.
I think I'll be over by that time.
Okay, I need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back, guys.
Okay, alright.
Wow.
Insane.
Well, I didn't think we'd be making it this far.
And that was really insane.
Getting that one dub was enough to fill in.
To actually make me happy.
Thank you, thank you so much.
Whether we lose here or whatever, I like it.
I like what happened today.
It feels like I gained new friends and also I feel like I gained some experience.
And it also gave me insight on how pro players play.
And my god, that is insane.
I don't think I can match the current playstyle that they're doing right now.
But eventually in the future, if I actually get into it.
But Apex is really fun.
It's really, really fun.
I'm happy that I get to play it with both of you.
Really.
Yeah.
It's an opening moment.
Apex is definitely at its peak in tournaments.
Oh yeah, definitely.
The hype is just super insane.
The strats and everything dude, it's just badonkers.
When I was so addicted, not really addicted, but when I was really into Apex, I think a few years ago, I would just non-stop watch streamers play solo queue.
Do you solo queue in Apex?
Very rarely.
I mean, I'll solo pubs, but never really ranked.
Oh yeah, I mean for sure.
I think the sweatiest people are like, yeah, I don't think you'd be able to do that.
I mean, probably you can, but I think that's just stupid.
It's very taxing on the mental.
What is?
Like solo queuing.
Oh no, 100%.
No, but I still did it yesterday or today.
Yeah, so we're definitely going for day two.
Well, we don't know yet.
We have three more games and we do really well.
The thing is, the next three games is Flame's actual LGS drop spot.
So he's very familiar.
So like, we have a lot of expectations.
The thing is that we just need one really good game and then we get top ten.
It literally only takes one good game.
One good game.
Yeah.
Okay.
So.
Holy shit!
Oh my god, here's the rotation.
Red is hitting console.
So that's you, Drag.
Drag, you gotta know how to do this.
Rotation.
Yeah, that's how you loot.
Yeah, so you land at the side that doesn't have an arrow.
So the arrow is like where you end it.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
So you land on the two bins, loot into the pyramid, you go right and then into the houses.
Usually you want to hit console as soon as you're done with the two houses.
And Doki, you and I have to swap between yellow.
Actually, no, both you and I can hit support bins.
You take yellow, I take blue.
I land on the far right, right?
So like, the yellow arrow is where we end, right?
Alright, I got it.
We're doing homework, guys.
This is...
This is our homework real quick.
I'm putting this on my other chest.
Wow, I should have known this beforehand.
I must have been stealing a bunch of your materials.
Whoops.
No, this is a new drop spot.
This is a new one.
Oh, okay.
We're going in now.
Okay, I gotta check.
Where are we?
Okay, so it's here.
Oh, okay, that's fine.
Gotta land here, okay.
Remember, gotta land over here.
Okay, alright.
Got it to the T.
You wanna make sure you hit console as soon as possible.
Oh my god, we're doing our homework.
I have a triple take, do you want it?
Uh, yeah, I want it.
Okay.
Thank you.
There's also a stock here too.
Yup.
Okay, just checking, just checking.
Oh my god, did my homework.
I'm doing it, I'm doing it, I'm doing it.
Doing our homework.
Who's picking up?
Did you do your homework at school?
No.
I never fucking did.
That's why we're streamers now.
That's why we're streamers.
I did my homework.
I used to be a really good student.
Yeah, and then I discovered.
Honors.
You were honors?
But you didn't do your homework?
Well, cramming.
Like, I would do it during the class itself.
We need to hit, just hit console and then we're hitting cash and leaving.
Yeah.
I have everything I need.
Console time.
Console, console.
They're poking now.
It's on me.
Console, okay, okay.
Yeah, okay, okay.
Don't worry, we have like two more games for you to practice this rotation.
I think Cascades might be rotating to us here.
Yeah, I think so too.
I want this cash.
There's a redeploy right there if we need it.
They're sitting on the cash.
That's annoying.
The zone might be on us, I'm not sure.
Not again.
Okay, I'm on my way.
To you?
No, no, hit the console.
Zone, zone, zone.
Are they sprinting at me?
Okay.
I don't have a bubble, I had to give it to him.
Yeah, I'm right here.
Where are you?
I'm coming over to you.
I think it is on us.
Yeah, you guys have to.
They're running above me.
I don't have scope.
I got a scope here.
Run slow behind, run slow behind.
Look at the guy behind.
Twelve, I hit twelve.
I don't have scope, by the way.
Here, here, take it, take it.
He's running past the bubble.
Just don't be in open, don't be in open when you do that.
Okay, okay, here, here, take it, take it, take it.
Wait, uh, we just grabbed the cash here.
We're not behind them.
I want to be in barrel here.
Do we have an evac?
Doki, can you come towards me on the evac?
Yeah, I'm coming, I'm coming.
Do it like here.
Yeah.
You can evac now.
Alright.
We want to go right into spiders here.
I'll wait for you.
Yeah, go now.
Someone might be at that house.
I think we should fight for it, to be honest.
I have bubble.
Droid is not healed though, that's the thing.
No, it's okay.
I have one shield bat.
Do you have shield cells?
I can give you shield cells.
Do you want us to use spiders?
Come here, come here, come here.
I'm right behind you.
There's a cache next to us.
Yeah.
Need to clear this house first.
Can you bubble in?
Yep.
Someone's routing, we might die.
Nope, everything's fine.
We just hold now.
On the roof, on the roof here.
One, two, three, shooting.
Am I stupid?
How did I miss that?
I missed that too.
I'm going to grab the triple-tag.
Okay, we can do spiders and we can grab the cache.
I've dropped it.
You might need to bubble me here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm heading out.
You stay here, Droid.
I'll let you know if I need bubble.
Okay.
Did you get it?
Landing here in the open, look, look, look.
Okay, I'm looking, turn around.
I don't see it.
They've already gone underneath.
Okay, I'm still inside the house.
Yeah, just stay there.
I'm going to do spiders then.
Uh, yeah, we can.
I'm just going to do spiders from here.
You have to make sure no one walks up on this cannon here.
Yeah.
In the open, in the open here.
You have to stay right there, Droid.
I'm looking.
Is he, is gone?
No, he's behind us.
Yeah, he grabbed the cache, he grabbed the cache.
Oh shit, okay.
They're running up here.
He's running in the open right now.
50, cracked him, he's 1.
He bubbled, he bubbled, he bubbled.
I don't have an angle on that.
Yeah, I'm good.
There's like 50 HP.
I'm going to
grab this helmet.
I need this ammo actually.
Yeah.
Do you have the rest of the ammo?
No, I can't.
Okay, I'll grab more.
I already kind of have everything.
Alright, I have everything I need too.
Is the team just playing on the prairie here?
I'm playing in the house.
Just to have a better angle.
On the right side.
I'm looking west.
Yep.
I'll look west.
Droid's looking north.
Get some covers outside here, Droid.
Droid, put cover outside.
Outside, in front.
Make sure it doesn't block the door.
Yeah, I mean that's fine.
If you can put a cover on the left here as well, that'd be pretty good.
Whoa, that scared the shit out of me.
Holy fuck.
I'm looking north right now.
No, there is a piece of cover there.
There's no way.
I don't know what, but I'm shooting through him.
Gang issue, maybe?
Inside the next room.
I don't know, honestly.
Shit, they're fighting there.
Wait, we're all looking at the same area.
I'm looking...
Droid, look at a different angle for us.
Yeah, I'm looking behind here.
Is this okay?
Yeah, that's good.
I don't know if we drop off for this.
Not drop off, but the angle.
Hostile spotted.
Can you hit that guy?
I can't, no.
There's a cover right there.
I swear, I swear there is.
We might need a canoe cover.
We need another cover here.
We need a new wall droid.
Okay, alright.
Destroy it, destroy it.
Yeah, you can.
One, two, three, four, five.
Okay, there's five.
I was wondering if we should wall the bottom just in case, but I don't know.
Yeah, definitely should.
Yeah, droid, droid, come here.
Take this, take this away, take this away.
And then wall here.
Down here.
So we know if somebody comes down.
Okay.
Let us know your cooldowns, because we need to re-wall places.
Yeah, it's fine, it's fine.
I got it, I got it.
Outside?
Wait, wait two seconds.
No, okay, I didn't get the door I think on.
Alright, you can start pulling.
There.
And then, droid, come over here.
Can you do it against the door or no?
I don't know if you can.
This is too thick.
Or like too wide.
Can you do it against it?
Like just on this, yeah, like on like here.
Like blue, just...
It's showing me red, I can't...
Okay, but you can.
I don't know if you can for this door.
Wait, wait, um...
Gotta be extra...
How do you...
You can, that's fine.
I was just curious if you could.
The team on upper barrels.
It's only available on that one.
Okay, that's fine.
Then we should be good.
Oh, can you put a cover on my right here?
One, two, three.
Yeah, we have a lot.
One, two, three, four.
You look in front of you?
Yeah, just on the right.
We still have one more door.
Thank you.
Oh!
On me?
Okay, he's...
Should I give you a shield?
Yeah, definitely.
Just in case they cross again.
Okay, you look this side.
I'm gonna look here.
I wanna see what they're gonna go through.
They're shooting over here.
Someone's fighting over here.
I don't see them.
I see bullets.
Okay, if you see people standing in the open, let us know and we'll shoot.
And we'll take spots.
Oh my god.
Okay, you IGL.
You're doing great.
Oh, thank you.
I don't like IGLing.
It's too much stress.
What the hell is IGL?
In-game leader.
Oh.
It's too much work.
Oh, car, car, car on the left.
Okay, I'm looking for you.
They stopped in the open right now.
See them?
They're straight up in the open.
They don't have a bubble.
Okay.
I don't see them yet.
They're like...
I don't have an angle on this.
Yeah, it's really hard.
Can we see from the door?
Yeah, can you see from this side?
Do they bubble?
I'm gonna look back on my end.
Bin's refreshed.
Oh, there's a mythic bin right there.
I can what?
Bubble?
Oh, that's the corner.
That's with them.
I just mean we might be able to shoot people.
Let me know and I'll rotate.
This team's getting bullied right now.
Someone died.
Can you give me another wall here?
Car, car, car!
They took the middle spot.
That spot is really good.
That's the spot I wanted.
Enemy, enemy!
Okay, I'm looking.
Your gun shield is crazy.
They're like all the way to the far right there.
So I can't do anything.
Bro, I swear this new castle is like...
Spinboarding.
I can't handle it.
The moment your shot looks at him, he just...
It just turns.
He just turns like...
Just a tiny bit.
Man, they're shooting something over there.
We'll never know.
But I can't see it.
We need a cover here.
Refresh.
Thank you.
Someone landed on this hotdog.
Team over here is...
Keep looking.
We just need to make sure nobody pushes up.
Oh shit.
Shots on cannon.
Okay, I'm heading over.
Come to me.
You stay.
Stay and make sure our spot is still there.
They're fighting.
I'm over.
They might have finished.
Is it worth it?
You can just go back.
I'll go back.
Just stay there and make presence.
Oh shit, they're red.
It's fine.
I have to run back.
They're walking at me.
Okay.
Dread, can you open the door?
Come downstairs and open the door for us.
Come downstairs, Dread.
Open the door.
Here, thank you.
Just close the door again.
Dread, we swap spots.
We're getting megadrilled from cannon now.
We're getting megadrilled from cannon.
Okay, you look there.
They're gonna be a pain in the ass.
Liam and I are just gonna check up.
They're fighting down here.
They're not.
I'm looking at the right side then.
Cannon is still our biggest threat.
They're right here.
I have 56.
I'm looking back.
I'm looking back at us.
I've been drilled on the outside again.
I'm looking here because they're getting poked heavily.
There's someone peeking from the zone here.
Castle.
I'm just looking at this.
They're getting pushed.
Look at zone.
We have to move to here.
Look at this.
I got one.
There's a full fight here.
I got kill.
We have to move.
This team is moving.
I'm ready to move whenever.
I think we should move now.
Come with me.
This is gonna be really hard.
Just run with me.
Keep running.
We're going under here.
Then we're taking bottom floor of this house.
Keep coming.
Don't look back.
I'll bubble when we really need it.
Sit behind me.
Sit behind me for 2 seconds.
Climb up.
1, 2, 3, climbing.
Bubble us on this door.
Come inside.
100.
I got one.
Fight.
Last guy.
Just heal.
Put walls.
Come to me.
There's a full team there.
We just have to chill.
There's a golden PK right here.
Can you come to us?
Put walls down.
Put wall here.
I'm peeking outside.
I don't know what's going on.
There might be another team.
There's an R9.
I'm getting the R9.
I'm healing.
I have an R9.
I'm only close range.
They're rezzing.
They're rezzing right under me.
You want me to come down?
I have R9 on me.
Come look at this.
I killed one.
Gibby's one.
Come back.
Can you climb up?
I can.
I'm safe for rezz.
Thank you.
There's a team underneath.
Try peeking us.
You have to fight.
Just hold.
It's a solo nuke castle.
You're okay.
I'm healing.
I'm going to rezz.
You cover that door.
Just shoot your Sheila.
They won't push in.
Just heal.
Take my shield.
Are you fine?
Just heal.
Healing.
We have to make a play here.
Do you have bubble?
Can you bubble up?
We just fight them.
Bubble up.
They're not here.
Castle on me.
He's one.
On my door.
Dead.
There's a team.
Zipping.
Above me.
On hype.
Come left with me.
Left.
It's fine.
They got me.
Come down.
I'm here.
You have to hit this climb.
I don't think I can make it.
Get on this rock and climb to me.
Don't panic.
Keep coming.
I got it.
They're walking up to me.
He's right below me.
Just hold on me.
I need to heal.
We have to be careful of the walk up over here.
I'm here.
We just play behind my Q first.
You save your bubble.
I have bubble.
We can kill them.
I don't have an angle.
I don't either.
Climbing.
142.
Good shots.
I need to not touch my Q.
The spinning thing is crazy.
We need to make a play.
I can ult this side.
You want me to?
No, save it.
I'm looking climb up.
Horizon Q.
They're fighting.
Just heal.
I'll look for climb up.
The team under us doesn't take this Q.
I'm looking for us.
They're crafting over there too.
They're fighting.
I'm going to nade.
I have a lot of nades.
We have to do something here.
Save your nades.
I think we have to bomb this team.
87 in the back.
Kill.
He's right here.
Cover.
Inside.
At the back.
Fight this.
I'm batting.
I'm here.
Don't jump in.
Stay outside.
I need a dome.
Pushing.
I broke it.
I'm fine.
We just chill here.
Play for these two kills on the left.
Right here.
We're okay.
Focus the left.
I'm waiting.
Pushing us.
Can't see them.
I'm timing.
Okay.
String this.
Get these kills.
I couldn't.
You guys did great.
Awesome.
I literally looked at Sheila and got beamed.
It was so hard.
I couldn't do anything.
When he got rid of his wall, the box just disappeared.
That's weird.
I wanted to stop it and it was just gone.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Unfortunate.
How many points does that give us?
That's 9?
Or 10?
9.
We got 6th place, right?
Give me one second.
That's 9.
9 points.
Okay.
We have 16.
We just need another 10 points.
We should be good.
Alright.
Nice game, everybody.
Oh my god.
R9 was clutch for me.
I could actually do stuff.
That was an intense game.
We got really good.
I'm surprised we got the rotation.
We were just running in the open.
That rotation was so fucking scuffed.
I don't know how the fuck me and Flame made it through.
That was awesome.
We just ran there.
Oh my god.
We made it.
That rotation is actually what I live for.
Let's go.
Let's just run.
It's like running past the fucking battlefield.
We're storming Normandy again.
It's like World War 2 and we're fucking storming the beaches.
The beaches.
Here we come.
Oh my god.
Two more games, guys.
Two more games.
Two more.
How many points are we at?
7 plus 9, so 16.
Okay.
That was 9 points, right?
5.
We got what?
6 kills?
5 kills and 6 plays?
I'm checking the thing right now.
Give me one second.
Yeah, we are at 16 points.
Okay.
So we just need...
Top 10 is only at 24.
Cutoff is gonna look like 30.
Oh, 30?
Oh my god.
It's gonna be high 30.
Oh my god, that's the cutoff.
That means everybody is getting in and stuff.
Yeah.
I hesitated too much there.
I tried to use the horizon queue to get up to the roof but I should have just climbed it.
If I climbed it, they were popping literally a mobi rez.
I could have just You could have farmed it.
Actually just destroyed them.
Now you know.
We could have taken the mobi rez and that would have been 8 kills with a top 5 and we can do more from there.
I don't know why I didn't just climb.
I looked at the horizon queue There was so much stuff happening.
There were literally gunshots all around us.
I had the same idea.
I wanted to get to the roof.
I don't know why I thought I had to take the horizon queue.
You just saw it.
It was so tempting though.
You were just like I could take it right now.
When will I ever get that chance again to just take that horizon queue.
To be fair I think if I had 20 ping, I would have been completely fine.
I'm pretty sure that was another 300 ping game.
Wait, really?
Oh my god.
What the fuck is going on with your routing there?
That's crazy.
Yeah, Tokyo usually for me is sometimes like a 300 for no reason.
Yeah.
Just unrouting sometimes.
It's like the case for Korean players as well.
I have a friend in Korea and sometimes he just gets 350 ping.
Yeah, that's insane.
That's really weird.
That's crazy.
I guess they just swapped servers for this one.
Like the...
I don't think they did.
Yeah, I don't know.
Like the same server The winner's round is like this.
Some games it's not.
And some games it is.
If I play ranked in Tokyo, some games I have like 90 ping and some games I have 300.
That's interesting.
Wait, what's your ping?
How do you even check your ping?
Okay.
Okay, you go to settings.
You go to...
I don't even know how to do that.
You go to settings.
I've been experiencing like ping issues.
Like everyone is teleporting.
Go to settings.
And then you go to...
You scroll down until you see accessibility.
You scroll down and you see accessibility.
And then you look up and you see performance display.
You press on...
Performance display...
Colorblind...
Subtitle...
No, you go look up.
Not under accessibility.
You look up.
Oh, okay.
Performance display.
I thought it was in the...
That's why I said you look up.
I saw what happened in one of that map where we had to guide you like a rat.
That's so funny.
We were like, Jirard, that's right.
Follow the ping.
I was panicking.
It was so funny though.
I was trapped in this...
Yeah, you were trapped in the fucking cage.
And the fact that Flame gave you a medkit for a good job done.
Good job, Jirard.
He has a medkit.
I am directionally challenged in Apex.
I do not memorize anything here.
L, M, N, I.
I don't know how many hours you have in Apex, but I remember when I first started playing the game, it was just information overload.
Oh my god, I currently have...
Oh my god, this is my...
Okay, so this is not including my other account, but this is the one where I grinded Pred.
It has 918 hours for this account.
So...
That is very little.
Yeah, but I wasn't on this account for three years.
Oh my god.
So there's definitely more.
I don't know how many hours the other account has.
Jesus Christ, there's more?
Alright, it's time to lock in last two games.
Last two games.
If we get champion this game, we don't have to worry about the last game.
That's all I'm saying.
I'm throwing.
The endgames are a lot more like...
Crazy?
Everyone's just playing good spots.
Yeah.
Basically, like I said, it's like LGS, but VTubers.
It's literally that.
There's a team with 60 points.
I don't know.
Holy shit, what the fuck are they doing?
Do the same thing.
Remember to do the console right after.
Run with the house on my yellow ping.
Run for the console.
Underneath the big building.
Okay, okay.
You want to hit it as soon as possible.
Alright.
I have a 3x if you need it.
Do you need it?
Yeah, I do.
Can you hold on to it?
Thank you.
I don't have the...
Oh, I do.
Triple take.
Do you need that, Flame?
Yeah.
If you see another triple take, let me know.
Yeah, I will.
There's actually an extra 3x here, but it's far, so...
Yeah, I'll just bring it over there.
Do you need this?
No, I don't.
Okay.
No caches on us?
I can't see through the pings.
Is there no caches on us?
Nope, no caches near us, unfortunately.
Okay, I'll just leave.
Okay, we need to be there.
We need to go now.
I'm heading over now.
Start running towards the hill.
We're hitting cannon.
I'm heading over.
I have a...
We want to be in one of the nuts here.
Either that or on the hide.
I left my 2x, so...
You're the only one with a scope for now.
That's fine.
I have a 1x to 2x.
I can give you for the 3x if you have it.
I have a 1x.
You want it?
No, it's fine.
I'll take his 1x or 2x.
We just leave first.
We just have to go first.
Run...
Here.
We need to go right here.
Don't loot.
Just keep running.
No looting.
We need to go super, super fast.
Going, going, going.
Can we hit this blue bin?
Yeah, I can hit it.
I'll hit it.
Or you hit it.
Your support too.
Just keep going.
No looting, no looting.
We have to get to this right nut.
Uh oh.
I'm going to shoot a cell behind and then I'll go.
I can throw a bubble to him in a minute.
Bubble into me.
It's a solo.
I think it's a solo.
I got the bubble.
He ran off.
Did he?
They ran.
There's an energy here.
Yeah.
I'm going to hit that cache outside.
Can you come with me?
Start walling.
Start walling again.
Get walls outside here on major road if you can.
Careful.
What's your bubble at?
I have 3 seconds.
I'm going now.
Wait until you need it.
I'll let you know if I need it.
We'll heal first, Gerard.
Don't risk dying.
If you die, we can push.
We can't move anymore.
They took this door so we don't have this door.
Yeah, it's fine.
Do you need shields?
Do you not have heals?
I'll give them to you.
Just...
Don't heal, Gerard.
No, no, no.
It's okay, really.
Just take these bats for now.
I think you mostly want to use bats.
Yeah, you just want to use bats because you're...
I can give you one more shield cell but heal that pull up.
We want to use the cells so we let Gerard use the...
Okay.
He should...
So I should be using bats or cells?
It depends.
It depends on how much health you have.
Come out to me and start getting rampart covers down.
Team Godrock.
There's a car behind us.
There's a car right here.
Wait, is that their car?
Yeah, it's their car.
You want to set up a shield over there?
No, just get rampart covers here on the right.
How many cells do we have?
I have six cells.
I have six cells, one bat.
Oh, here's a purple mag.
I have a purple mag.
How many cells do you have, Gerard?
I have one.
Okay.
I'm four, eight.
How many bats do you have, Gerard?
One.
Oh my God, Gerard.
Do you loot heals?
No.
I need to watch your bot after this.
I do.
You said we need to run.
I ran.
I got everything that I needed.
Gerard, I'm sorry, but I do not believe you right now.
What?
I do.
I've never heard anyone leave Ceto Station with that little loot, brother.
Literally, never.
On us, on us.
We're getting locked up.
Oh my God.
I couldn't pay attention.
I was laughing.
With me, Gerard.
One HP, Castle.
Okay, okay, okay.
I don't even know where we got locked from.
No!
I'm so sorry.
I wasn't locked in.
Oh my God, I wasn't locked in.
I laughed at this.
No, I'm so sorry.
The Gibraltar slid in.
That is tough.
Did they break our door with Rampart?
I don't know.
There was no roll for that door.
For that specific door when I walked up.
Because, like, he was...
Gerard was waiting for his cooldown.
He was waiting for his fucking...
Bro, why did they do that?
They died for it.
Yeah, that's tough.
Why did they do that?
We just need one really good game, guys.
laughing.
Just one more, and we have literally one more chance.
We just need a 20 point game, guys.
We just need a 20 point game.
We'll win with 8 kills.
Hey, we managed to get 11 kills on those other ones.
We just need one really good game.
laughing.
We let our guard down for one second.
That's crazy.
Why does that always...
We let our guard down for one second and that's when they appear.
Every time.
We died because of it.
That's crazy.
Alright guys, free up your schedule for tomorrow.
I can't wait to see you guys again.
laughing.
Oh, I have to...
I've had to do so much rescheduling already, man.
laughing.
Oh no.
Wait, I gave you the...
Okay, I gave you the fucking...
The server that had all the information.
And it's all in Japanese!
laughing.
Oh my god, he actually gets the res after the shit he pulled?
Yeah.
It's just crazy.
It's actually crazy.
Oh my god, they like griefed us so hard just for that to happen.
Oh guys, I think we actually died 20th place.
laughing.
We were last!
After a very long time.
We hit our high during like the first bracket and now we're back to the lows.
laughing.
We hit the highs and now we're at our lows.
We literally have just one more chance, like last chance.
The next game is our last game.
Okay, Jiraiya.
How good are we supposed to be?
Okay, Jiraiya, to be fair I think the elimination bracket is not as difficult as this because this is literally a top 10 from each bracket.
So like, those who lost this one will have to fight the will have to fight the teams who won the first elimination.
It's literally like ALGS.
Wait, wait, wait.
Are you sure we're playing at that time?
I think that's why it starts so late because they're doing the first elimination first.
So it's like actual ALGS where we fight the winners of the first elimination.
Yeah, yeah.
We already beat them before so like maybe it'll be different.
I don't know.
Okay, yeah, no.
It is a limited, yeah.
It should be fine.
But then we also have the people, bottom 10 from here too, so like that's where it's harder because the bottom 10 here will be in our lobby.
So we're at the part where they stormed our house while I was laughing.
They're like the killer joke.
Alright.
Jeez, what made you laugh?
Because when he was like I need to VOD review you I...
That part, okay genuinely when I heard like we need to go I immediately like shifted gears and just started running.
Okay, this is our loot heals.
We can't keep feeding you heals.
We need our own heals.
Don't look at the screen.
It's fine.
We're VOD reviewing this.
After this game we're gonna VOD review for 10 minutes.
Don't look at the screen.
You are under judgment right now.
Sure, go ahead, go look at it.
But when I heard it I immediately like okay I need to go.
It's fine that you went, but like how do you not have heals?
I was looking at the places of where the map was telling me and I was getting stuff.
Right after this game it's VOD review time.
VOD review and you're just pointing out like what I did wrong.
That's what VOD review is!
That is what VOD reviewing literally is.
Why?
So you're getting two!
Please tell me you got this.
It's like what do you want it to be like?
Come on!
I am so sorry.
Yes, okay.
I get it.
I will get me some healies.
Wait, you can actually rewind his stream?
Oh, you're actually doing his VOD review right now?
Yes!
I'm streaming it!
Oh my god!
While we're waiting for this game to end It's time to VOD review!
He's streaming it!
Look at your stream!
Oh god, the embarrassment is right here.
He's VOD reviewing.
He's literally checking.
Holy fuck!
You have to wait.
There we go.
I turned it off.
Fuck you.
It's over.
On one bed and six cells.
One bed and six cells.
Shut the fuck up!
I was wondering why we get to the place and he's just like I'm 1-0 guys.
I'm 0-0.
I have no cells.
I have no heals.
You want a syringe?
Okay, alright.
I didn't think I'd be VOD reviewed God damn it!
I should have turned off the fucking DVR.
God damn it.
God wasn't on my side today.
There's no God here.
It's just you.
Everybody like I want you guys to clip just counter I want you guys to make a counter of how many cells that I've missed throughout my entire run.
Like oh my god I missed like probably a hundred fucking cells and I did not even bother to pick him up.
Jesus.
You're hurting him.
You're fucking hurting him right now.
Holy shit!
What the fuck is this guy's house?
It's literally just filled with this.
What is that?
This is where all your bats and shield cells went to.
Oh, where's all these cells?
Where did all these cells go?
I'm not watching the same team you guys are.
Oh, you're not?
Okay, open up.
Wait three minutes and then open up my stream.
Dude, like Fuse, Gibraltar and like Newcastle are like dancing on these top cells.
That's crazy.
There's no way that's end zone.
Where the fuck did they pick them up?
From mice?
What?
No, they killed this house.
This house had so many people die.
And then they rotate after.
Really?
It just piled up.
Oh my god, they have like an entire stockpile down there.
In three minutes, get ready to see what we saw.
Okay, I gotta private this bot.
I gotta trim out the parts where I actually like Every single time I like failed to pick up the loot.
Yeah, I'm just gonna trim it out.
That's like every game.
You don't know that!
We literally asked you about your heal situation every time and then we're always so surprised.
We're like, how do you have so little meds?
Cause we always have to feed you dry.
I gotta bring out my first time card.
First time!
To be fair, we made it this far with you as your first time.
Don't give me that shit!
It was 100% my fault!
Shut the fuck up!
It was all my fault!
Okay, this time for real.
Flame, Flame, you gotta look at my bot now.
I think you're gonna be able to see what I saw.
It's like a bunch.
When they're at the place where there's a million shields and everything, it's actually crazy.
I think we're at the part where you're getting VOD reviewed.
Chaz, look at the part where you're getting VOD reviewed right now.
I can see them reacting to the VOD review.
I see it being private and live.
Is this why I can't watch your VOD?
Have you paused this?
So people won't rewind.
So if something happens, people won't rewind.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I know, I know, I know.
It's part of my journey.
I'm learning now, I'm learning now.
We're learning from our mistakes, it doesn't matter.
He keeps 400 ammo.
That's like the thing.
Per gun.
Do you see the house?
I'm watching.
I think you needed this, Duran.
Yeah, I needed all of that.
That's basically what you should have.
I'm afraid of looking into your VODs and how many batteries you guys have.
I usually carry 4-6.
2-3 max is just my shield battery cells.
I take 4-6 bats and 8 minimum shield cells.
How many shield cells should I have and how many bats?
So I can make some economy in my inventory or something.
He's taking your criticism now.
He wants to get VOD reviewed.
Now you want to get VOD reviewed after you private your VOD.
I'm gonna turn it back on.
No, I'm not gonna turn it back on.
Listen, we only have one more chance.
And we gotta do good and I'm gonna learn from that.
So how many should he have in his inventory?
How many should I have?
Cells and batteries.
As much as you can carry.
As much as I can?
Okay.
It depends depending on what backpack you have.
I run 2 bats, 8 cells.
That's about the bare minimum.
4 cells is okay.
Anything more and it's just kind of nice.
You don't need 400 ammo for one gun.
I thought that was the requirement.
200 is fine for your gun.
That's the requirement.
So you can have more space for meds.
Honestly, it's a little fun to have 400 ammo if you're willing to give us the ammo if we need it.
But other than that if you want to be the ammo carrier That was my idea!
I was picking up ammo for all of you.
But then you gotta make sure that we run the same ammo type.
Because it will be very useless if it's not the same ammo.
Oh yeah, you're right.
Alright.
VOD review was actually useful.
Okay, now I know.
That's why we're gonna win the next one.
Yeah, we're gonna win the next one.
And then we're gonna win tomorrow.
Or not.
No, no, no!
Tomorrow!
We're gonna make it.
Now we are!
We're gonna win!
I'm watching the last two teams fight and these guys know what they're doing.
These guys know what they're fucking doing.
Well, we do too.
Now we know.
Now I know.
Woah!
Oh my god!
Oh no, down!
I mean, it's usually a team that fights first dies.
Oh yeah.
For real.
Yippee!
Last game!
It's a make it or break it!
Alright, let's go guys.
Hey, someone's watching TV, what the fuck?
Get more water, I'll be right back guys.
I think?
I'll be right back, I gotta get water.
I gotta pee.
I've been holding this thing forever.
Okay, be right back.
Alright, now it's just me and both of their viewers.
Hello everyone.
That's it.
That's all I wanted to say.
Okay.
Alright, I'm back.
Are you guys pumped up for the last game?
Hello?
Hello, hello.
He's gonna take a piss.
I am not excited for this last game, I can't lie to you.
Wait, why?
This just could not have come at a worse timing.
Because we're asking for help from someone and like, I've had to reschedule a VOD review session that was supposed to happen like a few hours ago.
Oh no!
Right?
And then I told him let's do tomorrow at the same time.
Unfortunately, we don't make it.
But it's a different time, because like oh, but the same time is when we start the game.
Yes, the VOD review is set for 8pm SGT and we start at 6pm.
That's awkward.
That's so awkward.
I'm gonna have to ask him to reschedule again.
Sorry, I didn't realize we didn't make it too.
No, we didn't make it.
So we gotta play it next day.
Wait, what happened?
You didn't make it?
Wait, okay, I'll write the message to him and then you can copy and paste it.
Your responsibility.
And then you screenshot my message.
Okay, what's his name?
I'll write it.
I'll be like, hey...
His name is Balvarin.
Okay, okay.
Thank you, thank you.
I appreciate it.
Hey, Balvarin.
Sorry, man.
I fucked up, bro.
Oh, God.
You're gonna have to make room, man.
So we have to play an extra day.
And we need it more.
Okay, we're here.
There we go.
Hey, Balvarin.
Sorry, man.
I fucked up, bro.
I'm the leader for the team.
And we didn't make it.
We didn't make it to the top 10.
So we have to play an extra day.
And we need him.
We have to play an extra day.
He's our high GL.
There we go.
You can send that to him.
He'll understand.
Yeah, I'm sure he will.
I'm sure he will.
I'm hoping I don't have to send it.
I'm hoping we just qualify.
Are you waiting until we qualify?
Yes, I am waiting.
20 points, guys.
20 points.
No pressure.
Just 20 points.
Yeah, just 20 points.
We have to win.
We literally have to.
Guys, if we don't win, we get knocked out.
We get knocked out like the Falcons did.
And won the BLGS.
Why are we bringing that up?
What?
You got a problem with them?
Zero pissed you off or something?
No, I just...
Okay, but who hasn't been pissed off though, to be fair?
Hasn't he been really angry?
No, I just...
I just remember how people were like, Whoa, they didn't make it?
There's a backpack right here.
Yeah.
To be fair, Both Waldse and Hal are like not the greatest mechanical players and like fighting for controller is just rough.
To be fair, they put three IGLs in one team.
I don't know what they expected.
Yeah, I mean, Waldse is not really an IGL.
He was IGL in his last team.
Yeah, he was.
Do you need a triple take?
Or do you have one?
Yeah, I'll take a triple take.
There's one over here.
Remember to do the console.
Yep, yep, yep.
Just picking up stuff that I need to.
Remember to get meds.
They're very important.
You don't want to get bot reviewed.
Wait, we want to instant rotate in here.
I have one evac.
Can you hit the console to run?
Okay, console time.
I would say their biggest problem, honestly, is just having two controller players and a Gibby meta.
Their controller players are not very good.
Yo, my ping is 300.
Come hit the evac.
We're just leaving right away.
Okay, 200.
I got 200.
We want to be in this house here.
Okay.
Drag, drag, drag.
You have to go hit the evac.
Right now.
You have to hit it right now.
It's going to fade.
I think we just keep going ahead.
Yeah.
He's going to be really behind though.
Yeah, I know.
It's fine.
Are we taking that same house or a different house?
We want this house here.
Man, I'm...
Yeah, I'm pretty sure zone will pull on us.
Okay.
Like on this cannon here.
Oh, I hear another...
another evac.
Follow where we are.
Look at this.
You have to shoot for him.
Just keep running.
I don't think he's going to make it.
It's fine.
Just keep crawling.
Let's keep cracking and crawling.
They might bubble on us.
Are we getting flown on?
No, we're okay.
They might bubble car on us.
I'm playing roof.
Well, just as soon as I got all the bats, I fucking died.
Yeah, we don't have any walls, so that's like the worst part.
And there's no crafter near us.
I have a rez.
We have to sit here and stare at them pretty much the whole time.
Yeah, I have a rez.
Maybe you can figure out a way to get them.
There's no way we can get out until they leave.
We just have to sit here.
Do you want me to look anywhere else?
Or do you want me to look at them?
No, just hard stare at them.
They're going to hit the car.
I think I can go now.
You keep looking at them hard.
They don't know, I think.
I have to heal, though.
I'm still looking for you.
I have a rez.
There's a team right here.
I'm poking them.
I can throw a bubble whenever.
They might do my hard push, though.
I'm okay.
Don't rez yet.
I can ult them.
We need to get to the roof.
I'm looking at this team over here.
They're just getting shot at.
I have my own mobi here.
I'm just going to put it down on the roof.
Oh my god.
They destroyed my door.
This other team is rotating to the right.
I think they might zip to us.
I'm looking at them right now.
This is my last two shield cells.
I literally can't heal anymore.
I have one shield cell left.
Gibby's flashed here on the...
He's one!
There's another car.
That's them.
They're just grabbing cash.
I can't.
There's a team in front of me that's looking at me, too.
This team in front of me.
In seconds.
Scratch on Major Road.
Can you bubble up the left door here?
Can you bubble under us?
Bubble on the door.
We want to jump down.
I bubbled it.
I have no shield cells left.
Come, George.
I have to use all of them.
I'll give you heals.
Give me one second.
I'm dropping a bat for Gerard.
I dropped three cells for you.
I'm 1-4 now.
We have a really bad economy.
Gerard and AFK.
I don't think we should poke anymore.
You can peek off gun shield, but that's it.
We're running back here.
Gibby's peeking us.
Just chill.
Start putting walls around.
Put walls at the bottom first.
Put walls here.
And here.
So we know they push us.
Make sure we don't die if someone pushes us again.
On the stairs?
Here.
Just put against the wall.
And against this wall.
Against this door.
And this one here.
Seven seconds.
Use all three.
So they don't walk up.
Okay.
So we'll hear it when they walk up.
Because we don't need as much up here.
Okay.
16 more seconds.
Should I take these?
Should I take this?
Just put the bottoms first and then we'll worry about the top.
Okay.
We have three down here.
Put one...
Refresh this one.
Don't peek yet.
Don't peek.
Don't try trifling.
And yeah, just refresh that.
Yeah, listen.
I think we can peek a little bit.
And play off regen with castle wall slam.
Okay.
I'm purple already.
You want me to come over to you then?
If you guys get wrecked, we'll just slam castle wall.
Oh, okay.
You'll just slam.
Okay.
I don't think this team has Gibby.
No, they did.
Because that's the...
They bubbled that anyway.
Unless it's a new skin.
Yeah, you're right.
1, 2, 3, 4...
We have one more.
Can you put it right here?
For the last...
Last door right here.
We should be fine.
You guys have to make sure you're like...
Properly watching like...
Remember how we got to this building in that one game?
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
We have to make sure no one does that to us.
Someone's over here.
Shot me.
Over here.
This is bad.
There's a lot of angles.
Don't peek anymore.
You don't need to...
Flying in on me, I think.
Yeah, flying in on me.
Directly on me.
Flying literally on me.
Peek!
I'm okay.
I couldn't...
They're killable here.
Shoot this with the Rampart.
This team is looking at me.
Where?
Oh my god.
I couldn't...
Shoot the door.
Spray this.
Spray it, Joren.
Spray the door.
Come to me.
Just keep shooting into that.
There.
Open.
Okay.
Where's your...
I don't have...
Castle wall anymore.
Okay, take one of the doors away.
We need to put a shield back here.
Because now you have to do it again.
Because you have to take away one of the doors.
And remember to do this one too.
Remember this door.
Oh shit.
Let me know when you have your ult.
I only have one shield cell so I'll recharge off your ult.
I have two shield cells so I won't recharge off your ult.
Fifty percent.
Oh my god.
Okay, I can't peek now.
I'll wait.
I thought I could last...
They hit through my shield instantly.
I'll just fully heal my white meds.
Yeah, I'm 20% here.
Seventeen teams.
We're so...
We're so healthy.
Okay, I'm shield celling in.
No, no, no.
They're full on the rock.
Come to me.
He's in my corner.
Come here, come here.
They broke this one.
Oh, they broke this one too.
Our little home.
Andy, open here.
Castle.
Okay, I'm looking.
I don't see them.
I'm looking at the story.
Bin's refreshed.
Can you bubble up this way?
Yeah.
Oh, nevermind.
No, no, no, no.
I'm fine, I'm fine.
They're like hard staring at us.
Okay, that's fine.
They broke our wall here.
Yeah.
I can't even peek that.
They bubbled it.
They took the stuff in there.
Almost killed Rampart here.
Shoot this.
I'm looking.
I hit 40.
He's so low.
I hit 90.
I'm throwing a nade in there.
There's like all of us are looking at him.
I killed one.
You bubble up on this.
Okay, I'm following.
No, stay, stay, stay.
You stay, you stay.
You stay.
Alright, alright.
I threw a nade behind them.
Two seconds.
Come, come, my way.
I killed one inside.
90 on him.
You killed him.
No, he's one.
Come to us.
Come, come, come.
Oh my god, he was one HP.
He's getting pushed right now.
He's just killed two guys.
Try and stop fighting.
Run up.
Oh no, he's getting shit at.
Squad wipe!
What the fuck?
What happened over there?
What happened?
No, don't, don't.
What the fuck?
Wait, you cooked?
Oh my god, what happened?
Oh my god.
What happened?
What'd you do?
I don't even know what happened over there.
Redemption arc!
Redemption!
To be fair, like...
Like what happened over there?
Oh my god, who the fuck did I kill?
I don't even know.
I fucked up though.
I whiffed my master shot.
I whiffed one shot and then it fucked us over.
I whiffed the shot that would've killed them.
Oh my god.
That was crazy.
I guess we're gonna have to go tomorrow.
Guys, guys.
You have to send the message, man.
Oh wait, I'll edit it.
Don't worry, I'll edit it.
I whiffed my one massive shot.
I'll train after this, I promise.
I'll train.
I whiffed my one shot that would've killed that team.
My bad.
Look, we all had clutch moments in each game, guys.
We all had clutch moments.
Look, that's your character arc.
You grew as a player from that.
Isn't that insane?
Oh my god, they took over our house.
It's free real estate now.
Hey, at least they have zero meds from us.
Oh, but you killed a team with meds!
Nevermind.
You literally killed a team that had meds.
I think if we stayed in that house, we could've maybe...
We could've just took over the other...
Oh no, but then this team would've pushed us.
Nevermind.
Did you 1v3, Gerard?
Yeah.
Wow!
Yeah, they were all coupled up inside.
I started spraying.
You just started spraying?
Oh my god, that's crazy!
Thank god I didn't run after you, because they were just waiting.
That's why I said you have to stay there.
Yeah, that was a nice call.
I would've just fucking ran.
Well, I was surprised that you ran in the open right after without healing yourself.
I didn't know what to do!
I was lost!
You had so much adrenaline inside you, you ran right after the open!
That was crazy!
Well, I thought I should go for your stuff!
You could've full healed, bro!
You could've full healed!
I'm sorry.
No, no, no, you did great though.
That was insane.
That was insane, that 1v3.
Tomorrow, tomorrow.
I'll do better.
That was actually crazy.
I will never...
It would've been nicer if we had top 10 at least.
I'm sorry.
I think it was also my fault that I dropped a bunch of my batteries that I could've gotten.
But yeah, it was...
No, it's fine.
You just gotta be faster.
You got picked because you were the last one running and you were so far from us that we couldn't help you.
So you just gotta be faster in your rotations.
Okay, okay.
That's really it.
You gotta be there.
You had to be there.
I think the biggest mistake at the end there was not just all three sending that hot hug.
Yeah, definitely what we should've done.
Because two teams ended up fighting for that house.
Like for our house as soon as we left.
We would still be fine and we can take a roof.
This team is playing roof now.
We just need to not...
I didn't know two teams ran for the house.
That's why Gerard managed to get three kills.
They were fighting each other.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's crazy.
I should've thrown a nade too.
I could've thrown a nade in there with you.
I was just like, I'm just gonna go in.
You're going in, I don't wanna go in too.
If I threw a nade in there, I think that would've helped us.
Because I had like...
They ran to the other side of the wall, I think.
And then ran back in.
I don't think it would've made too much of a difference.
Yeah, but it would've like, cluttered...
Made them in a corner more.
We had to fight two rampart walls there.
Which was a struggle.
I was in a struggle bus there.
Oh my god, wait!
You're right, Chad!
From 14 damage to 3 digits?
I'll see you guys here for international scrims.
Oh yeah, you have international scrims literally in a couple of minutes.
Literally right now.
From this to international scrims, good luck!
Yeah, I mean you're warmed up, right?
Is it still Apex?
Yeah, that's international scrims.
No, he's gone.
He's literally gone.
He's really gone!
He had to go to international scrims right now!
He's gone!
His last playthrough was with us!
No, he's gonna feel more motivated and he's like, I'm sorry I ever yelled at you guys.
He's gonna be like, I'm sorry team.
You guys are the best I ever got.
I'm sorry I ever yelled at you guys.
I now know how hard it is to play with other people.
Yeah, it is.
It is very hard, I could tell.
I think he had fun though.
Of course I did, of course!
Jesus Christ, I don't know what you guys are gatekeeping Apex for, but I think it's a really great game.
I invited you!
You were like, don't go down to this path.
I'm sort of interested in this because you guys are so awesome.
You're interested in the tournament side?
I mean...
No, we weren't gatekeeping the tournament.
We're gatekeeping being addicted.
Yeah, that one!
I definitely want to keep playing.
This is different.
I literally didn't even...
I could play more Apex to get...
I honestly don't think playing more Apex for me right now would actually change the result.
I'm still playing the best as I could.
Oh...
I'm just like, the mistakes I make it's just awareness in terms of like I laugh and then they run to me.
Like, it's just that.
I mean, for me.
I think...
I'd really love to take interest in this one because I've had a lot of fun.
Yeah, it's like different.
It's definitely a lot different from regular.
Yeah, definitely not from tournaments.
No, no way.
No, I get it.
Yeah, but I don't know if I'm going to be playing Apex at all, like literally after this.
Like, Jesus, I still have to play like a Marvels.
Oh yeah, there's just so many stuff to do.
Bro, it's just Mastiff, Mastiff, Mastiff everywhere.
Well, three squads remaining.
I think this is it.
Well, okay.
That's it.
That's it, everybody.
I wonder what placement we got.
I know we definitely not got 20th because we got two kills.
We're not 20th place.
And technically, we did get top five.
We got top five.
You're right, you're right.
Just remember the top five part.
You did.
You went through a character arc.
I did, I know.
You started off with 14 damage.
Wait, no, you started off with zero damage.
You started off with zero damage.
And now you got 322 damage and three kills.
And you got in one game.
Dude, actually getting coached on stream was so fucking cool.
Both of you were like, no, you gotta put it here.
When you guys were coaching me putting stuff there, I'd be like, oh shit, so this is how you do shit.
I used to be doing the opposite of things.
I was just like, I'm just going to be pulling up in this and never thinking about anything.
The amount of ammo that I've been picking up, I didn't think about the resource management of that.
You have to be quicker now, though, too.
You have to figure out how to be quick on certain things.
Yeah, for real.
I'm not going to lie, I think I might play more after stream.
I'm feeling adrenaline because I feel like we could be a higher rank squad.
I think there's an awakening.
Literally in just six hours, you learned so much in six hours.
Wait, we've been playing for six hours and that wasn't four?
No, we've been playing for six hours.
I just want you to know, you're a bronze player.
You've killed Pred players.
As a bronze player, because you're 1v3, right?
Every team here has at least one Pred player.
So you killed a Pred player as a bronze.
Stop!
Shut the fuck up!
No, you did!
You did!
If they knew you were a bronze player, they would be so embarrassed right now.
Okay, I can't even brag about this in public now because they would be fucking killing me!
Oh my god!
I don't want to bring an animosity!
I didn't even know who I killed!
Are they even chill with bronze players being here?
Gerard, you literally killed your... in that game we won championship, we killed your senpai and you were bronze.
Senpai, oh my god!
Oh no!
Guys, do any of the holostars make it to the winner's bracket?
Oh wait, we'll figure that out in three minutes.
Yeah, we'll figure that out in three minutes.
Goddamn!
Because you could be... I don't know if Astel and... I know there's two holostars members, right?
In there?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, Fuma and Astel.
I don't know, did you see Fuma in here?
No, I was like in streamer mode.
Everyone was like on default names.
Wait, I mean, I could literally check if... we'll just check if they're streaming still.
No!
Because you could be...
you made it to winner's bracket.
Like, just think about that.
You literally made it to winner's bracket.
Probably the only holostars that made it to the winner's bracket.
I don't want to think about that.
Oh my god!
You made it...
Fuma didn't make it to winner's bracket.
Fuma didn't make it.
Wait, did Astel not make it too?
Wait, are you kidding me?
Wait, no, Astel's not streaming it.
Astel's not streaming it.
He didn't stream it.
I don't know if he streamed it on Twitch, but he streamed a different Apex tournament.
But you did it!
As a bronze player!
That's pretty impressive!
As a bronze player?
That's really impressive!
I think I painted a massive target on my back.
Like, losing to...
I don't know, but I have a bad feeling about this.
I mean, we literally got champions during group A, so...
I hope they realize that I was only being carried by two of you.
Like, Flame and you, you guys were carrying the shit out of me.
Like, I have no part in this.
If they're gonna be angry at me...
Fuma-senpai, listen to me!
She and him were carrying me!
I'm not the one doing the shots!
They're literally puppeting me!
I didn't do anything!
Like, majority of my plays here are all based on their decisions.
Not my fault!
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
But not my fault!
I'm just making a public statement right now before anyone attacks me.
Oh, we got 15!
That's not bad!
15 in the winner's bracket!
Yeah, that's actually pretty decent for winners.
The only way for us to get top 10 was actually winning that game.
We actually needed to win that game to get top 10.
I think it was a very impossible chance because it was literally the last game.
So everyone had to lock in.
I mean, we have tomorrow.
We have tomorrow now.
Are you excited?
I think we're going to win a lot tomorrow.
Are you going to practice?
Yeah, I'm going to practice literally a lot.
Are we still going to go with the Rampart build?
I think Rampart works the best.
The walls are really good.
Just figure out Rampart walls.
Walling is not that hard.
It's literally just wall the doors and wall our angles.
Okay.
I'm going to be watching a bunch of streams and videos.
The only thing I think you need to improve on is just looting.
You literally need to loot faster.
You don't need to stand still when you drop stuff.
Oh yeah, you're right.
You can't run when you drop things.
Running on just general knowledge.
You can run and then press tab while you're running and drop stuff while you're running.
I still have this habit of checking death boxes and just standing still.
You should be strafing, right?
But I still can't help it.
I cannot focus at all.
I guess I have to practice.
God damn, I have to practice on a bunch of stuff.
I guess I have to cancel one stream for a tournament.
Yes, I'm making an army school app.
I'm sorry.
I'm gonna...
No!
Don't cancel the army!
I'm sorry.
They should understand.
What's a fake here is way more important.
No, I'm not responsible for this.
I'm begging him to not cancel the armist collab.
They understand.
I'm their leader.
Don't cancel the armist collab.
You can fit too.
Yes, you are not a part of this.
This is my executive decision.
At least make them play Apex with you.
Just make them play Apex with you.
I will...
No, because there's only three and I don't want to exclude one more.
Wait, Astel didn't make it to the winners.
What?
He didn't make it to the winners.
Wait, really?
So he's gonna be in the elimination bracket.
Oh, shit!
So you're literally the only holostars that made it to the winners bracket.
I was scared so hard!
What the fuck?
You actually made it!
I made it!
We made it!
Not me!
But we have to do this again.
We have to do it again though.
How heavy was I?
On a scale of 1 to 10, how heavy was I?
No, you were doing your learning.
The first two games was rough.
It was very rough.
But then after that you started picking up.
We really did not have any sort of...
We don't know the chemistry.
I was feeling things out.
How do I play with him?
Is the thing.
I only play with casuals.
All you have to do is just listen.
You just listen to what he says.
You don't hesitate.
You just listen to your IGL.
Unless you know better than him.
But I don't know better than him.
So I'm not fucking gonna argue.
That's actually good fucking advice.
He literally has the most knowledge and you literally just listen to what he says.
Just keep going.
Just follow his orders.
You also need to listen to because when we run away you ran into it.
I mean...
That was the first one, right?
And then after that you started listening more.
You started listening more, which is good.
Yeah, yeah, which is really nice.
So I'm gonna be doing exactly all of this.
I'm gonna accumulate everything that I've learned here.
And you're not cancelling the Aramis collab.
I will.
I need to sleep.
Yesterday I streamed for 11 hours and after 11 hours I saw your fucking DM.
Like, you wanna play tomorrow?
Like, which tomorrow?
Is it Saturday or Friday?
Technically it's my tomorrow.
It's been four hours.
What the fuck?
Four hours?!
You could have said no.
Because I assume...
Oh, so Saturday.
And okay.
I told you the hours.
I was like, it's in 14 hours.
I saw same time and my brain processed like, so 11pm.
I still have time.
It's in 14 hours.
That's like less than 24.
It's like less than 24.
Okay, that was my bad.
Okay, you should go to sleep now.
You should really go to sleep now.
Alright, I won't keep you anymore.
Go to sleep, man.
GGs.
Thanks for joining me.
Thank you for playing with me.
Thank you.
Bye.
This is three minutes.
So like, I'm gonna call it here, everybody.
We streamed for six hours today.
This was supposed to be a rest week.
But tomorrow, we'll be back with more ASGS, which is basically ALGS for VTubers and others.
I had a great time.
It was great playing with Flame and Gerard.
It was my first time playing games with them.
Well, it was my first time actually meeting Flame.
I've always wanted to play with Flame.
Ever since I watched the ALGS and how well his team did.
And I know a lot of people were super impressed with his team back then.
And I've always wanted to play with Flame a long time ago.
During the before times.
And I was so happy that Flame was super down playing with me.
And you guys didn't know, Tenjin was originally supposed to be part of my team before my points got recalculated.
Because my team was too good.
So because of that my points were considered still pred level.
Even though I was like, I haven't been pred for 4 years.
I think it's also because I was bragging about how I got top 500 in Marvel Rivals.
So he took that too.
I think they saw that too.
And was like, oh she clearly still has the FPS skills.
So my points got re-evaluated and everything to be a lot higher.
So I couldn't get Tenjin because he got his diamond and our point threshold was gold and under.
I could not find literally could not find silver or gold players.
Silver or gold players.
It was either a player that's never played before or like players who are at best the lowest I could find was plat and bronze.
It was plat or bronze.
And I literally could not find anybody.
So that's why I didn't open call.
And then somebody in chat, I saw someone reply and was like, you should totally get Jirard.
And I was like, oh my god, what a great, I should ask Jirard.
Because I've asked so many people and Jirard never came up to me because I never had an actual collab with Jirard before, other than like WrestleTuber.
And so I was like, oh my god that's a great idea.
He was really funny during the Apex custom.
I thought that like, you know, as a tournament, that's more of like for fun and just like fucking around type deal.
Oh wait, not fucking around, but to like make it so it's not that serious.
Like, I know it's a serious tournament.
I mean, we totally got top five, even though like with it we weren't, we were like, we locked in during when it matters, but it was more so like you we lock in and have fun at the same time.
So like, my goal was to make sure it's like, you know, fun but also serious too when it needed to be.
Because I didn't want to be like super duper duper serious and also I couldn't fucking find a player that's silver or gold.
And I'm pretty sure if I had a gold player like mechanically gold player especially like, oh my god, especially when season whatever that season was that inflated everybody's SR like that inflated everybody's RP, like it was almost, it was impossible finding an actual mechanical gold player like that I know of like so he shouted to Gerard for willing to step up very last minute.
I was like are you even allowed to like join this tournament within, with like, you know like 14 hours notice and then he's like yeah, no, it's fine.
So like he shouted to Gerard for like hopping in super last minute literally like 14 hours before the stream, the tournament was about to start and just like playing with us and he shouted straight flame for being my IGL and just like holding our hands and telling us what to do I like that actually helped a lot really good IGL,
he's an incredible IGL which is why I literally was like cause like it was either like cause I I had to make a really tough choice of either replacing Flame or replacing Tenjin and like it was, I was like I wanted to have an IGL because I am like hopeless without an IGL and like I told Tenjin,
if I have another tournament invite, like I will get him in there and then I
so so like cause like obviously I can get tournament I can try and get another tournament invite in and so so so like I had to go with an IGL because like I don't know what to do without an IGL I'm so fucking lost and I know this is like a super serious tournament as well so like so like you know We did our best and we did really well.
I was very happy with how well we did.
I never really expected to get into winner's bracket, so I'm super happy that we did get into the winner's bracket there.
Gerard's literally playing with 300 ping and same with... Gerard's playing with 300 ping and same with Flame apparently sometimes.
So I was just like, oh my god, how did we make it this far?
Literally, the times we died was just unlucky.
Unlucky timing.
We literally got timed.
Valorant, when you get timing, we literally just got timed because of it.
I'm just really happy that despite so many odds against us, we were still able to do so well.
Anyway, thank you so much for the support.
That is my reflection of today.
I originally was actually not going to be in the Sloppy Sisters collab.
I didn't see the group message because I was in my semi-break, so I was not catching up on my messages or anything.
I saw it super last minute yesterday.
I thought I couldn't do it because I was like, oh man, I'm really tired.
I'm going to still show up for the Sloppy Sisters collab because I thought I had a convention today, too.
Also, Tempo, you are not a gold... I know you're masters.
I know you're fucking masters, Tempo.
Also, bro, international scrims are out.
Flame literally left to go to international scrims.
What the fuck?
I literally saw that message from Flame where he's like, I'm the gold player.
I literally saw your fucking ranking stream where you're trying to get to a masters in 24 hours.
Shit, where was I?
Oh my god, it's a three minute delay, so I'll never know where I was at in the conversation.
I'll never know.
Oh yeah, so I thought it was just too much because I thought I had a convention right after, but I think it'll be fine.
I thought it was a convention on the same day, but it should be fine because my convention is actually on...
I'm going to be at Holiday Matsuri tomorrow on the 21st, so I have a meet and greet and a panel, so that's going to be on the 21st.
And Friday I'll be at the Sloppy Sisters collab, and then I'm going to sleep or play Marvel Rivals, depending on how fucked up I am mentally regarding my addiction.
It just depends on how it's going to go later today.
And then after that, we go straight to... we go to sleep before the turn... oh, I mean it's at 3.
Day 2 is at 3.
Elimination round is at 3am PST, I believe.
Let me double check.
I think it is.
I have to look at the scheduling again.
Yeah, it's at 3.30am PST, so we're just going to be there at 3.30am PST for tomorrow.
And then after that, it's Sloppy Sisters collab, rest, 3.30am tournament, Holiday Matsuri stuff, and then we make it to the finals, and I guess more Apex.
Oh my god, remember when I said I was going to take a break?
Well then, whoa!
But yeah, like I said, I didn't realize that Mint asked for a collab until the day before the collab was going to start.
And then I was like, guys, I'm so sorry.
I just saw this message.
I don't think I can make it.
But I can make it now.
I can make it now because it's not as bad as I thought.
I was like, I have to do a convention right after and then back to the tournament, but now it's like tournament, collab, tournament, convention.
Tournament, we make it.
If we don't, then that's fine.
Anyway, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing, and if you're up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Also, yeah, before I say bye, if you guys didn't know, there is Phantom Thief concert merch is up for pre-orders.
And my mods can put those links there when I say this because it's going to be so weird when I post a link to the Phantom Thief pre-order merch, concert merch.
So even if you guys didn't go to the concert, you can still grab the merch.
I just thought it was weird that... I thought it was weird if I post it now and then you're going to be like, what's the fucking context?
And then so my mods can post a link for me when I say this.
Anyway, guys, bye, everybody.
Bye.